Das, was sich heute in der Metaebene abgespielt hat, erinnert so ziemlich an den Plot eines Katastrophenfilms. Clemens explodiert laut knallend und erzeugt eine gigantische Druckwelle. In sechs Städten krachen Mauern ein, zerbärsten Fensterscheiben und über 1000 Menschen werden von den herumfliegenden Gegenständen verletzt. Andrea Reimoser-Feitsch über diesen bildstarken Ausnahmemoment in der Metaebene.
Apple hat sich aus Designgründen entschieden, den Lightning-Connector unten anzubringen, die Pen. Statt vorne, dass man das scheiß Kabel da reinstecken könnte und dann hätte man ne Wired-Maus, wo Bluetooth nicht geht. Ja, zum Beispiel im Flieger oder so was, wo das nicht benutzen darf.
Die Bewohner der Millionenstadt Tseljabinsk trauen ihren Augen nicht. So mancher denkt, ein Flugzeug sei explodiert. Andere rechnen mit noch schlimmeren, glauben gar an den Weltuntergang. Es folgt eine gewaltige Druckwelle, von der nicht nur diese Kinder beim Tränen im Turnsaal überrascht werden. Als ich hereingekommen bin, waren alle Fenster zerbrochen. Überall nur Scherben.
Plötzlich gab es eine Explosion.
Das Glas ist zersplittert und hat mich getocht.
Hunderte Menschen müssen ärztlich versorgt werden. Sie haben Schnittwunden und Prellungen erlitten. Tausende Gebäude sind beschädigt. Bei Temperaturen von minus 18 Grad wiegen zur Boston die Fenster besonders schwer.
Kein Echo. Hast du das eigentlich drin gelassen in der Sendung?
Warst das Echo?
Unser Pre-Show letztes Mal? Oder hast du das rausgeschnitten?
Pre-Show?
Unser Echo-Pre-Show.
Ich hab wirklich nochmal von vorne angefangen. Ich hab's mir ein bisschen angehört, es war ein bisschen zu confused und man muss ja auch für eine gewisse Konsistenz, also, nicht? Die Hörer erwarten ja eine, ähm, wie soll ich sagen?
Qualität.
Qualität, genau, die Hörer erwarten Qualität und...
Ja, aber das war doch von ganz besonderer Qualität.
Ja, vielleicht.
Na ja, alle erwarten Qualität, aber wir sind trotzdem wieder auf Sendung. Genau, jetzt nehme ich die Freak Show, Nummer 164.
Freak Delicious.
Genau, Clemens glüht noch ein wenig nach und ist von daher nicht da. Der muss erst vom Katastrophenteam wieder aus den Einzelteilen zusammengesetzt werden.
Das kann noch ein bisschen dauern.
Aber der Rest ist da.
Dennis ist da.
Wo weit. Wenn immer alles klappt, dann wird es auch schnell langweilig.
Jetzt komme ich gar nicht so richtig rein.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Das ist das Problem. Wir können ja gleich einfach mit Podcasting anfangen.
Ich bin schon müde.
Nein, nein, Mami, ich bin schon müde. Nee, los, erzähl jetzt was von Podcasting.
Soll ich?
Ja, komm, jetzt holen wir noch Frischsinn.
Geht ja schnell, oder?
Ja, also ja, im Prinzip schon, aber nur unter einer Bedingung.
Wenn der Hörer jetzt gesehen hätte, wie der jetzt in der Liste dieses Podcasting, was ganz hinten war, so ganz dezent gerade, mit einem Schwung, so ganz nach vorne kopiert, das ja sagt eigentlich alles.
Wieso, was sagt denn das alles?
Dass das Thema eigentlich gar nicht hinten war. Dass du das immer so von hinten reinschmuggelst. Man sieht das gar nicht, das ist so außerhalb des Bildschirms, weil außerhalb des Scrollbereichs und dann zack ist es ganz vorne.
Außerhalb des Scrollbereichs.
Du erregst die Freak Show berichtet. Außerhalb des, ja genau, von außerhalb des Scrollbereichs. Du erwächst gerade den Eindruck, dass wir hier irgendwie immer wohlstrukturiert an den Start gehen. Na ja, es geht so.
In unseren Köpfen zumindest. Jeder für sich.
Gut, na ja meistens wird es dann doch Plan B.
Plan B? Ja, das wird sich schon wieder ein bisschen antreten, aber es gibt in der Tat einfach ein paar Dinge, die man vielleicht mal vorweg stellen sollte, die im weiteren Sinne den Bereich Podcasting betreffen. Und das fing nämlich damit an, dass ich letzte Woche wieder mal alles kaputt gemacht habe. Na ja, weißt ja, wie das ist.
Wenn zu viel Entropie, also nee, mal wieder ein bisschen Entropie sorgen, wenn sich alles zu sehr...
Ohne Änderungen kein Fortschritt. Also das ist halt einfach... ist halt so.
Und ohne Änderungen auch kein Rückschritt.
Ja, naja gut, ich würde sagen, ein Rückschritt stellt sich eigentlich so von alleine ein. Durch Nachlässigkeit und dann fädelt man halt einfach so aus.
Na ja gut, wo vorne ist, ist sowieso noch mal Definitionssache, aber das nur am Rande.
Ja, naja gut, also das lassen wir mal offen.
Ich versuche ja schon immer ein bisschen weiter vorne zu sein. Nicht, dass mir das jetzt immer gelingt. Tatsache ist, dass es beim Podcasting und vor allem bei den Podcasts der Meta-Ebene so ein Problem gibt. Es gibt ja so durchaus so Shows, wo die Leute dann auch gerne mal wieder früher anfangen wollen. Sagen wir mal, jemand hört jetzt das erste Mal diese Sendung und ist total begeistert. Warum hab ich nicht Show und Side, Inside Number of Years hier, davon gehört und so. Und viele wollen dann natürlich auch ältere Sendungen hören. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr besonders, so eine News getragenen Sache wie Freak Show nicht so sehr, aber so der E-Interview-Podcast. Aber wie auch immer, man möchte ja gerne allen einen guten Zugriff auf das Archiv bieten. Nun ist das aber nicht so einfach, weil ja Podcasts über RSS-Feeds ausgeliefert werden und RSS-Feeds tendieren halt dann dazu, immer größer zu werden, umso mehr Sendungen sie enthalten. Was jetzt vielleicht so erstmal auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so ein Problem sein kann. Textartal im Internet, was kann schon passieren? Genau. Von der Übertragung her ist das alles zu machen und das ist auch mal von der Serverlast her alles noch zu machen. Aber wenn ich halt jetzt, was weiß ich hier, das ganze CRE-Archiv, wenn ich jetzt für jede Sendung die vollen Show-Notes mit drin habe, also die ganzen Beschreibungen, alles was sozusagen im Feed drin steht, und dann halt 208 Sendungen in diesem Feed gebe, dann kommt dann halt so eine 5 Megabyte-Datei raus.
Ungesippt.
Ungesippt. Genau.
Also wie gesagt, Übertragung ist ja nicht das Problem. Das Problem entsteht beim Kunden. Beim Kunden, weil der Feed allein macht das ja noch nicht, sondern der will ja auch gelesen und gepaarzt und interpretiert werden. Und da entstehen dann halt schon mal so Probleme, weil die Zahl von Podcast-Client-Developern, die jetzt so mit 5 Megabyte XML-Feeds testen, scheint ja überschaubar zu sein. Na ja, eigentlich will man halt alle Sendungen da drin haben. Andererseits will man aber auch nicht wirklich jetzt bei jedem Feedrequest immer 5 Megabyte rausgeben. Gut, da hilft einem der Server, man kann halt irgendwie zippen, man kann auch immer sagen, nee, hat sich nicht geändert, seit dem letzten Mal behalte einfach deine Kopie etc. Diese ganzen Mechanismen sind ja auch in Kraft, bleiben immer noch eine ganze Menge Leute. Weiß ich nicht, das ist jetzt auch unerheblich. Weil erheblich ist, was es sozusagen nach dem Zippen ist. Wie viele Elemente es enthält, wie komplex es ist. Aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal auf die eigentliche Problematik hin. Das heißt, grundsätzlich macht man es eigentlich so, dass man eben diesen Feed rausgibt und sagt, okay, hier sind nur die letzten Sendungen drin. Aber damit gibt es dann natürlich keinen unmittelbaren Zugriff auf alte Sendungen. Jetzt, um jetzt diese Last generell schon mal gering zu halten, benutzen Podcaster und auch andere Blogger gerne solche Feed-Proxy-Dienste, wie zum Beispiel Feedburner von Google. Was ursprünglich ja mal nicht von Google war, sondern das war ja mal so eine kleine aufstrebende Unternehmung, die gesagt haben, hier Feeds gibt es für uns und so. Und dann haben die da so ein paar Modifikationen reingemacht und können dann darüber Analytics machen und dann hast du immer einen schönen Subscriber-Account, wie viele unterschiedliche Geräte oder Programme saugen sich denn das Ding regelmäßig. Und du hast halt auch nicht mehr die Last auf diesem Server. Nur kamen sie dann halt mit so merkwürdigen Limitierungen, wie dein Feed darf nicht größer als ein halbes Megabyte sein. Und wenn er das ist, dann hören wir einfach auf, den zu aktualisieren und wir sagen dir aber auch nicht Bescheid. Weil, we don't care.
Wo kämen wir da hin?
Wo kämen wir denn da hin, wenn wir da irgendwie ein umfangreiches Angebot machen. Wäre sicherlich ein Feature-Request, was mittelfristig bei Feedburner auch durchgegangen wäre, hätte Google das nicht gekauft und das Interesse generell an RSS ein wenig verloren. Das scheint sich jetzt übrigens geändert zu haben, dazu komme ich auch gleich nochmal. Tatsache war, wenn man sowas benutzt, das ist schon mal Einzwang, den Feed klein zu halten. Und damit passen halt nicht mehr alle Sendungen rein. Das waren wir bei PodLav ja ganz klug und haben mal so ein bisschen durchs Internet geblättert und sehe da, es gibt da einen Standard, der nennt sich Paged Feeds. Also der ganz unabhängig von Podcasting ist, der einfach nur sagt, naja, du willst so einen kleinen Subscription Feed, dafür haben wir Verständnis. Aber warum schreibst du nicht hier einfach in den Headers noch die Informationen mit rein? Weitere Einträge gibt es unter dieser URL und dann verweist du quasi auf Seite 2 dieses Feeds, was dann nochmal ein separater Request ist und dann lieferst du die nächsten Sendungen ab und dann kommt noch eine Page und noch eine Page und noch eine Page, bis dann irgendwann Ende ist.
Eigentlich ganz sinnvolles Vorgehen.
Eigentlich ganz sinnvolles Vorgehen, deswegen haben wir das auch in den Podlove Publisher eingebaut und jeder, der irgendwie mit Podlove publiziert hat, hat sozusagen Paged Feeds out of the box. Fett! Selbst wenn du sagst, hier mein Feed hat nur 10 Einträge, dann sind automatisch immer alle alten Sendungen auch über Pages da. Jetzt kennt ihr natürlich das Problem mit dem Internet, nur weil irgendjemand eine gute Idee hat. Heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass auch alle gleich aufspringen auf diesen Zug. Und so war Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten und das haben wir dann auch teilweise geschafft. So hat zum Beispiel der Martin Hering das in Instacast eingebaut und siehe da, auf einmal hatten alle unblimitierten Zugriff auf das Archiv und alle waren glücklich und die Sonne schien und die Vögel entzwitzerten. Alles wurde gut und niemand hatte mehr ein Problem. Abgesehen davon, dass natürlich andere Leute auch manchmal andere Podcast-Clients benutzen, sowas wie die Podcast-App von Apple, ihr wisst schon, und diese ganzen anderen auch, die natürlich alle nicht Pagefeeds unterstützen, bis weniger Ausnahmen. Also ich glaube, Antennapod auf Android hat es. Also so ein paar haben es halt eingebaut. Ich würde sagen, so alle deutschen Clients, die so halbwegs mit uns klarkommen, haben das halt einfach mal eingebaut, weil sie das für eine gute Sache gehalten haben und mal ehrlich, so schwierig ist es auch nicht. Also man muss halt seine Logik beim Feedparsen ein bisschen dahingehend erweitern, dass man sagt, es gibt da nicht nur eine Datei, sondern kommen unter Umständen noch mehrere. Das heißt, man muss da nochmal eine Schleife drumherum bauen, die quasi über mehrere Downloads iteriert.
Dazu kommen wir ja dann in unserem nächsten Themenkomplex auf, wie man das genau baut.
Den Feed zu parsen ist sowieso mit das größte Problem, das du da hast.
Äh, ja, genau.
Also aber es ist eigentlich unabhängig davon, wie groß dieser Feed ist. Stimmt natürlich jetzt auch wieder nicht, weil Speicherverbrauch und so weiter. Hat sich aber gezeigt, dass das eigentlich so dieses Häppchenweise parsen gar nicht so blöd war. Weil man hatte immer eine kleine Page, die so zehn Einträge hat, die wurde dann irgendwie gepasst, neue Episoden wurden in die Liste reingeschmissen, dann kam die nächste Datei, wurde gepasst und so weiter. Und so baute sich das halt langsam auf. Kann vielleicht eine Weile dauern. Aber man muss halt, wenn man jetzt nach einer neuen Folge guckt, eigentlich auch immer nur diesen kleinen Subscription-Feed ziehen und eben nicht das alte Archiv immer wieder neu aktualisieren. Vielleicht nur, wenn man so ein Deep Refresh macht oder so.
Naja, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, Apis rund um die Welt, die haben alle irgendwie, wenn da mehr Zeug kommt, sind die alle paged. Wo du dann so und so viele Items bekommst und dann musst du halt sagen, ich will jetzt Seite zwei haben. Also load more ist ja jetzt auch keine neue Erfindung.
Also es ist so.
Kannst du dann am User Agent unterscheiden, ob der Client auf der anderen Seite das schon unterstützt oder nicht?
Das könnte man tun, wenn die User Agents mal immer so genau sagen würden, wer sie sind.
Aber die schummeln natürlich auch alle, so wie bei den Browsern auch.
Genau, da gibt es dann so Podcast Clients, die sagen, ja hallo, hier ich bin's, was haben sie sich immer ausgegeben als iTunes und so. Genau, wie das eben so ist bei User Agents. Naja, und die Rufe nach Archivzugriff rissen nicht ab und ich will ja eigentlich auch, dass Leute auf alte Raumzeitfolgen problemlos in ihrem Podcast-Line zugreifen können.
Freak Show nicht so, aber Raumzeit.
Freak Show nicht so und ja klar, weil mal ehrlich, also das mag mal aus kulturell, Forschungsgründen ganz interessant sein.
Wer will sich schon die alten Rants über Nokia anhören?
Naja, manche Leute tun das. Ich kriege immer mal wieder so Tweets um die Ohren. Das finde ich auch eigentlich ganz cool. Gerade was so unsere Predictions betrifft. Ja, teilweise gut waren und teilweise katastrophal daneben lagen. Na ja, gut, auf jeden Fall bin ich dann so ein bisschen eingeknickt und dachte mir so, okay, dann lasse ich irgendwie nichts. Nix wird mit den Pagefeeds. Wie schaffe ich, dass das alle das kriegen? Und dann war irgendwie erstmal klar, was mir eigentlich auch schon länger klar war, Feedburner muss überwunden werden, weil mit Feedburner geht halt gar nichts voran. Und es ist halt auch so wie Google Reader so ein Produkt, wo man so ein bisschen Angst hat, dass sie das morgen abschalten. Gibt wohl einen Grund, warum sie das noch nicht getan haben, dazu komme ich auch gleich nochmal. Wie auch immer, es gibt alternative Dienste und ich bin dann auf Feedpress gegangen. Feedpress ist so ein Dienst, den gibt es jetzt gefühlt seit einem... Feed.press, genau. Gibt seit zwei Jahren ungefähr den Dienst und das ist halt im Prinzip dasselbe wie FeedBunner, aber eben mal komplett neu gecodet und von coolen Leuten, die ansprechbar sind und auch auf E-Mail antworten und so. Das ist ja schon mal was wert. Ja und dann habe ich einfach mal alle meine Feeds umgezogen, was für mich mehrere Vorteile hat. Also erstmal habe ich Ansprechpartner, zweitens sieht es so aus, als ob das Ding über die Zeit Features bekommt, drittens man darf da Geld bezahlen, das heißt man ist auch Kunde. Also ich zahle da vier Dollar im Monat, das passt schon. Und die bieten übrigens auch zusätzliches Podcast-Hosting noch an, aber dann muss man nochmal acht Dollar pro Monat dazuwerfen, habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert. Aber auf jeden Fall ist mal meine Feeds drin und es gibt hier nicht so dusselige Limitierungen mit der Größe. Das heißt jetzt konnte ich halt meine Feeds auch größer machen. Da dachte ich mir so, ha, mache ich doch einfach mal meine Feeds größer.
Hast du einmal alle Podcast-Show's in Deutschland gedostet?
Ja, na ja und mich auch.
Und eine halbe Stunde später.
Mich auch. Du hast dich gedostet tatsächlich?
Ja, ja, weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich, ich hätte es natürlich besser wissen müssen, aber wir sind immer so, es sind solche Momente, man ist in so einer Euphorie. Ja, ich gebe es euch, was ihr schon immer haben wolltet.
Das nackte Metallene Podcast Archiv.
Genau, und habe dann einfach mal so Feed von irgendwie nur zehn Folgen auf, pack mal alle rein, umgestellt so bei CAE und dachte, ja, das sieht ja ganz gut aus. Hab das dann so ein bisschen getestet und ging so. Ich glaube, ich habe nicht mit CAE angefangen, ich habe mit irgendwas anderem angefangen. Und ja, dann habe ich das noch bei zwei, drei anderen auch noch gemacht, Freak Show und noch ein paar andere, dachte so, ja, jetzt, Full Throttle. Ja, und dann wurde es langsam ein bisschen haarig, weil ich weiß mir ja ganz genau, womit es anfing, aber die ersten Reports waren so was wie, oh mein Kleiner stürzt ab. Also Podcast-App zum Beispiel, also jeder, der CAE abonniert hat, dem habe ich halt einfach mal die Podcast-App remote exploded sozusagen. Ein Remote Explode. Genau, und ja, da wusste ich dann schon so, okay, das war jetzt vielleicht nicht so eine gute Idee. Also so fünf Megabyte hat er nicht er tragen. Zwei oder drei gingen irgendwie noch. Und dann gab es aber auch Berichte von verschiedenen anderen Clients, Overcars und so weiter. Und dann wusste ich schon so, okay, alles klar, das bringt jetzt irgendwie gar nichts. Hab das dann auch relativ schnell wieder ausgeschaltet, aber das hat ja dann alles immer so extreme Nachwirkungen, weil wenn der Feed erstmal gezogen ist, dann gibt es so Spezialisten wie Antennapod zum Beispiel. Das mögen auch noch andere Clients gemacht haben. Ich habe jetzt nur konkret davon gehört. Wenn die halt jetzt den Feed checken und dann tauchen, dann neue alte Folgen auf oder da tauchen dann alte Folgen auf, die vorher nicht da waren, dann sieht der Client die als neu an. Und wenn der Client halt eingestellt ist, wenn eine neue Folge ist, dann laden sie auch mal runter. Da haben dann diese Podcast-Clients angefangen, 200 CAE-Folgen parallel runterzuladen und das Ganze dann halt mal 30.000 Subscriber.
Die 8 Dollar vielleicht doch investieren sollen.
Ja, in der Tat. Und dann sah ich halt schon so die ersten, ja nee hier und drei Kilobyte pro Sekunde und nichts kommt mehr und webplayer geht nicht. Was kann denn da jetzt falsch sein? Hab das auch erst gar nicht mit meinen ganzen Featsachen zusammengebracht. Guck so mit Observium auf meinen Server und ein Megabit, da ist ja noch viel Luft. Ich kann doch ein Gigabit, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Bis mir dann irgendwie klar wurde, dass ich einfach wahrscheinlich viel zu viele Requests gleichzeitig habe, dass da wahrscheinlich gerade so so Abertausende von Connections auf diesen Server einschlagen und ich dann halt so meinen Lighty drauf habe, der so mit, keine Ahnung, 24 Prozessen noch…
Ja.
Was soll ich denn da vorhaben?
Was schnell ist?
Der Lighty ist schnell.
Nee, hast du ja gerade gesagt.
Wenn er mal lädt, dann ist er super schnell.
Wenn er mal. Du hast gerade gesagt, irgendwie war nicht ausgenutzt, 100 MBit und du hast ein Gigabit. Das heißt, er hat zehn Prozent von deiner Bandbreite geschafft.
Das Problem war einfach die Zahl an concurrent Downloads. Ich hab das jetzt auch nicht so genau nachmessen können.
Ich hab schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dass Lighty nicht mehr Stand der Technik ist. Aber gut, kannst auch ein Warnisch davor schalten, wäre noch besser eigentlich.
Ja, und was ist da anders?
Schneller.
Dann ist deine Leitung dicht und dann macht das Gigabit voll.
Nein, schnell ist ja nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist, viele Connections.
Ja, kann er auch besser.
Ist denen egal.
Ja, und wie besser kann er das?
Man benutzt nichts anderes mehr.
Ich hab schon vor zwei Jahren wollte ich mal auf Engine X umstellen, hatte das auch schon mal gemacht. Aber dann konnte der halt so ganz grundlegende Sachen nicht.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, das hast du nicht gefunden.
Nein, ich saß ja mit einem Engine X Experten auf dem Kongress und haben das irgendwie parallel aufgesetzt. Und was er nicht konnte, war, er konnte keine eTags.
Vor zwei Jahren?
Zwei oder drei Jahren. Er konnte keine eTags, glaubst du mir? Er konnte etwas, was es seit Jahren im Netz gibt.
Ich guck mal nach, seit wann es eTags in Engine gibt.
Ja, ja, guck mal nach. Das kam nämlich dann später auch irgendwann. Mittlerweile geht das auch alles. Ich wäre auch durchaus motiviert, da jetzt einen Upgrade vorzunehmen. Naja, also das ist sozusagen die ganze Story. Tendenziell möchte ich gerne schon meine Feats vollständig anbieten, weiß jetzt aber auch nicht, wie ich dieses Problem lösen soll. Dass es da draußen Clients gibt, die einfach explodieren, wenn halt ein 5 MB XML-Fall kommt. Was ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt, gerade bei der Podcast-App wundert mich das so ein bisschen. Weil ich eigentlich erwartet hätte, dass die das Parsing sowieso nicht mehr auf dem Device macht, sondern das Ganze vom iTunes-Backend durchführen lässt. Aber dem ist vermutlich nicht so, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es auch so.
Also eTax in Nginx gibt es seit ca. Mitte 2012.
Äh, richtig im Release oder in der Beta-Version?
In Version 1.3.3.
Genau, hier da. 10.7.2012.
Ja genau, dann muss das Ende 2011, so lang ist das schon her.
Ist ja egal, wenn du ein Programm hast, was von deinen Gigabit nur 10% nutzt, dann ist das Programm falsch.
Punkt.
Ich kann es dir nicht genau erklären. Ich habe regelmäßig 500 Megabit und auch ein Gigabit Downloads-Rate. Ich habe nie ein Problem damit gehabt.
Bis dann zu viele Connections kamen und dann du doch ein Problem hattest.
Und dann ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas komplett hops gegangen. Ich kann es jetzt auch nicht genau sagen, was jetzt der konkrete Grund war, warum das da nicht ging.
Wahrscheinlich hat der Leid, die alle Podcasts versucht, ins Ram zu laden, die er ausliefert. Und deine Kiste war im Swappen oder so.
Vielleicht hat es was damit zu tun gehabt, dass zu viele unterschiedliche...
Ich vermute mal eher, dass das wirklich so diese Long-Standing-Connections sind, weil normalerweise hast du vielleicht eher so kurze HTTP-Requests die meiste Zeit. Und File-Download ist jetzt nicht nur File-Download, sondern es ist noch was anderes da. Und wenn dann halt Slow-Clients kommen...
Auf dem gibt es ja nur Download auf dem Server.
Ach so, du hast einen extra File-Server. Na ja, vielleicht dann ist...
Wahrscheinlich sind da tausende Connections, die alle dadurch auch sehr langsam werden. Aber ich würde behaupten, er leid, die macht das falsch und das geht schon besser.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, ich muss mir das in Ruhe nochmal anschauen. Ich werde zu sehen, dass meine ganze Download-Infrastruktur da nochmal angepasst wird. Das kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin. Und ja, ansonsten kann ich trotzdem Feedpress schon mal empfehlen, weil Feedpress auch viel, ja, ob es wirklich besser ist, aber ich habe gesehen, dass im Vergleich zu Feedburner von Feedpress höhere Subscriberzahlen reported werden.
Und das ist ja auch schmangig.
Und was ist denn das jetzt hier bei Freak Show?
Was ist denn das für ein Dip da drin, den du da in allen Feeds drin hast?
Das ist der Dip, also was Roddy meint ist...
Wo du noch mal kurz ausmachen musst.
So eine Delle.
So eine Delle, genau. Das ist der Zeitpunkt, wo ich den Feed von Feedburner migriert habe und der Feedpress, also wenn du sozusagen vorher bei Feedburner bist, kannst du in Feedpress sagen, neuer Feed von Feedburner und dann lockt er sich quasi da ein und holt auch die ganze Historie noch mit. Das heißt, er zeigt hier sozusagen die an. Aber dann gibt es eben diese Phase, wo dann erstmal die ganzen Redirects greifen müssen und das gibt dann sozusagen so eine Tagesdelle.
Eine Rekuperationsphase.
Ach so, weil er sich dann die historischen Daten nicht mehr zieht.
Weil, ich kann ja das nicht so 100%-lich, aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Effekt. Diese Delle ist jetzt sozusagen der Zeitpunkt, wo ich von Feedburner auf…
Das war nicht dein Versuch irgendwie.
Nein, nein, das hat ja auch damit dann gar nichts zu tun.
Ein Kleines alles über zu helfen.
Und wir haben 30 Mal mehr M4A-Subscriber als MP3-Subscriber?
Was daran liegt, dass ich halt den…
Eine ganze 260 Org-Subscriber.
Und 171 Opus-Subscriber. Ja, also ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass sich das Angebot mit Vorbis und Opus lohnt im Sinne von… Dann nimmt man doch richtig was mit. Sondern das ist ja eher so…
Naja, aber manche Dinge macht man, weil sie richtig sind.
Opus ist einfach… Das ist eine gute Sache. Und wenn es keiner nutzt, haben sie Pech gehabt, aber ich finde es schon gar nicht schlecht, das anzubieten.
Ja, wobei ich so ein bisschen den Eindruck habe, dass die Leute, die wirklich Opus subscriben, dass die so tendenziell entweder kaputtere Software benutzen oder selbstgeschriebene Shell-Skripte. Weil ich hab ja dann gesehen, wie schnell die Leute von dem alten Feed auf den neuen Feed übergewechselt sind. Und so alles was MP3 und vor allem was MP4 ist.
Die haben Länger gebraucht, die mussten ihren Skript anpassen.
Der MP4 und MP3 war innerhalb von zwei, drei Tagen einfach bei Feedbunner alles auf Null. Aber bei Opus hat sich irgendwie fast gar nichts geändert. Was mir so viel sagt wie... Ja, also mal so ein 301 HTTP-Status-Code, den könnte man schon mal ernst nehmen. Also er wird vielleicht auch ernst genommen und sie folgen diesem Redirect. Aber das Besondere an 301 ist ja, dass der permanent ist. Und wenn er permanent ist, dann kann man ihn sicher vielleicht in dem Moment auch mal merken. Und Konfigurationen, aber wir wissen ja alle wie das ist. Da gibt es dann so ein Text-File, da steht dann der Feed drin. Der wird dann genommen und das Programm schreibt dann da nicht rein und so. Naja. Annie Huse.
Wie auch immer.
Genau, wir haben auf jeden Fall eine ganz stattliche Anzahl von Subscribern. Wir können das ja hier mal überschlagen. Was ist das hier so?
45.000?
Nee, 42.000, 43.000 oder so was. Die halt abonnieren.
Ja, 43.000.
Laut Feedpress. Was auch immer das dann bedeutet.
Schöne Sache.
Genau.
Ich erwähnt dir ja gerade Google.
Ein eigentlich sonst hier geächtetes Thema? Ich mach nur Spaß, Freunde. Jetzt bleibt mal locker.
Google hat ja bekannt gegeben, dass sie jetzt auch ein Podcasting machen.
Wo haben sie das denn bekannt gegeben?
Das haben sie auf ihren Blogs bekannt gegeben. Das ging heute rum oder gestern. Ja, und sieht so aus, als ob sie jetzt demnächst ein Podcast-Portal freischalten als Teil des Google Play Music Store-Dings. Also da, wo sie schon ihre Musik fair shoppen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, haben die auch so Streaming-Dienste mittlerweile mit drin? Flatrate, Spotify-Kram? Bestimmt, ja. Wir wissen es mal wieder nicht, ist auch egal. Tatsache ist, wir wollen jetzt auch Podcasts machen. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht sonderlich überraschend. Also es kam für mich jetzt zumindest nicht sonderlich überraschend, weil A, das Gerücht, dass Google da demnächst was rausbringt, gab es jetzt schon eine Weile. Und B, ist es ja ohnehin so, dass so in den letzten zwei Jahren einfach dieses ganze Podcasting auch kommerziell, zumindest in den USA, halt total Welle macht. Und natürlich auch, dass alle langsam das verstehen, was wir eigentlich schon immer verstanden haben, nämlich dass das halt schon ein relevantes Medium ist in diesem Netz, was man jetzt nicht so wegignorieren kann. Ja, jetzt freuen sich bestimmt Leute. Sie wollen dann auch tatsächlich quasi einen Podcastclient machen oder in ihren Musikclient, den sie schon haben. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, das mit reinbauen. Und das halt auf Android, aber auch auf iOS anbieten. Also mindestens auf diesen Plattformen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie tatsächlich noch andere Plattformen unterstützen wollen. Aber ich vermute mal, das wird nur mobile sein. Und Windows Phone, das ist ihnen dann eher egal.
Weiß ich aber nicht ganz genau.
Ja, und wie das halt so bei Google so ist, sie fahren dann so ein bisschen das YouTube-Modell mit anderen Worten. Sie hosten den Kram auch für dich. Wo man natürlich jetzt so als Podcaster sagen könnte, oh, booh, toll. Dann muss ich hier nicht wie Tim, bekloppt mit Engings-Konfigurationen oder Lighty-Konfigurationen unter meinem eigenen Erfolg leiden. Stimmt ja auch, will man eigentlich auch weghaben, das Ding. Problem ist...
Google.
Problem ist Google, genau.
Ich hab nie das Bedürfnis, dass ich jetzt irgendwie sage, ach, ich lass das mal die Wolke regeln für mich. Ich will immer den Daumen drauf haben.
Ja gut, aber du bist ja auch nicht...
Du bist nicht Generation YouTuber.
Und du bist auch nicht Hauptstrom.
Na, aber man muss ja auch mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen.
Ja, sicher, klar. Ich versuche ja auch mit gutem Beispiel. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt für jeden ein gutes Beispiel bin. Auf jeden Fall wollte ich nur mal kurz sagen, was also Google jetzt vorhat.
Du bist ja hinterhältig. Da steht hier in diesem Workflow, Google macht Podcasts und wir denken alle so ganz naiv. Na, jetzt wird er halt so zwei Sätze so einen Podcast klein machen. Dann klickt ihr auf das Plus und es entfaltet sich eine 1000-zeilige Liste an Punkten. Also lehnt euch jetzt mal ganz entspannt zurück da am Hörgerät. Die Punkte, die klappt da gleich auch noch alle aus. Oh, Tim, jetzt zieh mal durch.
Jetzt gib mal ein bisschen Galopp, das Thema ist schon ganz schön lang.
Ihr wisst, dass ihr euch total unpopulär macht bei unserer Hörerschaft.
Also die erste halbe Stunde ist rum jetzt.
Ja, lasst mich doch mal reden. Ihr Complänt ja nur. Hater Kommentare in der Freak Show.
Wir sind drei Viertel Freak Show hier.
Ich wär schon blöd.
Ja, glaub ich nicht, wenn ich mir die Liste angucke.
Ich warte einfach mal, bis ihr Ruhe gebt.
Komm, dann erzählen wir mal über Bitcoin und ZFS und so in der Zwischenzeit.
Also ich hab mir mal diese Terms of Service durchgelesen. Jetzt nicht, wie das so ein Jurist macht, sondern ich hab das einfach auf so ein paar Punkte hin abgeklopft, die ich verstehen wollte. Und zwar, naja, also du musst halt deine Mediendatei da hochladen. Also in Form, also nein, du lädst deinen, du meldest deinen RSS-Feed an. Insofern ist das genauso wie bei iTunes. Und dann tauchst du halt auch in dem Verzeichnis auf. Nur, dass sie dann halt deine Mediendatei runterladen und den Clients selber ausliefern und sich auch vorbehalten, deine Datei neu zu encoden. Das können sie natürlich auch gerne machen. Damit erschlagen sie auch dieses Formate-Problem, weil sie im Prinzip jedem das vorwerfen können, was sie wollen. Erste Frage ist natürlich, was bleibt mit solchen Metadaten wie Chapter und so weiter, wenn du jetzt da so wohlkreative Medienformate hast, was bleibt danach von übrig? Was lässt Google quasi durch? Wie transparent ist da ihr Konverter? Wissen wir nicht, werden wir sehen. Und ansonsten machen sie denselben Spaß wie iTunes. Es gibt ja diese iTunes Extensions für RSS, wo nochmal so Metadaten drinstehen, die in dem alten RSS-Standard für Podcasts ein bisschen unklar und doppeldeutig waren oder komplett gefehlt haben. Da gibt es dann sozusagen jetzt ein Google Play-Namespace, wo sie quasi den iTunes-Namespace komplett kopiert haben. Also sozusagen exakt dasselbe. Entweder sie nehmen was schon drinsteht mit iTunes, wie das quasi bei allen Podcasts der Fall ist. Oder du kannst halt explizit für Google Play nochmal andere Kontakt-E-Mail-Adresse angeben, anderes Artwork angeben, wenn man das überhaupt machen wollen würde. Also sie übernehmen das einfach komplett. Ja, und dann... Ich hab mir auch so Interviews angehört, was sie da so vorhaben und sie sagen so, ne, nein, wir blenden da auch gar keine Werbung ein. Wir werden auch deinen Podcast nicht auseinanderschneiden und dein ganzer Revenue und so weiter. Das bleibt alles bei dir. Ich meine, wenn sie das nicht machen würden, dann würden sie so aufs Auge kriegen, dann bräuchten sie das gar nicht damit anfangen.
Dann kommt die deutsche Podcaster-Elite und macht sie fertig.
Genau, aber da steht halt schon so was drin wie Google has the right to block any podcast content or advertisement that contain any podcast creator advertisement and or any other advertisements that do not comply with Google Ad Policies.
Advertisen.
Also du, wenn deine Werbung nicht mit den Google Ad Policies zusammenpasst, dann behalten sie sich vor, halt deinen Kram zu blocken. Und sie können dir halt auch vorschreiben, irgendwelche Ads rauszunehmen, die sie irgendwie nicht gut finden, die also mit ihren Policies so sind. Und natürlich auch Take Down wegen Copyright und Pornographic oder Obscene oder otherwise. Das ist schon mal eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten.
Na, da fallen wir doch schon raus.
Ja, ich meine, ich weiß schon, warum ich...
Du bist doch nicht Holgi, Mann.
Ja klar, also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt hier mal, keine Ahnung, im Hintergrund so eine Apple-Werbung, weil sie lustig war, einspielen und so, dann kann es halt schon schnell vorbei sein. Die sind natürlich da vor allem jetzt hier die MCA, Take Down, Musik usw. Das war im Prinzip genau das selbe Ding wie YouTube. Was ja auch der Grund ist, warum ich z.B. meinen Kram niemals auf YouTube hochladen würde, weil ich einfach nicht auf Plattformen stehe, die mich bevormunden und nach deren Regeln ich dann spielen soll. Könnte sein lassen. Und natürlich gehen ja die ganzen Download-Statistiken hobs. Vermutlich, muss man mal gucken, wie die so mit redirect umgehen, was die da alles so ersetzen und was für Kaskaden ein redirect soll sich dann wiederum erzeugt werden. Und du darfst dann dir die Statistiken in ihrem komischen Portal-User-Interface anschauen. Da steh ich auch so richtig drauf. Das sind wirklich so zehn Networks, wo du deinen Kram rausschüttest, alle einzeln mit eigenen User-Interfaces abklappern darfst, um irgendwie ein halbwegs ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie deine Zahlen sind. Da gibt's ja, sind ja nicht die ersten, die das machen. Also es gibt ja hier so Stitcher, jetzt heißt das Deezer, die machen das so, oder Spreaker. Irgendwelche Italiener, die sitzen hier sogar in Berlin. Ja, frag mich, so heißen die. Stitcher ist von Deezer gekauft worden.
Stitcher, Deezer, Spreaker. Ich glaub's ja nicht.
Ja, so heißen die. Das ist alles sozusagen schon die Versuche, so YouTube für Podcasts zu sein. Oder sonstigen Audio-Content. Soundcloud, genau das selbe Ding. Wobei die noch am wenigsten Podcast-Fokus haben. Die machen das zwar auch irgendwie. Aber das ist halt alles irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Mombats.
Es ist alles so ein bisschen shaky. Und in dem Zusammenhang möchte ich auch auf einen Podcast verweisen. Jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz schauen, dass ich nichts Falsches erzähle. Und zwar... So wie das immer ist, habe ich das jetzt gerade nicht im direkten Blick. Das war eine der letzten Folgen von LTP, dem Podcast mit Marco Amendt, der der Autor ist von Overcast. Es war nicht die letzte, sondern es war die vorletzte. LTP 139, I've seen this train before. Das ist wirklich gut. Also ich hab ja so ein bisschen immer so meine Bedenken gehabt bei Marco Amendt und seinem Vorstoß in die Podcasting-Welt. Aber man muss einfach mal sagen, der hat schon sein Herz eigentlich am rechten Fleck. Das hat er auch schon mal bei dem Talk, den er auf dieser XOXO gegeben hat, schon mal durchklingen lassen. Ich empfehle euch ATP 139 anzuhören, insbesondere den Teil zum Business Model, wo er auch von dieser ganzen Facebookization of the Podcast World spricht. So heißt glaube ich auch das Kapitel. Und an der Stelle auch noch mal die Bedenkenteil, die ich auch teile, dass wir einfach das Problem haben, dass Podcasts derzeit einfach noch frei sind von diesen ganzen Plattformen. Aber in dem Moment, wo wir uns halt Facebook, Google und so weiter eintreten, dass wir eben schnell sehen können, dass dann die Regeln einfach mal neu definiert werden und zwar von der anderen Seite auf eine Art und Weise, wie man das halt nicht haben möchte. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob das hier irgendwie einen großen Unterschied macht. Zumindest sieht es so aus, als ob Android demnächst meinen Standard-Podcast-Client bekommt, was ja schon mal von Vorteil ist. Was ich nicht weiß ist, ob sie nur Podcasts anbieten, die quasi bei ihnen gemeldet sind. Das ist ja bei iTunes nicht so. Also erstens kannst du beliebige andere URLs abonnieren in dem Podcast-Client. Und es ist auch so, dass alles, was in dem Verzeichnis ist, ist ja nur die URL verzeichnet. Es sind nicht die Downloads, die darüber laufen. Das verstehen manche auch falsch. iTunes hostet nichts, gar nichts. Das könnte Apple zwar wahrscheinlich mittlerweile problemlos auch tun, aber das tun sie halt nicht. Letztendlich immer von dem Original-Server. Und das ist mir halt jetzt hier noch nicht klar, wie das jetzt so läuft. Derzeit ist das alles natürlich nur wieder für Amerikaner freigeschaltet und demnächst wollen sie da irgendwie nachlegen.
So, so viel dazu.
Und ansonsten hatten noch Leute Probleme geäußert hier mit unserem Podcast, dass der sich so schlecht runterlädt. Und das waren halt alles Benutzer von Overcast. Das war einfach ein Problem mit Overcast und MPEG-4 Audio, das sei mittlerweile gefixt. Und von daher kann man Overcast eigentlich auch mal durchaus als Option empfehlen. Mein Podcast Clients of Choice ist es nach wie vor nicht, abgesehen davon, dass ich so das User-Interface jetzt nicht so geil finde. Ist aber irgendwie auch funktioniert. Hat ihn halt, wie gesagt, meine Feed-Überlast glaube ich auch weggehauen. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig. Und er macht halt kein Video, deswegen ist es auch noch mal nur für Audio-Hörer sozusagen was. Und macht halt natürlich auch kein Flatter, was ein generelles Problem ist. Aber das macht ja irgendwie kaum einer. Was sehr schade ist, also dass Flatter so wenig Unterstützung erfährt durch die ganzen Podcastline, das ist wirklich doof. Weil man hat halt gemerkt, mit Instacast ging das auf einmal dann doch wirklich auf so ein Level, wo man sagen kann, alles was gehört wird, wird auch bedacht. Und das halt möglichst gleichmäßig. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr faires Modell, was ich sehr schätze. Und ich weiß nicht, es geht so ein bisschen zurück mit Flatter. Das lässt sich schon seit einem halben Jahr ablesen. Und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, woran es liegt, dass Leute weniger Geld da reintun, ob einfach viele Leute es gar nicht mehr benutzen und da abspringen. Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Mischung von allem. Es ist jetzt noch lange noch nicht tot, aber so ist es mal locker alles um 40 Prozent zurückgegangen.
Aber ohne künstliche Beatmung würde es auch auch sterben, oder?
Künstliche Beatmung? Wodurch wird es denn künstlich beatmet?
Durch die User, die noch da sind.
Na, was heißt künstliche Beatmung? Das ist halt die Nutzung.
Na ja, aber normalerweise ein Dienst, der funktioniert ja nur, wenn der auch irgendwie wächst, weil so wie er gerade ist. Also der hat ja sozusagen nie sein Lebensziel erreicht, dass er wahrscheinlich selbstragend funktioniert, oder? Ja, so gesehen ist er aus der Brutkammer nicht rausgekommen.
Ja gut, ich meine dafür, dass das so eine ewige...
Und es sah ja mal gut aus. Ich glaube, die erste Fehlentscheidung aus meiner Sicht, ich hab mich jetzt nicht so viel wie du damit beschäftigt, aber es war schon, als du dieses PayPal rausgenommen hast. Da kann man ja PayPal hassen und Peter Sunde ist natürlich da auch irgendwie, hat da seine Ideale und verstehe ich ja auch, da kennt er nix, aber bei dem ging es mir auf den Sack.
Vor allen Dingen, weil die Alternative viel schlimmer ist als PayPal. Also von der Benutzung her, da hat einfach keiner Bock, sich mit auseinanderzusetzen. PayPal hat halt einfach jeder und dieses Skrill Money Bookers ist einfach auch so eine Usability-Katastrophe vor dem Herrn. Weniger Gebühren zahlt man da auch nicht. Auch das Geld da rauszukriegen als Flatterungsempfänger ist nervig.
Ja, das ist ein Schritt mehr, das nervt total.
Aber man merkt einfach, die kümmern sich da nicht groß weiter drum.
Das Ding ist, sie haben ja schon letztes Jahr in Rewrite angekündigt und vor allem eine Umstellung ihres Banking-Modells. Und sie haben ja im Prinzip da schon einen neuen Partner gefunden mit Mangope. Das haben sie auch alles angekündigt.
Freak Show-Berichtete.
Freak Show-Berichtete. Aus rechtlichen Gründen müssten sozusagen auch alle Flatter-User dann noch mal den neuen Terms and Conditions ihr OK geben. Was wohl nicht so viele Leute getan haben, wie sie sich das am Anfang vorgestellt haben. Und ich hatte so den Eindruck, dadurch ist ihnen so ein bisschen der Mut zur Umstellung abhanden gekommen. Was ich persönlich ein bisschen schade fand. Ich kenne jetzt die Zahlen halt nicht genau. Aber ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt auch mal wieder vor Ort in Malmo und habe mich irgendwie mit ihnen unterhalten, mit den verbliebenen zwei Leuten. Und naja, ich habe halt auch das neue System schon gesehen. Also es gibt sozusagen eine neue Webseite und es gibt irgendwie ein überarbeitetes Konzept und es gibt diese neue Banking-Integration. Ich weiß nicht, was da jetzt noch fehlt.
Wann hast du das gesehen?
Das ist jetzt ein Jahr her.
Na dann ist das ja inzwischen auch schon wieder kaputt, oder? Wie das mit Features ist, die man programmiert, dann lässt man sie liegen, hat eigentlich alles funktioniert, aber ein Jahr später geht das einfach alles nicht mehr. Man muss ja weiter integrieren und machen und tun.
Naja, soweit ich weiß, arbeiten sie halt auch dran. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann dir nicht sagen, was sie davon abhält, es umzusetzen. Das entzieht sich einfach meiner Kenntnis und entzieht sich auch so ein bisschen meiner Ahnung. Ändert aber nichts an der Tatsache, dass Flatter zum Beispiel für mich nach wie vor sehr wichtig ist.
Ja, und so für die bestimmt auch.
Sicherlich, aber ja, das ist ja an der Stelle unerheblich, oder?
Nö, dass du da abspringst, vielleicht die gleich ausmachen können. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß dein Anteil dabei Flatter ist.
Weiß ich auch nicht, aber warum sollte ich da auch abspringen? Also ich meine, Flatter hat jetzt für über einen Zeitraum von, na, fast fünf Jahre, hat das hier einfach die Metaebene Grundkosten getragen. Und zwar komplett. Also das ist schon nennenswert. Und ich freu mich auch über jeden, der da noch mal mit einsteigt. Also es gibt keinen Grund, es ist halt nur schwierig, dieses Klicken sozusagen zu machen. Also ich vermute, dass es jetzt bei mir noch läuft, ist, dass einfach viele dieses Subscription-Feature einfach benutzen. Was ich halt auch raten würde, jetzt wo es sozusagen kein Auto-Flatter mehr gibt und es auch nicht absehbar ist, dass das in Apps reinkommt oder in Backends. Also ich könnte mir das sehr wohl wünschen. Also gerade Overcast hätte alle Möglichkeiten, weil das ja ein Client ist, der ein Backend hat. Genau wie das ja mit Instacast, mit der Cloud auch war. Es hat ja nicht mehr die App geflattert, sondern dieses Habe ich gehört-Event ging quasi in die Cloud und hat dann eben hintenrum das gemacht. Nur den Amerikanern ist halt so was wie Flatter schwer beizubringen, weil das ist ja Sozialismus. Ich meine, die haben jetzt auch einen Präsidentschaftskandidaten, der sich Sozialist nennt. Vielleicht hilft das ja Flatter nochmal hinten rum.
Ich meine, bei den Amerikanern, die haben ja, wie gesagt, hier so mit Patreon und so, die haben ja andere Modelle auch.
Genau, die ja im Prinzip aber auch genauso funktionieren.
Also die, die letztens gehackt wurden, oder?
Ach echt?
Naja, haben sie aufgemacht. Richtig irgendwie User-Accounts und so weiter, alles aufgemacht, ganze Payment-History. Und zwar haben die einen Development-Server online gehabt, wo eine komplette Copy von ihrem Kram drin war.
Damit sie gleich noch den Source hatten zum Bugsuchen, ja geil.
Genau, mit Sourcecode und so weiter.
Einmal Hose runter.
Einmal Hose runter. Genau, das ist vielleicht zumindest noch nicht passiert. Also meinetwegen kann man auch weiterhin auf Marco Amendt einreden, dass sozusagen Flatter genauso eine gute Idee ist wie Kapitelmarken. Die haben wir ja letztes Mal schon darüber gesprochen eigentlich.
Ach so, dass er die auf deutsche Initiative hin doch jetzt akzeptiert.
Genau.
Don't doubt the Germans oder so ähnlich.
Genau, don't doubt the Germans. Also jetzt wird es aber noch lustiger, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz diesen Tweet, muss ich nochmal raussuchen. Und zwar hat er nämlich jetzt vor ein paar Tagen angekündigt, dass er auch ein Mac OS basiertes Kapitel Tool bringt.
Hab ich auch gelesen.
Und da sozusagen Beta-Versionen. So kurz schauen, genau, hier ist der Tweet. Und hier ist das, Moment.
Ja, mit Schwung. Nochmal Anlauf nehmen.
Und das ist das Icon, sein App-Icon, was er sozusagen während des Developments macht. Roddy, du darfst es vorlesen.
I probably can't chip with its placeholder icon though. Naja, das ist so ein Kreis, wo halt eine deutsche Flagge drin ist.
Die deutsche Fahne.
Ein deutscher Hamburger.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß das zu schätzen.
Jaja, ich auch.
Aber das liest sich dann fast so, als würde er einfach nur noch mehr spaßig über diese Kapitelmarken Wut der Deutschen machen. Vielleicht macht er ja wirklich gar keinen.
Er ärgert euch nur, genau.
Ich meine, er hat es eingesehen, dass das eine gute Idee war mit den Kapitelmarken. Und jetzt wird er demnächst Code rausgießen, wo er ein, er meint, das wäre kein besonders tolles Tool, aber es würde irgendwie funktionieren, wo man dann halt einer mp3-Datei Kapitelmarken hinzufügen nimmt. Was man auch mit Auffonic machen kann, aber eben nicht mit so einem Standalone-Tool. Es macht auch das nicht für AAC-Dateien, egal. Hier geht es eigentlich mehr um Statement. Aber ich denke mir, wenn man die Front von Kapitelmarken überzeugen kann, dann könnten Sie Germans ja dann vielleicht auch noch mal den Punkt mit Flatter machen.
Naja, als ich mit ihm gesprochen hatte, machte er halt auch so ein bisschen den Punkt auf, dass solange der ganze Workflow für ihn mit den Kapitelmarken nicht vollständig ist, macht das auch für ihn keinen Sinn, Kapitelmarken anzubieten. Und ich glaube, so ein bisschen muss man das in dem Zusammenhang sehen, dass er jetzt halt auch, er bietet jetzt die Kapitelmarken im Client an und jetzt will er natürlich im eigenen Podcast die auch haben und jetzt braucht er ein Tool, um Kapitelmarken zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht will er sich nicht auf Phonik verlassen oder in seinem ganzen Workflow, also irgendwie.
Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt weiter denken mit Flatter. Also wenn jetzt sozusagen Sie Germans, Sie Germans. Wenn Sie Germans jetzt kommen und sagen, jetzt baust du aber auch noch ein Flatter-Backend ein.
Aber Flatter sind ja The Swedish.
Ja, Flatter ist ja eigentlich nur for Sie Germans. Außerdem ist das aus seiner Perspektive Europe.
Kontinentaleuropäer.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, die Truppe hatte sich schon mal sehr kritisch zu Flatter geäußert und das würde ja nicht funktionieren, weil sie das natürlich in Relation zu ihren exorbitanten Advertisement-Spots in Relation setzen.
Ja, vielleicht laufen die ja auch nicht mehr so gut bei denen. Man weiß es nicht.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die läuft da sehr gut.
Gibt es da Zahlen zu, was die mit ihrer Werbung einnehmen?
Marco Armit meint, dass er ja ein Euro-American ist, so wie die anderen der Afro-Americans sind.
Also wir können mal gucken, was die hier so aufrufen.
Hast du Zugriff zu ihrem iPress, FeedPress-Account?
Nö, das steht einfach auf der Webseite.
So, hier steht's.
We reach an average of 80.000 unique downloaders per Episode. Our current sponsorship rate is $4000. So, und davon haben sie halt drei. Das heißt, die machen mal 12.000 Dollar pro Folge. Wir liegen in einem ähnlichen Bereich, aber wir nehmen nicht 4.000 Dollar.
Ja, da wüsste ich auch, wann.
Ne, ich nehme auch keine 4.000 Dollar.
Genau.
Ich hätte jetzt auch kein Problem damit, 12.000 Dollar per Flatter einzunehmen stattdessen. Gerade dafür, dass man nicht, genau. Aber wir wissen ja alle, man kann ja mehr Geld damit verdienen, indem man halt seine Hörer verkauft, sozusagen als Produktpfeil bietet, ja. Dafür gibt es halt hier keine Matratzen-Scheiße.
Matratzen-Scheiße, machen die Werbung für Matratzen oder was?
This is totally awesome and amazing and great.
Es gibt ja deutsche Podcasts, die diesen Weg beschreiten. Kennt man da Zahlen zu?
Ich kenne keine Zahlen dazu.
Ich auch nicht, deswegen frage ich ja.
Ich finde das auch gar nicht schlecht machen. Also jeder muss da seinen Weg...
Aber gut ist es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das lass ich so nicht stehen. Jeder kann das machen, wie er will. So und es gibt auch in Deutschland jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit jetzt, wo Audible anfängt, mit der Gießkanne Geld in der Szene zu verteilen. Ja, da wird jetzt immer schön hier Hörbuch ticken und so weiter. Ich kann das nicht. Ich kann, ich kann...
Wie Audible? Machen die auch Podcasts?
Das war vor Jahren schon.
Nein, die haben jetzt vor ein paar Wochen haben die irgendwie alle Podcasts in Deutschland angeschrieben und hier. Und wir wollen ja mal ausprobieren. Habe ich glaube ich schon erwähnt und ihr könnt ja mal Werbung machen und so. Die haben jetzt keine Zahlen genannt.
Mich haben die nicht angeschrieben. Power-Podcaster? Der 300 Herz hat auch so auch seine...
Na vielleicht kommt das ja noch....
1000 Subscriber oder so.
Ich finde es schon ganz gut, dass wenn ich mir hier ein Produkt kaufe und dann davon erzähle, das ist ja eigentlich Werbung, aber ich finde es noch fast viel besser, wenn ich mir ein Produkt kaufe und das hier sowas auseinandernehme, dass nie wieder einer auch nur das angucken wird. Das ist mir schon wichtig.
Und das ist, sagen wir mal, der Preis der Freiheit.
Auch mal sagen, dass was scheiße ist.
Genau. Und damit verdient man weniger Geld, als ob man diese Freiheit dann sozusagen in der Galerobe abgibt.
Genau, der Preis der Freiheit ist, dass man dann halt noch so einen anderen Job machen muss.
Ich will das auch für mich überhaupt nicht ausschließen, dass ich dieses Modell irgendwann mal justiere. Und ich habe ja auch selber mit meinen Auftragsproduktionen einen Zwischenweg. Also sowas wie Forschergeist und Focus on Europa. Das sind ja beauftragte Sachen. Da habe ich zwar auch eine sehr große redaktionelle Freiheit dahingehend, dass ich keine großen Vorgaben bekomme, wie das jetzt zu sein hat. Und wenn man sich die Podcasts auch anhört, dann wird man jetzt keinen nennenswerten, stilistischen Unterschied feststellen zu, wie ich das normalerweise machen würde. Und deswegen bin ich ja auch sozusagen da überhaupt in diesen Deal reingekommen, weil das auch das ist, was gewünscht ist.
Na ja, du siehst die Leute schon. Teilweise, teilweise nicht.
Das entscheidet sich immer so in den ersten zehn Minuten, nachdem man sich so trifft.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall die Situation. Um es jetzt mal wieder zurückzufalten, also ATP, andere Podcasts, die machen eine Menge Kohle. Und das ist ja auch ein sehr guter Podcast, muss man dazu sagen. Also eine Freude, John Siracusa beim Ranten zuzuhören. Also wenn der mal explodiert, das gibt mindestens so große Krater wie bei Clemens.
Ja, ihr habt Siracusa, wir haben Schrömpfer. Wo ist es?
Gut, aber vielleicht kriegen wir ja trotzdem mal Flatter eingetüttelt, weil das Ding ist ja, abgesehen davon, dass man natürlich den Aufwand leisten muss, das zu coden, was aber kaum Arbeit ist, wenn man schon so weit ist, wie der Marco Armin da ist. Da muss er nur die Flatter-Information, eine URL rausnehmen, einen API-Call machen und sagen, hier gehört Zack-Bumm-Klick.
Return musst du vergessen.
Das ist ja ohne Return, passiert ja mit API.
Genau.
Und...
Und das war's. Das ist sozusagen die gesamte Arbeit, die geleistet werden muss und man kriegt ja dann als Durchführer, als Proxy, quasi als Weiterleiter, kriegt man ja dann auch die Hälfte ab. Das ist ja eigentlich ein geiler Deal. Das heißt, dieses Feature macht sich einfach von alleine bezahlt.
Wie im Moment nochmal der Durchleiter kriegt die Hälfte von dem Flatter-Click.
Ja, also die Hälfte von dem Flatters Anteil. Also Flatter nimmt ja quasi 10%. Wenn du jetzt aber derjenige bist, der quasi diesen Button realisiert, wenn es nicht über einen Webseiten-Button geht, den du manuell klickst, sondern wenn das eben automatisiert über diese App, in dem Fall halt über das Backend geht, dann kriegst du halt die Hälfte von Flatter, also die 5%. Jetzt wissen wir alle, 5% von 10 Cent und so weiter, das sind alles keine Summen, aber man muss das halt hier immer alles mal 10.000, mal 100.000 nehmen, potenziell. Und dann läuft der Hase. Ich meine, ich finde Flatter nach wie vor, das ist immer noch eine genauso gute Idee, wie das vor fünf Jahren auch eine gute Idee war. Das ist einfach nach wie vor top und es ist sehr schade, dass das irgendwie keinen Anklang findet, aber es hat sich zumindest in der Podcast- Landschaft bewährt und wenn wir jetzt irgendwie Kapitel durchsetzen, dann können wir doch bitte jetzt auch nochmal Schlatter durchsetzen. Aber jetzt bin ich auch durch mit dem Thema.
Eine Stunde später?
Eine Stunde später, genau.
Erstes Thema...
Das war jetzt...
Wer es im Chat hat, hat schon bei deinem Video auch immer Prost geschrieben. Scheint sich so zum kleinen Trinkspiel aus.
Trinkspiel.
Gut, kommen wir zum Programmieren. Jetzt, wo wir wissen, was wir programmieren wollen, müssen wir nur noch wissen, wie wir es programmieren. Und letztes Mal hatten wir schon so einen kleinen Ausflug in die Spielewelt. Und in den letzten zwei Wochen ist tatsächlich ein wirklich sehr schönes neues Spiel am Horizont erschienen. Und diesmal ohne Werbung, ohne Nerv, Schlumpfbeeren, Warten, bis wieder alles aufgeladen ist und Facebook-Login und so einfach nur ein Spiel. Und das ist von den Machern von World of Goo, so heißt das Spiel, glaube ich, was so auf dem iOS schon sehr erfolgreich war. Und die haben jetzt auf Steam einen Spielrelease, das heißt Human Resource Machine. Und im Wesentlichen ist das ein Spiel zum, ja, ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, Programmieren lernen, weil ich glaube, so für Kinder ist das jetzt noch nix. Aber für Leute, die schon mal programmiert haben, ist das auf jeden Fall ein super cooles Puzzlespiel im Wesentlichen.
Ich würde das nicht sagen. Wir haben uns das ja vorhin mal gemeinsam angeschaut und das ist so basic, da weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, was an Kindern falsch läuft, dass sie das nicht machen können.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, an dem Zeitpunkt, wo du, also ab Level 20 von dem Spiel, wo es dann Zero Terminated Strings und so ist so, wo die Programme auch länger werden und so mit den Jumps, JumpifZero, JumpifNegative.
Ja, aber wenn du als Kind schon die ersten 20 Level durchgekommen bist.
Ja, dann fräste dich auch durch den Rest.
Ja, warum sollte man das nicht tun?
Mag sein, mag sein.
Ich hab auch als Kind December programmiert.
Ja, ich hab's nicht, deswegen kann ich das nicht einschätzen.
Das fällt dir vermisserlich nicht sogar leichter.
Ja, aber damals hatten wir nichts anderes. So, jetzt fragen die Leute natürlich gleich direkt mal nach dem Link zum Spiel, guckt euch auf jeden Fall auf YouTube auch mal so ein Gameplay-Video davon an. Ich guck hier gerade mal, hab ich einen Link hier von dem Human Resource Machine? Ich suche euch den gleich raus. Auf jeden Fall, worum es geht, du landest halt in so einem Büro-Draufsichtsraum und es gibt ein Förderband, wo Sachen reinfahren und es gibt ein Förderband, wo Sachen rausfahren. Input, Output. Und man muss dann halt den Input sozusagen, also das, was da im Förderband reinkommt, auf verschiedenste Art und Weisen multiplizieren, Vorzeichen ändern, testen, ob es positiv negativ ist, sortieren und so weiter. Und man hat sozusagen so einen visuellen Assembler-Programmierer, wo man sich einzelne Kommandos sozusagen hin und her drag und droppen kann. Und es fängt natürlich mit so einer schönen, leichten Steigerungskurve an, also erstmal so ganz iterativ irgendwie, sind drei Sachen auf dem Förderband und die sollen aufs andere Förderband und dann hat man noch keine Schleife und keinen Jump, das heißt, man muss einfach dreimal hintereinander sagen Inbox, Outbox, Inbox, Outbox, Inbox, Outbox. Dann ist das nächste Spiel, ah jetzt kommt ein Jump-Statement dazu, alles klar, dann muss man die beiden Kommandos nur einmal hinschreiben und jump einfach drüber und irgendwann geht's mit Speichern, also mit Registern los und so weiter und so fort. Und davon gibt es glaube ich so 40 oder 50 Levels und das ist echt ein ganz super schön putzig gemachtes Puzzle-Spiel und ich bin auch total, ich bin schon morgen da aufgewacht und dachte mir, fuck, eine halbe Stunde, um auf Arbeit zu fahren, na ja, mache ich jetzt noch mal kurz auf und dann sitzt man da so, ah fuck, irgendwas geht da noch nicht richtig und es geht doch noch optimaler und dann ist plötzlich schon zu spät und ich komme zu spät auf Arbeit. Ja, also dieses Spiel kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen, das kostet auf Steam 9,99 und kommt halt wie letzte Sendung gewünscht, ohne Nervfaktoren von wegen hier, du musst jetzt warten zum weiterspielen oder Werbung oder sonst irgendwas und ich dachte mir auch, als ich das gesehen habe und die ersten Gameplay-Videos so gesehen habe, ok, das sieht genau nach dem richtigen Nerd-Puzzle-Spiel aus, weil dann gibt es halt auch irgendeinen Punkt, wo sie anfangen dir zu sagen, was die optimalen, die optimale Anzahl Kommandos ist, um das Problem zu lesen und die optimale Zahl von Schritten um...
Ein bisschen wie bei Portal, wo man noch diese Challenges hatte.
Genau und dann fängst du halt so an, ja verdammt, jetzt ist mein Programm irgendwie 30 Schritte zu viel über der optimalen Lösung und sie sagen auch, manchmal ist es auch so, die optimale Lösung für die geringsten Kommandos ist langsam und braucht mehr Schritte und wenn du auf die weniger Schritte optimieren willst, dann hast du vielleicht mehr Kommandos als minimal nötig, sodass du halt dann auch so, du hast auch so Tabs, du kannst für jedes Puzzle drei verschiedene Programme, Varianten haben und dann eben verschiedene Optimierungen sozusagen durchführen. So, das Spiel, im Chat wird nochmal gefragt, heißt Human Resource Machine. Ich pack euch jetzt den Steam-Link nochmal rein, falls das noch nicht passiert ist. Ach, das ist sogar ein Humble Bundle?
Ist es?
Da ist gerade so ein Link irgendwie.
Gilt dieses Humble Bundle auch für Steam oder was?
Weiß nicht. Also es gibt vermutlich auch als Standalone-Game, aber ich hab tatsächlich so ein paar Indie-Spiele auch über Steam und hab deswegen das da geklickt, aber man muss es nicht.
Achso, gibt es das auch?
Ich pack euch jetzt hier erstmal den Steam-Link auch noch in die Show-Notes, dann haben das auch alle. Und wenn es das beim Humble Store gibt, super, vielleicht gibt es das auch sogar auf der Webseite von dem. Ja, man hat hier gleich immer noch so diesen Charity-Faktor noch mit drin. Zehn Prozent geht da irgendwie immer noch an irgendwelche Charity-Sachen, die du dir selber aussuchen kannst und so.
Aber jetzt hier nicht Teil eines Bundles, oder doch?
Scheint nicht so zu sein, ja. Naja, auf jeden Fall haben Human Resource Machine wirklich super schön, liebevoll, einfach gemachtes Spiel, lädt auch super schnell runter, weil das Programm, also den Spaß, den schreibt ihr ja dann.
Also ich würde nochmal unterstreichen, dass das auch wirklich was ist, wo man einfach poamieren lernen kann. Wobei das halt hier, was hier wirklich speziell ist, dass es wirklich diese Denkwelt von Prozessoren extrem repliziert und vor allem von super minimalistischen Prozessoren. Wie du vorhin schon meintest, man muss dann multiplizieren, aber es gibt überhaupt kein Kommando zum multiplizieren, sondern es gibt halt nur addieren und subtraieren.
Ja, das war wirklich für mich, weil ich ja nur mit High-Level-Sprachen, also angefangen hab zu probieren, glaub ich, mit Perl, JavaScript, Ruby, Erlang, das sind ja alles Sprachen, da gibt es halt eine Mars-Library. Da muss man sich nichts selber ausdenken. Und dann gibt es da einen Puzzle und dann steht dann, nimm die Zahl vom Laufband und multipliziere mit 8 und schiebst dann aufs andere Laufband und du hast aber nur ein Add. Und dann so, ja, aha, also wie multipliziere ich denn jetzt mit Add? Ach, das hat man natürlich alles in der Schule mal gemacht, aber dadurch, dass man das nie so sonst machen muss und es überall ein Taschenrechner mit einem Malzeichen gibt, denkt man halt nicht so drüber nach und dann sitzt man dann ebenso als alter High-Level-Programmierer und kommt auf die einfachsten Sachen nicht. Oder Vorzeichen ändern. Du hast eine Zahl, musst Vorzeichen ändern, hast halt eben nur so wie Add und Subtract und so weiter und so fort. Und so lauter eigentlich super simple Probleme, die halt auf so einer CPU tagtäglich Milliarden und abermediatenfach stattfinden, aber mit dem man sich als High-Level-Programmierer halt nie beschäftigen muss.
Die CPUs von früher, ich glaub die 64 auch noch nicht, die hatten keinen Multiplikator.
Hatten keinen Multiplikator. Nö, der gab's. Aber es gab aber immerhin eine Library im Raum, die man benutzen konnte. Also so eine Funktion, die multipliziert hat.
Aber eben dann, was dann auch schön ist, wenn du dann ans Optimieren gehst, dann ist eben auch so dieses Thema so Schleifen auswickeln.
Unwinding, Loop Unrolling.
Ja genau, Englisch ist das alles klar. Wie sagt man das denn in Deutsch? Das ist jetzt der Gehörer, der jetzt vielleicht nicht so viel Ahnung hat, aber man kann halt immer so eine schöne Schleife schreiben.
Ausrollen.
Und wenn man es dann wickeln. Abwickeln. Wenn man die Schleife abwickelt, dann ist es halt bisweilen deutlich schneller, als wenn man halt immer wieder den Stack hochjumpt. Oder wie ist das?
Schleifers immer die Bedingungen testen, ob die jetzt noch weit dann ausgeführt werden soll oder nicht. Ja, schon. Und wenn du die Schleife hast, die wird nur viermal ausgeführt, musst du jedes Mal checken. Vier, drei, zwei, eins. Das kannst du ja sparen, indem du es viermal hinschreibst, dann fällt der schon mal weg. Ansonsten bei großen Schleifen geht Unroll natürlich nicht, weil dann wird die Schleife in deinem Cache unrollt, dann ist dein Cache irgendwie, gehen deine anderen Daten verloren, dann muss er wieder nachladen. Also das hat Grenzen mit diesem Unroll.
Ja genau, und ich dachte mir auch so, der Dennis, der mit seinem Display da die ganze Zeit so irgendwie am Bit optimieren ist, der wird wahrscheinlich an diesem Spiel so, ahja, hier, alles ganz klar.
Ich glaube, die, die das am besten können, sind Leute, die Assembler können. Und die, die das richtig am besten können, sind Leute, die Assembler ohne Multiplikator gelernt haben. Also so vor 68K-Zeiten, die müssten das eigentlich am besten drauf haben.
Zwei Leute hier in dem Tisch. Und das Ding ist, ich bin jetzt gerade Level 20, jetzt gibt es da irgendwie Zero Terminated Strings, irgendwie mein Programm läuft auch noch nicht ganz, aber ich hatte noch nicht so die Ruhe, das nochmal durch zu debuggen. Man kann halt jeden Schritt auf diesem Faderband-Dingsbums auch wieder sozusagen Schritt für Schritt durchgehen, um das zu debuggen. Aber ja, es macht auf jeden Fall Laune.
Also das ist so, das ist irgendwie so nah an der Realität des Assembler-Programmierens, wie du es überhaupt gar nicht vorstellst. Also gerade mit diesen Registern und dann halt auch so dieses um die Ecke denken und was ja auch noch erwähnt, dass man bewertet wird dann nach Anzahl der verwendeten Kommandos und wie viel Schritte und wie die Performance ist, also sozusagen wie viel Durchläufe es gibt.
Wie viele Zyklen sozusagen.
Genau, wie viele Zyklen. Und ernsthaft, also damals auf dem Ziel 64, da hat man sich wirklich hingesetzt, man hat so eine Routine geschrieben und dann hat man sich schön ausgerechnet, wie viele Instruktionen, wie viele Zyklen, jede Instruktion, die man da verwendet, verbraucht und wie oft die aufgerufen wird und ob man nicht noch mal irgendwo...
Damals war das aber auch einfach, weil es gab diese ganzen Caches nicht und es gab auch auch keine Pipelines und so. Da stand halt im Buch zwei Taktzyklen und dann waren es zwei Taktzyklen und zwar immer.
Für eine Liga konnte man die auswendig, für die Standardbefehler.
Ja genau, das hatte man dann halt irgendwann drauf.
Und deswegen war die Multiplikation auch so um die 60, 70 Taktzyklen bei den C64, weil man musste halt, ja, das war halt entsprechend viel Kot.
Der teuerste BP auf dem 68k war Dividieren durch mit 78 Taktzyklen. Da stand aber wirklich dabei, es kommt darauf an, was du dividierst, weil bestimmte Divisionen könnten auch schneller sein, also das war so ein Dynamischer.
Durch Null vor allem.
Ja und das ist halt zum Beispiel eben auch, genau, dann gibt es nämlich auch ein Multiplikations-Puzzle und eben auch wieder nur mit Add und Sub. Und natürlich kannst du dann, wenn Null auf dem Förderband liegt, dann ist halt die Sache, wenn jetzt ein längeres Programm mit vielen Kommandos schreibst, dann kannst du natürlich auch gleich am Anfang noch testen. Ja, wenn der eine Multiplikator Null ist, jump und gleich hier die Null aufs andere Förderband. Wenn der zweite Multiplikator Null ist, jump gleich aufs Förderband, aber dann dadurch wird der Code gleich auch wieder ein ganzes Stück komplexer. Und ja, es macht mir halt Spaß, weil ich wollte eigentlich auch schon immer mal Assembler programmieren und prinzipiell ist mir schon klar, wie das funktioniert. Aber ich konnte mich immer nie so wirklich entscheiden, ja, welchen Assembler und auf welchem, auf welcher, also was, wo fange ich jetzt an eigentlich, wo finde ich das Instruction Set für den jeweiligen Assembler und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt mit dem Spiel habe ich so das Gefühl, da komme ich zumindest der ganzen Sache schon mal näher, gedanklich.
Was ich ja so geil fand, war, wie irgendwie dann in irgendeiner Zeitung hatte einer einen Algorithmus veröffentlicht, wie man eine schräge Linie zeichnet in Parizellen. Und zwar ohne Multiplikation und ohne Teilung. Dieser Algorithmus, ich habe mir den damals angeguckt, dachte mir, wer kommt auf so eine Idee? Aber der war wirklich genial, weil da hat man irgendwie zwei, drei Register immer nur Zeug addiert und dann kam da plötzlich eine schräge Linie raus.
Das kriegst du auch glaube ich performancemäßig gar nicht hin.
Wir haben uns da auch Sachen einfallen lassen, heutzutage würde da keiner mehr irgendeinen Finger krumm machen oder diese Zeit, die da reingesteckt wurde, um Sachen zu optimieren, ist schon unglaublich.
Das war doch auch, war das nicht so bei dieser, ich meine darum ging es auch bei dieser Demo-Scene oder?
Immer möglichst klein alles hinzukriegen.
Und immer schockierend beeindruckendere Grafiken damit zu produzieren.
Ich hab gerade mal den Prozessor, den ersten Prozessor, den ich programmiert habe, rausgesucht. War noch ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht sehr sehr geil, weil es ist so ein ganz historischer Prozessor. Der RCA 1802.
Wer kennt ihn nicht?
Spannung bis 10 Volt? Alter Schwede!
Der kann richtig was ab. Der ist nämlich auch mit der sogenannten SOS-Technologie gefertigt, Silicon on Sapphire, von Anfang an, was dem eine extreme Resistenz gegenüber Strahlung und Aufladung gegeben hat. Und der RCA 1802 ist, wenn ich, also hier steht jetzt komischerweise nichts davon, aber soweit ich weiß, ist das Ding in der Voyager unterwegs. Oder? Warte mal, Voyager? Kann gar nicht sein. Wann ist die Voyager gestartet?
Na Mitte der 70er oder so.
74 kam der raus.
Oder noch Anfang 70er?
In vielen Satelliten, hier sind sie jetzt nicht genau gemeint, aber was in der Galileo? Achso, der von der NASA, ich dachte von der ESA. Also so ein Ding, ne? Also zwei, vier Bitregister und so. Das willst du nicht.
Also mein erster war ja der Z80. Und da gab es irgendwie so ein Standardwerk. Da gab es so ein Standardwerk, wo irgendwie alle Befehle erklärt wurden und da gab es wirklich die abstrusesten Befehle, die ich je bei einem Prozessor gesehen habe. Also auch so mit ganz merkwürdigen Optimierungen, so Schleifensprünge, die gleichzeitig Bits setzen und in irgendwelchen Registern Sachen hochzählen, noch am Rande und so.
Huibu.
Ja, Huibu. War ein echt dicker Schmöker, weil sie viel zu erklären hatten.
Gut, es wird schon wieder darauf hingewiesen, zurecht, dass die Männer vom Krieg erzählen.
Ja, und? Ist doch schön.
Ja, ja, super.
Ja, damals waren das noch richtig.
Ich werde gleich nochmal hier an die Human Resource Machine anschließen. Und zwar gibt es ein ähnliches Spiel auch für iOS. Das ist sehr nett und zwar heißt es Lightbot. Und das ist auf jeden Fall sehr kinderkompatibel, aber auch nicht nur. Das ist lightbot.com, genau. Und das ist halt so ein Spiel, wo du so einen kleinen Roboter über so ein Feld, so eine kleine Matrix hüpfen und laufen lassen musst, um an bestimmten vormarkierten Feldern das Licht einzuschalten. Und auch da musst du quasi so Assembler-Style, da sind die Instruktionen für so kleine Piktogramme gemacht, also lauf nach vorne etc. Hüpf, dreh dich um, links, rechts, so ein bisschen wie auch, wie hieß das noch gleich, diese Turtle-Graphics? Logo, genau. Würde aber dann halt immer komplexer mit Subroutinen und so, und musst ja darüber Gedanken machen, wie du deine Schritte richtig zusammenfasst, also da kann man diese ganzen Unterprozeduren und so weiter alles ganz gut erlernen. Gibt es dann auch in verschiedenen Varianten für kleinere Kinder, für größere Kinder und ich sehe gerade, es gibt es auch für Mac, für Windows, für Android, sogar für Kinder.
Also ich hab neulich eine Weile so ein Spiel gespielt, wo man so durch so ein Dungeon rennen musste und Fallen ausweichen und so. Das sieht so ähnlich aus wie das, aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie es hieß. Lustig war, dass man ab einem bestimmten Level dann gegen andere Bots kämpfen konnte. Und da wird es dann interessant, weil du musst natürlich versuchen, irgendwie dem Bot irgendwie ein halbwegs intelligentes Manöver beizubringen, damit er gegen den anderen, der auch irgendwas macht, dann irgendwie ankommst. Aber ich hab's da nicht weiter gespielt, weil es war auch so mit Schlumpfbeeren und so.
Irgendwann hab ich mal so, ich hab leider vergessen, wie es heißt oder ich hab es auch nie wieder gefunden. Es gab auch mal irgendwie so ein Spiel, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Im Prinzip sowas wie Human Resource Machine, aber mit Logic Gates. Also wo es sozusagen noch mal eine Stufe drunter geht und halt addieren sozusagen mit Gates und so weiter. Und so weiter. Also wo du wirklich auch so diese Bausteine, die dann so irgendwie nach und nach zusammen kombiniert hast, um dann halt mal eins und eins zusammen zu zählen oder so. Aber um eben so dieses Konzept auch nochmal, wenn halt irgendjemand mal dieses Spiel oder irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mal, ob es ein Spiel war oder einfach nur so ein Tool, womit man sich so Schaltkreise bauen konnte und auch irgendwie so ein bisschen dabei an die Hand genommen wurde, das hätte ich total gerne mal auch. Weil das ist ja dann noch näher am Metall. Ja stimmt.
Ich finde es super, dass es überhaupt so so ein Genre gibt, jetzt so Programmieren, was sich insbesondere an sehr junge Programmierer wendet, auch so rumgesagt.
Ja, ich bin ja auch noch sehr jung. Nee, aber auch, wie ich schon sagte...
Das ist die Stimme der Jugendhuckel.
Die Leute, die wirklich auch nur so mit High-Level-Sprachen unterwegs waren, für die ist das auf jeden Fall auch noch ein Erkenntnisgewinn. Auch einer bei uns im Büro, wir haben das mal eine Mittagspause so angefangen zu spielen, das Human Resource Machine und der Einzige, der sofort irgendwie natürlich die Lösung parat hatte, der studiert gerade noch Informatik, weil da hatten sie das halt jetzt irgendwie gerade und alle anderen saßen dann auch so da, so ja, also ich hab das auch schon mal, also jetzt schreiben wir das noch mal kurz auf, also muss doch irgendwie gehen.
Produktivität bei Vugat wieder gelitten, ja?
Na sicher. Alle Spiele drei Monate Verspätung.
Vor ein, zwei Wochen gab es ja das Vintage Computing Festival. Vintage Computer Festival, Computing Festival Berlin. VCFB, wer war da? Keiner? Du auch nicht, Dennis? Hätte ich jetzt mal vermutet. Ich hatte auch Schwierigkeiten, da viel Zeit für zu finden, weil parallel ja auch noch die Maker-Affair war, die ich dann auch noch besuchen wollte. Und wenn man so Kinder im Schlepp hat und so, da kann man dann auch gut hängen bleiben, weil da gibt es so viele Aktivitäten, 3D Printing und Peeper-Pool. Da kommst du irgendwie echt nicht weiter. Aber dann bin ich doch noch dahin gefahren, bin dann in diesem großen Raum, wo diese ganzen alten Geräte rumstehen und hab's gerade mal bis zur ersten Ecke geschafft. Ich hatte, bis da sozusagen der Raum an dem Tag geschlossen wurde, glaube ich noch so zwei Stunden Zeit hätte ich gehabt, mir alles anzuschauen. Aber ich bin dann gleich an der ersten Ecke gestrandet und nicht mehr weggekommen, weil dort ein Professor von der, jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, war das TU oder FO, eins von beiden, war und sein Projekt gezeigt hat, was er da, genau, Professor Elektrotechnik, und hat das Projekt gezeigt, was er da mit Studenten im letzten Jahr durchgezogen hat. Und das hat mir die Schuhe ausgezogen.
Was ist das denn ein komisches Projekt?
Die haben...
Irgendwas mit Robotik.
Kommt so eine kleine Drohne angefahren und...
Ich bin auch voll im Thema. Ich muss auch schauen, ob ich nebenbei nochmal die Webseite dazu finde. Muss ich noch mal raussuchen. Was die gemacht haben ist, die haben eine CPU gebaut. Weil sie haben diese CPU gebaut aus normaler TTL-Logik. Also mit so ganz normalen ICs, ganzen Standardbausteine.
Okay, also ICs, nicht einzelne Transistoren?
Nein, nein. Ja, so Käferchen halt, so Standardkäferchen-Kram. Aber so alt alles, so diskretter Kram. Das heißt, so wiederkehrende Logiken, die hatten sie eben sozusagen als Steine. Aber es sollte ja eine CPU sein. Und es sollte nicht irgendeine CPU sein, sondern was sie implementiert haben, war eine MIPS-CPU. Also nicht so...
Gibt's da ein Bild von dem Aufbau?
6502 nach.
Ja, es gibt, ich muss...
Und eine Platine hatten die dann sicher auch nicht, weil die kann man ja nicht bezahlen, weil die wäre ja Meter groß. Also haben die das Hardwired.
Lief das aber dann mit Kilohertz-Takt?
Ah, okay, der Chat war schneller als ich dachte.
Das ist nicht das MIPS-Takt, das ist nur ein kleiner Set.
Nein, das ist es nicht.
Das hab ich auch gesehen bei Heise.
Ich erzähl dir jetzt erstmal, und vielleicht kann der Chat mal kurz gucken. Also es war entweder TU oder FO Berlin Elektrotechnik und war eine MIPS-CPU im Nachbau mit TTL.
Ich glaube, an der FO gibt es keine Elektrotechnik, aber ich glaube nicht, aber 100% sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Gut, eins von beiden war es auf jeden Fall. Das war so eine Backplane, und darin standen so 10, 12 Platinen drin. Die Backplane war quasi die Querverschaltung der gesamten primären States dieser CPU. Das heißt, jede Karte konnte quasi auf jeden auf diesen grundlegenden Zustände dieser CPU zugreifen. Das Ding stand da halt auf dem Tisch, und dazu hatte er noch so 20, 30 DIN A3 Plots mit der internen Verdrahtung, also wo diese ganzen TTL Steine und wie die dann halt alle miteinander verdinkt waren. Und dann, und das war für mich ja der totale Knaller, da bin ich dann einfach gar nicht mehr weggekommen, dann halt so eine große Tabelle, wo der komplette Mikrocode dieser CPU codiert war. Und jetzt muss man sozusagen noch mal einen Gang runterschalten, weil was man normalerweise so als Assembler-Programmierer eben so hat, das sind eben diese mehr oder weniger komplexen Instruktionen. Da ist dann halt so was wie addire dies und Register laden und Speicher im Memory ab und indizier das mit dem Inhalt von diesem Register und so weiter. Und unterschiedliche CPUs haben halt einen unterschiedlichen komfortablen Kram und allein schon daran, dass man eben sieht, dass die teilweise unterschiedliche viele Zyklen brauchen, merkt man, naja, irgendwie sind das auch nur Makros auf einer eigentlichen anderen Logik. Und diese Logik, das ist quasi der Mikrokod. Und der Mikrokod bestand halt da aus einer Platine, wo halt da so, was war das? Das war nicht ROM. Ich glaub, es war Flash, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau. Aber da war sozusagen der Mikrokod drin. Und dann habe ich halt diese Tabelle von mir gesehen, wo sozusagen genau drin stand, wie jede einzelne Assemblerinstruktion, die in diesem MIPS-Befehlssatz drin war, hier eben konkret implementiert wurde. Ja, genau, das ist das Teil.
Das ist hier dieser letzte Link.
It's in the links. Genau, da könnt ihr das schön sehen. Wunderbares Gerät. Dazu haben sie halt auch noch so eine kleine IO. Tastatur eingebaut. Und gucken, was haben sie denn hier noch? Gott, diese Webseite ist so oldschool. Sie nimmt sogar an einem Webring teil. Ja genau, ne? Blog-Schaltpläne, ach hier kann man sich auch alles runterladen. Das ist ja wunder, wunder, wunderbar. Und ist hier irgendwo diese Microcode.
17 Ampere Stromaufnahme.
Also da unten gibt's Microcode einlesen für VHDL-Dokumentationen.
Also man könnte doch ganz einfach so ein FPGA kippen und fertig.
Microcode des Steuerwerks.
Na ja, mal gucken, ob das jetzt das Format ist.
Natürlich könnte man das, aber es sind Elektrotechniker. Die wollen halt Zeug bauen.
microcode.xls Da muss er erst mal hier, da ruckelt gleich die Aufnahme bestimmt.
Genau, das war exakt die Grafik hier. Ich präsentiere euch das mal kurz hier. Und Platz schaffen. Ja, da ist er, der microcode. Und da sieht man überhaupt erst mal, dass halt so eine CPU, woraus die eben intern besteht. Also diese ganzen Funktionseinheiten einer CPU, das ist jetzt hier so was wie Alu-Control, Register-Control, Program-Counter-Control, Exception-Handling-Control, Memory-Control. Das sind alles so einzelne Bits und die einzelnen Instruktionsbefehle, die man dann hier in dieser Tabelle von oben nach unten ablesen kann, sind sozusagen einfach ein Ablauf von verschiedenen Einzelschritten, bei denen eben manche dieser CPU-internen States getriggert werden. Das heißt, wenn man sich mal ganz genau verstehen will, wie eine CPU funktioniert, im Sinne von ganz genau, dann hat man mit diesem Projekt wirklich alles. Und das eben auch nicht nur jetzt in der Komplexität eines C64, sondern eben in der Komplexität einer MIPS-CPU. Und das ist schon was. Ich muss zugeben, ich kenne MIPS nicht sehr gut, aber das ist halt im Prinzip eine ziemlich erfolgreiche Architektur gewesen. Gibt es auch heute noch, im Prinzip die Erste, die diesen Rissgedanken auch straight an den Tag gebracht hat. Also ich glaube, MIPS ist am Ende sogar, also wenn es nicht die Älteste, dann ist es so eine der ältesten.
Sollen wir mal die Wikipedia bemühen?
War früher viel so in Laserdruckern und so drin.
Ja, MIPS ist überall drin und auch heute noch.
Auch in den Frühstücksflocken.
Workstations, MIPS-Architektur, schauen wir noch mal kurz.
1981 Introduced.
Ja, das ist auch relativ alt.
Genau.
MIPS 1.
Im R2000 und der R2000.
Genau, so und diese MIPS 1-Architektur, die haben sie halt hier mal implementiert. Also es ist dann halt über die Jahre noch weiter verfeinert worden. Das hätte dann zu viel Komplexität gemacht. Sie haben auch hier Pipelines weggelassen und so, aber es führt halt denselben Code aus. Und kannst halt auch das Verhalten und die Simulation des ganzen Pipelineings, kannst du halt hier nachvollziehen. Also wer da jetzt, wer jetzt, sagen wir mal, von unserer Diskussion nicht sowieso schon komplett an den Boden genagelt wurde, ja, also wer wirklich mal eine CPU verstehen will, ich glaube, das ist das beste Projekt dazu. Ganz großartiges Ding und ich muss auch sagen, Hut ab für den Prof, der das durchgezogen hat. Ich finde das einfach fantastisch. Also ich glaube, da haben am Ende, glaube ich, sechs Studenten wirklich ein Jahr lang dran gearbeitet, bis es dann halt auch wirklich funktionierte. Das ist einfach grandios, weil das Ding ist doch heutzutage schon halt auch keiner mehr wie eine CPU funktioniert. Also das ist einfach die Komplexität einer CPU. Ich glaube nicht, dass du bei Intel irgendjemanden findest, der da auch nur halbwegs sagen kann, ich kenne alles, im Sinne von alles.
Ist doch ein bisschen schwierig, ne? Wahrscheinlich ist heute so ein 64-Bit-Multiplikator größer als das, was die da gemacht haben.
Ja, aber...
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber...
Ich habe mich halt länger mit dem Prof unterhalten und meinte so, ja, ihr habt es wahrscheinlich geschafft so. Also die Leute, die jetzt an diesem Team beteiligt waren, verstehen das. Er meinte, ja, weil sie hätten es nicht bauen können. Es wäre nicht herstellbar gewesen, wenn eben nicht mehr oder weniger alle Beteiligten ein vollständiges Verständnis aller Funktionsvorgänge gehabt haben. Man musste alles wissen. Man musste nicht nur... Also erstmal lernst du ja viel über Elektrotechnik, weil dir ist dann auf jeden Fall der Einsatz jeder dieser einzelnen Chips klar. Aber das ist ja nur so die grundlegende Logik. Du verstehst den Instruktionssatz, du verstehst, wie die CPU das implementiert, wie du das codierst. Und dann haben sie halt in den letzten Monaten im Prinzip nur noch ihren Mikrokod so angepasst, dass er eben genau die richtigen Hebel drückt in dieser ganzen Maschine, um dann letzten Endes kurz im Laufen zu kriegen. Und jetzt können sie halt so einen beliebigen MIPS-Code nehmen und auf ihrer Maschine ausführen. Ich hab ihnen gleich mal vorgeschlagen, soll gleich mal die Erlang-VM drauf zum Laufen bringen. Das wäre auf jeden Fall eine gute Methode, da mal ein bisschen Performance-Testing zu machen.
Aber das sind richtig gebrannte, also richtig geätzte Platinen.
Ja, aber kleine dann mit so einen Schichten da.
Klein?
Na, wie viele Schichten die haben, ist nicht klar.
Die Kleine ist auch nicht, das ist schon ein Riesentisch.
Also da waren sie bestimmt schon bei einem Dienstleister, der ihnen die gebaut hat. Also sie sind nicht selbst geätzt, das sieht man. Obwohl die schon so 80er-Anmutung haben, die Platinen.
Und machst du ein CRE mit dem Herrn?
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut man sowas in Audio rüberbringen kann.
Aber einmal so durch den Computer?
Einmal durch eine CPU durch, kann man drüber nachdenken.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Würde ich mir anhören.
War der letzte Jahr auch schon da?
Weiß ich nicht. Nee, glaube nicht, das ist erst in diesem Jahr fertig geworden.
Hier steht aber was von, das ist der Nachfolger des Space Age. Der Space Age 2 und der Space Age 1. Der sieht ja fast noch abenteuerlich aus.
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Sehr schön.
Aber das war dann wahrscheinlich keine MIPS-CPU, sondern...
Wahrscheinlich was Selbstgestricktes.
Kannst du mal in der UR L da oben statt Space Age 2 einfach mal... Ah nee, da ist das doch verlinkt.
Das ist verlinkt, aber nur auf dem Foto.
Aber eine 32-Bit-CPU aus fast 500 TTL-ICs zusammenzubauen, ey, das ist irgendwie... Das ist ein kompletter Irrsinn.
Ja, aber die haben es halt gebracht und es läuft. Und vor allem ist es so hervorragend dokumentiert, dass man sich jetzt wirklich jedes... Jedes Bit, jeder Takt, jeder Schritt, den diese CPU durchführt. Also da sind sozusagen keine Mysterien mehr. Außer man hat es noch nicht verstanden.
Ja, und man kann sich eben auch noch auf hier so einen Ceilings FPG auch nochmal raufsynthetisieren und da nochmal ein Software quasi...
Genau, dann läuft es vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen schneller als mit dem TTS. Hat dann irgendwie ausgerechnet, dass sie... Also bei normaler Taktung... Was steht hier? 17 Ampere Stromaufnahme. Das hältst du auch nicht gerade wenig.
Naja, bei 5 Volt wahrscheinlich aber, oder?
Naja, das ist trotzdem schon ordentlich.
Das ist schon was.
Und sie kamen wohl auf sowas wie 0,7 MIPS Performance, also MIPS im Sinne von Million Instructions per Second.
Also 700 Kips.
Das wäre sozusagen nur der Nominaltakt, aber sie hätten mal ausgerechnet, wie weit sie das Ding halt übertakken können, ohne dass es ihnen zerschmilzt, also dass es sozusagen thermisch alles noch greift. Und mit ein bisschen Übertakken können sie das Ding theoretisch, praktisch hat das nicht gemacht, aber theoretisch, so habe ich es dann interpretiert, halt auch auf ein MIPS bringen. Also sie haben einen MIPS-Prozessor, der dann auch ein MIPS-Performance liefert. Und das finde ich schon mal ganz gut, so eine Million Instruktionen pro Sekunde, also da, no?
Naja, das ist halt so ein C64, ne? Der war mit einem Megahertz getaktet und hat im Prinzip die meisten Assemblerbefehle auch in einem Taktzyklus hingekriegt.
Nicht alle, ja.
Nicht alle, aber Großteil. Großteil.
Ja, das ist halt auch irgendwie, als ich mich jetzt hier mit diesem Human Resource Machine und so rumheranziert habe und man dann auch so anfängt, halt eine Multiplikation in einfache Schritte zu zerlegen, dann fällt einem ja auch wieder auf, dass eigentlich so diese ganze Computergeschichte, das ist ja wirklich nur Schichten und Schichten von Abstraktionen. Und dann, wenn man wiederum so drüber nachdenkt, na okay, man hat jetzt hier so höhere Mathematik, irgendwie so eine krasse Formel und dann bricht das alles auf Addition und Substraktion runter, dann endet man natürlich, wenn man das jetzt aufschreiben würde, mit wendemweisen voll Zahlen und Operationen. Aber die Sache ist halt, so ein Computer macht das halt einfach eine Million Mal pro Sekunde und ist dann am Ende trotzdem noch schneller, als wenn man irgendwie drei Stunden über der Formel brütet und immer noch nicht alles verstanden hat und das ausrechnet. Und diese ganzen Back-to-the-basics-Sachen, die sind wirklich echt erleuchtend auch für High-Level-Programmieren am Ende, wenn man doch irgendwie dann am Ende so ein bisschen mehr Gefühl hat, für was da eigentlich da drunter passiert. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel, wenn ich dann den Studenten an der Uni immer so erkläre, den Kunststudenten, die kriegen ja die abstrakte Variante davon, was da so für Abstraktionsebenen dazwischen liegen und dann so ok, jetzt habt ihr mal verstanden, vielleicht so ein bisschen wie ein Computer und so weiter funktioniert und jetzt zeige ich euch mal hier, euer Computer hat ja 3 Gigahertz, also 3 Milliarden Takte pro Sekunde und 4 Kerne und dann mache ich den Activity Monitor auf und ziehe einfach irgendein Fenster ganz schnell hin und her und der Activity Monitor geht dann halt so auf 37% von deiner CPU-Utilization nur um so ein Fenster mal schnell hin und her zu ziehen und einfach nur so um so 3 Milliarden Mal pro Sekunde tickern da die Bits durch und das braucht einfach ein Drittel deiner hochmodernen 21. Jahrhundert-CPU um Fenster von A nach B einigermaßen schnell und ruckelfrei zu bewegen mit Schlagschatten.
Mit Schatten und Transparenz und Skalieren eventuell.
Was da am Ende einfach für Zahlenketten durch diese CPU gepumpt werden müssen, um diese ganzen Layers of Abstraction wieder auszufalten in 3 plus 4 und dividiert durch 7 und hast du nicht gesehen. Das ist schon, ja.
Verstaunlich.
Das dazu.
Ich hätte sowas früher mal gebraucht. Ich glaube, wenn ich früher so die Gelegenheit gehabt hätte, mir so CPU-Kram von unten anzuschauen, dann wäre ich da vielleicht noch ein bisschen anders drauf abgegangen. Vielleicht wäre noch ein Hardware-Mensch aus mir geworden. Wer weiß es? Wer weiß es?
Keiner weiß es.
Hoddy.
Ja?
Wo wir gerade so bei Apps sind. Du hast da noch was.
Ja, das... Zumindest für mich irgendwie Nächte um die Ohren, Schlagermäßiges Spiel. Das heißt eigentlich Split, aber das I wird geschrieben wie ein Minus.
Ja, das ist für welche Plattform?
Es ist schwarz-weiß. Das ist jetzt erst mal irgendwie... Also so grafikmäßig macht das nicht viel her. Aber vielleicht erklär ich mal, wie das funktioniert. Also man hat eine Spielfläche und wenn man einmal tappt, dann wird die in zwei Teile geteilt. Und jetzt kann ich entweder die obere Hälfte oder die untere Hälfte wieder in zwei Teile teilen.
Mach doch mal Airplay.
Die Hörer können das eh nicht sehen. Genau, die Hörer können das eh nicht sehen. So, und jetzt ist es so, du machst immer abwechselnd eine horizontale und dann eine vertikale Linie. Und alle Flächen, die da sind, kannst du halt teilen. Bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt. Dann ist es nicht kleiner teilbar. Das Atom sozusagen. So, und vorbei ist, wenn du nicht mehr teilen kannst. Das Interessante ist, wenn nebeneinander vier gleich große Kästen sind, dann werden die unteilbar. Und bekommen den Wert der Teilungen, die du schon gemacht hast. Und das zählt mit jeder Teilung runter. Wenn die bei Null angekommen sind, verschwinden die und es schiebt sich alles runter, wie bei Tetris.
Das muss man glaube ich mal selber spielen.
Das musst du dreimal spielen und entweder legst du es dann wieder weg oder es lässt dich nicht mehr los. Also das ist wirklich so ganz absurd. Ich dachte auch so, was ist das für ein Spiel? Aber es ist wirklich super.
Also was ist denn jetzt das Ziel, auf Null zu kommen?
Das Ziel ist eine möglichst hohe Punktzahl zu bekommen. Wofür gibt es Punkte? Für alle Kästchen, die weggehen. Na ja, wie gesagt, wenn vier gleich große Kästchen nebeneinander sind, so im Viereck sind, dann werden die so grau und können nicht mehr geteilt werden. Und wie gesagt, die bekommen eine Zahl, hier das, und zwar die Zahl der bisher schon gewesenen Teilungen. Und für jede weitere Teilung zählen die runter. Wenn sie bei Null sind, gehen sie weg. Und Tetris-mäßig schiebt sich alles nach unten. Aber nur, wenn es auch passt. Also da sind so mehrere Konzepte verboten. Das ist ganz absurd. Und das Fiese ist, dadurch, dass du immer abwechselnd horizontal und vertikal teilst, gehen dir irgendwann die horizontalen oder die vertikalen Teilungsmöglichkeiten aus. Und man ist dann immer am Überlegen, wo teile ich denn jetzt so, dass ich möglichst ein schmales, also schmal hochkant oder flach vertikales Stück hab, was ich dann möglichst oft vertikal oder horizontal teilen kann, damit mir nicht eine der beiden Dinger ausgeht. Also es ist irgendwie...
So, wir gucken jetzt mal Tim zu, wie er teilt.
Noch mein bisheriger Highscore ist etwas über 50.000.
Okay, ich muss noch mal Chili's Palace-Level sagen.
Kann man immer nur in der Mitte teilen, ja? Ja, nein, du kannst immer nur einen Viereck teilen. Und das teilt sich immer in der Mitte. Und das kleine Männchen...
Jetzt hab ich also einmal sozusagen...
Genau, das kleine Männchen, das da oben ist, wenn es die Arme oben hat, dann teilst du vertikal. Wenn es die Arme zur Seite hat, teilst du horizontal.
Also wenn ich jetzt da oben hin tippe, dann werden da zwei draus.
Genau. Jetzt kannst du wieder horizontal tippen. Genau, immer abwechselnd.
Und was sollte ich jetzt nehmen?
Da links und rechts ist da egal.
Ist egal, mach irgendwas. Am Anfang hat man eh noch keine Sprechen.
Und wenn man jetzt aber links, wenn Tim jetzt links auch nochmal teilen würde, dann wären es vier gleiche. Ach nee, das ist... Ah, weil es immer wechselt. Verstehe.
Jaja, die Komplexität des Ganzen kommt erst später. Also richtig mit voller Kraft zum Tragen. Genau. Jetzt hast du vier gleiche Kästchen erzeugt. Du hast siebenmal geteilt. Das heißt, in jedem Kästchen, das jetzt grau schraffiert ist, ist eine 7 drin. So, bei der nächsten Teilung...
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Na ja, je größer die Zahl ist, die da drin steht, desto länger dauert es, bis es auf Null ist und die tatsächlich verschwinden. Sodass du neue, leere Kästchen bekommst.
Dann sind es vier leere Kästchen oder das ganze Feld ist dann leer?
Das ganze Feld verschwindet.
Jetzt muss ich es sozusagen schaffen, siebenmal weitere Teilungen zu machen und dann hab ich das wieder zurück. Oder hab ich da unten noch ne Menge Platz.
Genau, jetzt bist du bei sechs, jetzt bist du bei fünf. Also die Regeln, die klingen erst mal ganz... Ah ja, jetzt hast du da einen neuen Vierer-Pack erzeugt. Da muss man aufpassen, weil immer irgendwelche entstehen, die man gar nicht haben will. So, noch zwei.
Ganz pfiffig.
Genau, und jetzt gehen die weg und dann fällt da halt ein leeres Feld nach.
Das will man eigentlich, damit man so oft weiter tappen kann, wie man will, weil der eigentliche...
Genau, und es gibt noch ne Regel, die ich vergessen hab. So, wenn jetzt so ein grauschraffiertes Ding mit runterfällt, weil weiter unten was weggeht, dann halbieren sich die Zahlen. Das heißt, du willst eigentlich immer möglichst weit unten die Felder haben, die als nächstes weggehen, damit die, die oben drüber sind...
Unterfallen und schneller wegzählen.
Und schneller wegzählen, ja. Das ist schon vertragt.
auch dieses Spiel kommt ohne Schlumpfbeeren.
Ohne Schlumpfbeeren, kostet aber 3 Euro.
Muss man auch keine Facebook-Freunde einladen?
Ne. Das ist einfach runterladen und los geht's.
Und teilen.
Und teilen, ja.
Die weit in Konkar.
Guck, ich hab schon 160 Punkte.
Also, ihr wisst, die Aufgabe ist, 50.000 zu schaffen.
Aber wenn man erstmal viele, viele kleine Kästchen hat, dann sind ja auch diese davon... Okay, aber das Problem ist, die Zahlen werden immer größer.
Genau, die Zahlen werden immer größer. Es dauert immer länger, bis die dann tatsächlich verschwinden.
Okay, was hält mich davon ab? Achso, es gibt aber auch ein kleinstmögliches Feld.
Genau, es gibt ein kleinstmögliches Feld.
Sonst könnte man ja ewig teilen und immer die selben und so.
Das heißt, es lässt sich sozusagen auch nicht verhindern, dass man da...
Es lässt sich nicht verhindern, dass man sich irgendwann den Weg verbaut. Und ganz... So ein lustiger Nebeneffekt ist das Männchen, das immer die Arme hochhebt oder zur Seite tut, wenn man nicht mehr teilen kann, dann lässt es die Arme fallen und guckt betrübt.
Und dann hast du 50.000 Punkte gemacht.
Ja, das ist mir aber bisher nur einmal gelungen. Mein zweitbestes Ergebnis sind glaube ich so um die 40.000 gewesen. Ja, ich sag ja, das ist addiktiv.
Und läuft wahrscheinlich auch auf älteren Geräten noch einigermaßen schnell.
Naja, die Grafik ist jetzt nicht so super anspruchsvoll.
Und dann haben sie doch die Unity-Engine verwendet und es läuft nur mit 13 Frames die Sekunde.
Glaub ich nicht, das sieht alles handgemacht aus. Einschließlich diese sieben Segmentzahlen da oben.
Mit mundgeklöppelten Linien-Algorithmen.
Ich hab mir das jetzt nicht näher angeguckt, aber das mag durchaus sein.
Ich würd mir doch irgendwann nicht mehr los, diese ganzen Zahlen, das sind doch alle viel zu viele.
Ich tippe jetzt einfach mal so drauf rum, bis irgendwas passiert.
So machen das die Kinder, wenn sie nicht wissen, wie es geht.
Naja, so kriegt man es ja raus.
Und jetzt schaffst du es mit so einem random Getippe gleich die Highscore?
Nee, das dauert nicht mehr lange, dann ist Feierabend. Obwohl, da geht noch was weg. Du hast jetzt ein sehr schmales Hohes. Das heißt, du hast da potenziell sehr viele horizontale Teilungen drin. Das heißt, dir werden relativ schnell die vertikalen Teilungen rausgehen.
Ja, da haben wir heute echt schön Spiele-Content für die dunklen Nachmittage des Winters.
Herbstberatung. Die dunkle Seite des Jahres.
Herbstberatung. Jetzt muss ich noch sechs hier.
Weiter unten hast du noch ein paar Vertikale, die du teilen kannst.
Hier fallen aber gleich wieder welche runter. Zwei muss ich noch schaffen.
Hier ist noch einer vertikal. Da ist noch einer quer. Duft, duft. Ja, es geht voran hier.
Ja, so weitermass schaffst du noch 4000 Punkte. Ja, da sind sie ja.
Lustiges Spiel.
Contagious.
So, hier weiter.
Genau.
Lass uns weitermachen.
Einen hast du noch. Einen hast du noch. Und dann ist es vorbei. Nee, doch nicht.
Jetzt hab ich da die Null gerade ausgelöst.
Voll, Roddy.
Jetzt ist er traurig.
Keine Teile.
Naja, 4, 8, 6, 7.
125 Teilungen.
Das bringt mich übrigens zu dem Punkt, ich hab nämlich letztes Mal erzählt, dass ich irgendwie King of Jelly Splash bin. Ich hab überhaupt nicht gesagt, bis zu welchem Level ich vorgestoßen bin.
Ich dachte auch, du hast dich geschämt, weil ich 126 gesagt hab.
Da werden selbst die Kollegen gucken, wa?
Serious Business. Also, Tim hat es tatsächlich auf Level 477 geschafft. Und ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, da zockt man schon weich hin. Also, da spricht man schon von ernsthafter Sucht.
Wie viele Millionen Punkte hast du ihm rübergeschoben?
Noch gar keine, aber...
Punkte gibt es da gar nicht. Da gibt es nur...
Deine Statistik ist im Aufschwung. Freak Show erhält eine Menge Traffic.
Sagt mir gerade WordPress.
Dieses Moment, wo das wohl herkommt.
Und vielleicht zweimal aneinander voll slow.
Immer diese vorlauten Apps.
Aber ja, das ist beeindruckend tatsächlich.
Das ist auch wirklich beinhart und vor allem ohne irgendwelche Extras zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Ich bin wischlich schwer bei.
Wie würden Sie bei Quake sagen?
Killings-free. Aber das war unreal.
Ich muss echt nochmal mit dem Chef sprechen. Und einfach sagen, hier, guck mal, da. Gib dem jungen Mann doch mal den Kauf-Button. Oder den Unlock All. Und bezahl einmal. Nicht schlecht, also wow. Ich hätte jetzt mit vielem gerechnet, aber 477 finden.
Im Chat ist einer mit 394 dran.
Warte mal ab.
Der 400er-Block ist Hardcore.
Ich glaube, wenn die Sendung gestreamt ist, dann kommen da welche, die haben mich schon längst überholt. Und ich könnte wetten, die sind alle unter 15.
Also, wenn wirklich manche Level sind, dann wird die so brutal. Und dann denkt man, sitz mal wirklich tagelang auf diesem Level und dann so, was?
Wie auch immer, Prost! Gerade wieder im Chat.
Liebe Live-Hörer der Freak Show, ich fordere euch auf, eigentlich für das nächste Mal eine Bingo-Karte zu machen. Das würde mich mal interessieren. Da müssen mindestens 16 verschiedene Begriffe drauf stehen, würde ich sagen. So eine 4x4-Matrix müsste sich eigentlich mindestens finden, oder?
Ja, also Bom-Zack-Return, das kommt ja heutzutage nicht mehr so oft vor, aber immer mal wieder auch.
Man müsste halt mal finden, was sozusagen wirklich die Dinge sind, die auch häufig gesagt werden. Und dann kann man ja verschiedene Karten machen.
Es gibt doch bestimmt schon ein Webservice, um sich so Bingo-Karten zu machen.
Man kann so eine Casual Freak Show Bingo, wäre dann so eine 3x3-Matrix. Serious Freak Show Business ist halt so 4x4. Und so die Crown Freak Show Bingo ist 5x5. Ja, so 25 Freak Shit.
Aber gibt es nicht schon mittlerweile Web-Services oder irgendwelche Cloud Bingo-Provider, wo man sich einfach genauso...
Ganz bestimmt.
Ich meine, diese ganzen Bingo-Cards, die für die Keynotes gemacht wurden von Steve und so, die waren ja bestimmt auch nicht alle mundgepinselt.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite ist es jetzt nicht schwierig, ein 5x5-Feld zu machen und Text reinzukippen.
Das soll ja auch noch gut aussehen. Wir haben ja qualitativen Anspruch, wie wir schon am Anfang der Sendung feststellten. Beziehungsweise die Hörer. So.
Das war SPLT.
Oder Split, je nachdem, wie man es ausspricht.
Wir müssen jetzt mehr über Max reden.
Dann leg mal los.
Beugst du dich dem Clebeszid?
Hauptstrom.
Wieso? Was war der Hauptstrom?
Ach so.
Ja, wiss nicht. Ich muss ja noch ein bisschen nachtragen. Also vielleicht noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Apple hat irgendwie durchklingen lassen, dass sie demnächst Apple Pay in Hongkong, Singapur und, wait for it, Spanien rausbringen können. Im nächsten Jahr. Spanien.
Was hast du gegen Spanien?
Nix.
Und wo haben sie das durchklingen lassen?
Ich hab nur was dagegen, das sie nicht Deutschland gesagt haben. In ihrem Conference Call, diese Telefonsession nach der Bekanntgabe ihrer Quartalszahlen, wo sie dann immer sitzen und noch so ein bisschen genauer erläutern, was Phase ist und dabei haben sie diese Information mal so ganz dezent nebenbei fallen lassen.
Weil letztens gab es bei Apple Pay auch so einen Bericht, das, wo war das irgendwie, Osteuropa, Australien und noch irgendwie Land Europa, auch nicht Deutschland, aber dass da irgendwie Apple Pay wohl kommen soll, haben sie vermutet, weil auf irgendwelchen Google Maps schon Geschäfte auftauchen, mit denen man wohl mit Apple Pay bezahlen konnte und so.
Das war auch in Deutschland.
Ja, war es auch doch in Deutschland, ja.
Ja, das tauchte auf. Ich glaube, das war aber eher ein Fehler von Apple Maps.
Nee, sie haben, glaube ich, von Google geredet da, glaube ich. Mapservice auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, das kommt daher, weil so Leute wie Clemens halt mit irgendwelchen US-Karten und irgendwelchen Läden bezahlen, was sie ja hier auch in Deutschland schon machen, teilweise. Aber trotzdem gibt es halt hier kein Apple Pay. Das ist halt über ganz schräge Wege und mit US-Karten und vielleicht deswegen poppt das da auf diesen Maps halt schon auf.
Die Wege sind gar nicht so schräg. Das Ding ist, hier wären schon sehr viele Läden Apple Pay-fähig. Nur Apple hat halt hier mit den Karten-Providern der Deutschen noch keine Deals, die ausreichend zufrieden stellen sind. Oder sie sparen sich Deutschland auf, weil das hier nicht so ein Credit-Card-Country ist. Ich glaube, hier ist Cash Country.
Wir sind schon eine große Nation, das wird sich hier schon lohnen.
Ja, aber nicht im Bereich Electronic Payment.
Zumindest nicht mit Kreditkarten. Also ich meine, das was wir letztes Mal schon nicht richtig mit EC-Karten bezeichnet haben.
Also so ist das schon halb richtig. Wir sind hier nicht so das Land der Kreditkarten. Aber wir wären schon das Land von Kontaktlos bezahlen, bin ich schon der Meinung.
Ja, als Replacement für mit Karte bezahlen, aber da sind wir halt weit hinten.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, zahle ich die 7 Euro damit mit meiner EC-Karte. Dennis, kein Vergleich.
Geh mal nach Holland, da hast du schon Läden, da kannst du nur mit Karte zahlen.
Ich war in Holland, in einem Laden, da haben sie keine einen Euro, keine einen Cent-Stücke. Auch nicht rausgerückt.
Ist ja auch vernünftig.
Sie haben mir einfach einen Cent Wechselgeld vorenthalten.
Aber wenn du was mit sechs Cent bezahlen müsstest, müsstest du auch nur fünf geben, weil sie den einen dann auch nicht nehmen würden. Das ist in Skandinavien auch so. Das finde ich auch ganz gut. Die runden einfach mal auf fünf Cent oder auf welche Kronen.
Das war aber etwas unerwartet. Und ich fand es irgendwie auch frech. Aber egal.
Wie gesagt, die erlassen dir das auch. Wenn sechs Cent sind, musst du den einen Cent auch nicht bezahlen. Die runden einfach mal auf und ab.
Ich habe übrigens irgendwie einen oder zwei Tage nach der letzten Sendung meine neue Kreditkarte bekommen. Da ist auch so ein WLAN-Kaffeefilter mit Symbol drauf. Und da war so ein Zettel dabei, das funktioniert mit der Karte auch nur bis 25 Euro, wireless. Also es ist kein britisches Phänomen scheinbar.
Dann kriegst du ja am Biosupermarkt gerade mal drei Karotten für.
Ja, aber nur die kleinen.
Deswegen macht ja die Watch so viel Sinn. Oder das Telefon, weil du ja da noch eine zusätzliche Authentifizierung hast, während eben bei dieser Kreditkarte einfach nur der Besitz, also nicht der Besitz, sondern das, wie soll ich sagen, wie heißt das? Gibt der Unterschied zwischen Besitz und...
Eigentum?
Gab es denn noch einen anderen Begriff?
Na, bei Fahrzeughalt. Es gibt ja auch Fahrzeughalter und Fahrzeugbesitz.
Ja, wie auch immer es heißt. Also wenn du die Karte geklaut hast, dann kannst du damit halt für 25 Euro irgendwo durchwedeln. Und das geht halt mit der Apple Watch nicht. Deswegen ist es halt inherent sicherer.
Weißt denn jemand von euch was? Es gibt ja hier auch so Automaten, die haben da neben dem Pinpad noch so einen komischen Plastikblöppel draufgesetzt mit diesem Kaffeepfiltersymbol. Ist mir jetzt aufgefallen, jetzt wo ich bewusst auf dieses Kaffeesymbol...
Na, das ist dann dieser NFC-Räder.
Ja, aber was kann ich damit tun? Dann muss ich nicht mehr meinen Pin eingeben und kriege einfach direkt Geld entgegen geworfen? Underscheinlich.
Achso, beim Geldautomat?
Beim Geldautomat gibt es so einen Kaffeepfilter-Räder da dran und jetzt frage ich mich, was tut der denn dann eigentlich? Ich habe mich auch noch nicht getraut, den einfach mal da ranzuhalten.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die Alternative zu reinstecken. Aber du musst da wahrscheinlich immer noch deine Pin eingeben. Aber ich habe meine EC-Karten haben jetzt auch die Rupee oder wie das auch mal heißen mag. Die haben glaube ich keinen WLAN-Filter.
Genau, das hat auch nur meine ING-DiBa-Karte.
Bei mir hat es nur die Kreditkarte.
Das ist ja auch bei mir die ING-DiBa Hauptkarte. Also falls jemand das irgendwie weiß, von den Hörern vielleicht auch in die Kommentare oder per Twitter gerne nochmal Bescheid sagen, was ist dieser kleine Plastikblöppel bei Geldautomaten mit dem, der hat auch so 4 LEDs irgendwie und so, ist so ein echt kleines Kästchen, was da so neben dem Pinpad sitzt.
Hast du das bei mehr als einem Automaten gesehen? Bist du sicher, dass das legend ist?
Ja, das sind zum Beispiel diese Abzockerautomaten, wo man so 4,99 Euro, also hier von Bankhaus, Lenz und wie die heißen.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall sieht es so aus, als ob wir noch warten müssen. Oder es heißt auch nur, bei Spanien sind sie sich schon sicher und bei Deutschland sind sie sich noch nicht so sicher.
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass sie da so viel Zeit geholfen haben.
Auf dem europäischen Festland gibt es noch gar nichts. Also nur aus den Britannien gibt es eigentlich gar nichts in Europa. Oder an Apple Pay?
Es gibt sowieso derzeit nur USA und UK. Das sind die einzigen Länder. Und jetzt kommt Kanada dazu. Hongkong, ich glaube Singapur und Spanien. Und da hieß es halt 2016. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich wäre etwas überrascht, wenn das dann schon alle neuen Länder in 2016 wären. Also dass es jetzt wirklich noch 15 Monate mindestens dauern soll, bis irgendeins der anderen europäischen Länder da erreicht wird. Zumal ja das hier schon funktioniert. Das ist eine reine Sache des Deals.
Vielleicht haben sie das mal so fallen lassen, um irgendwo ihre Verhandlungsposition zu stärken.
Also ich würde das schon cool finden, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie bei da, wo ich einkaufen gehe, wo ich jetzt, ich zahle gerne mit EC-Karte, weil Bargeld will ich immer nicht ausgeben. Man muss sie nämlich nicht so oft abheben und so. Da muss man immer tippen, dann ist das Gerät so, dass da schon der nächste Kunde eigentlich steht, weil das am Anfang der Schlange ist, und nicht am Ende der Schlange sozusagen. Oder am Anfang vom Rollband, das ist immer ein bisschen unbequem. Dann tippst du, dann guckt der eine über die Schulter. Du musst dein Portemonnaie rausholen, du musst die Karte rausholen, dann lässt du dein Portemonnaie da liegen. Also alles ist irgendwie voll für den Arsch. Und eigentlich wär schon schick, wenn du so ein kleines Gerät hast, holst du dein iPhone raus, da kommt der Preis. Du siehst dann auch den Preis irgendwie gleich. Oder sieht man den Preis auf dem Display? Nee, sieht man gar nicht, oder?
Du siehst auf deinem Telefon, was du... und auf der Uhr siehst, was du bezahlen hast.
Die Summe.
Genau. Aber es ist auch geil.
Aber es ist hinterher.
Nee, vorher glaube ich.
Also du würdest dir dann auch eine Apple Watch nur dafür kaufen?
Nee, mein iPhone kann das. Deins auch.
Genau.
Und ich hab ja die Watch, deswegen brauch ich mir keinen iPhone 6 dafür zu kaufen.
Hast du Glück gehabt, aber...
Das hab ich so von langer Hand geplant. Nur Apple liefert jetzt nicht.
Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob es so richtig, richtig cool ist, aber es kostet jetzt auch nicht so viel Geld, weil so richtig Hardware müssen die eh nicht kaufen oder haben die schon gekauft und werden die eh kaufen. Und sie sollen es mal ausrollen. Wenn es keiner benutzt, dann tut es auch jetzt nicht so weh.
Naja, dauert auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen. Ansonsten, Geld scheint Apple ja genug zu haben. Keine Ahnung.
207 Billiarden Dollar im Ausland.
Gelagerte.
Billiarden, Billiarden.
Aus unserer Sicht Billiarden. Wir nennen das Billiarden. Nee, Quatsch, den nehmen wir eben nicht, genau. Die nennen das Billion, wir nennen das Milliarden.
Genau, irgendwo lasse ich einen Tweet, wo Tschechien gratuliert wurde, dass sie noch zwei Milliarden mehr Brutto-Sozialprodukt haben als irgendwie Apple.
Wie viele Griechenland-Rettungen sind das?
Also damit kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal den einen oder anderen Staat so fahren. Das ist schon alles ein bisschen frech.
Ja, aber eigentlich müsste man gucken, welche Staaten man jedes Jahr mit dem Apple-Gewinn fahren könnte und zwar auch jedes Jahr wieder. Also da sind schon so einige kleine Länderchen, die Apple finanzieren könnte so nebenbei. Theoretisch.
Aber nicht tun. Es ist absolut viel Kohle. Aber abgesehen jetzt von diesem ganzen Geldkram, fand ich erfreulich, dass die Macs nach wie vor im Plus sind. Im Plus sind.
Im Gegensatz zu den iPads.
5,7 Millionen war das jetzt in diesem Quartal. Wobei das mit den iPads, da glaube ich ja da dran, dass das nur so eine Konsolidierungsphase ist.
Ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht so richtig.
Ich glaube, das wird nichts mehr.
Die Dinger halten einfach zu lange. Mein Kumpel hat sein iPad 1. Ich glaube, jetzt inzwischen nutzt er ihn wirklich nicht mehr. Aber der hat ihn jahrelang benutzt und benutzt. Und dann denkst du auch, ja stimmt, der ist jetzt ein bisschen alt und ein bisschen lahm. Aber so richtig, wenn der doch noch so funktioniert, dann muss man sich jetzt auch nicht wirklich einen neuen kaufen. Also ich glaube, das sind so Dinger, die liegen einfach jahrelang rum.
Ja, aber irgendwann werden sie aktualisiert. Irgendwann sind sie kaputt oder irgendwann sind sie zu alt. Oder irgendwann sind sie dann auch...
Ja, aber wenn der Cycle halt doppelt oder dreimal so lange hält wie bei einem Phone oder wie bei einem Laptop, dann ist das dementsprechend auch von der Verkaufszahl dementsprechend weniger.
Ja, aber es ist ein Cycle. Es ist nicht so, dass die Leute, die sich einmal ein iPad gekauft haben, nie wieder eins kaufen. Sondern irgendwann kaufen sie sich wieder eins. Und wenn dieser Zyklus dann auch irgendwann mal signifikant anzieht, dann ist der halt da. Und dann addiert sich das auch auf die anderen Verkaufszahlen mit drauf. Außerdem denke ich, dass das auch schon ganz anders ausgesehen hätte, wenn es nicht so Sachen wie das 6 Plus gäbe. Weil das 6 Plus nagt halt auf einer wichtigen Stelle rein. Weil das Tablet war ja auch gerade die Dinger mit SIM-Karte. War halt von Leuten, die mehr sehen wollen. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Die einfach größeres Display haben wollen. Und auch da ist natürlich das 6 Plus eine Konkurrenz. Das ist nicht der einzige Grund oder so, aber es ist definitiv eine Option, sodass das an der Stelle das iPad kannibalisiert.
Ich halte es immer noch für ein großes Problem, dass es kein gesundes Third-Party-Software-Ökosystem gibt. Für alles, was iOS ist.
Aber das ist meiner Oma zum Beispiel egal.
Ja gut, sicher, klar.
Die ist ja auch mit dem iPad, was ich ihr da schon mal gemacht hab, auf lange Zeit bedient.
Ja, nur dann, weißt du, wenn du eigentlich mit dem iPad nichts anderes machst als Browser, dann hat Apple natürlich auch wieder ein Differenzierungsproblem gegenüber den Android-Geräten.
Also ich denke im Bereich Games haben sie durchaus...
Guggelsoma auch egal, glaube ich.
Nee, sie spielt Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel.
Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel?
Kreuzwort. Ich glaube auch. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das alleine herausgefunden hat oder ob meine Schwester hier geholfen hat, aber sie ist ja immer noch sehr fit und so und die macht auch immer Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel und hat irgendwie einfach ein riesiges Allgemeinwissen und rattert so ein Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel auch relativ schnell durch in so einer gewöhnlichen Tageszeitung. Und dann hat ihr, glaube ich, meine Schwester oder so so eine Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel-App installiert und jetzt ist sie da, fräst sie sich da durch die Kreuzfahrt-Rätsel durch halt, ne? Also, die spielt da überschaubar wenig natürlich, aber spielt auch was. Und die Wikipedia hier, dieses Articles, das hat sie auch. Also zwei bis drei Apps hat sie schon installiert.
Siehst du mal, also ich glaub nicht daran, dass die iPads verschwinden werden. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was sie an Innovationen da noch liefern können an den Geräten. Gut, also schneller, höher, leichter.
Aber willst du wissen, warum ich mir kein neues iPad kaufe?
Hast du denn überhaupt schon eins?
Ja, geht die Batterie kaputt, hab ich gehört, von den Mitarbeitern.
Das ist noch mal übrigens Anhängerkupplung mit der Batterie kaputt, ja?
Kurz mal eine Klammer aufmachen.
Ingo-Style.
Auf welches Thema willst du jetzt raus?
Auf den Tesla. Muss ich ganz kurz mal einschieben. Ich glaub, wollte ich letztens auch mal, bin da nicht dazu gekommen.
Okay, wir haben zur Kenntnis genommen, dass viele Macs verkauft werden und alles.
Applaus, Applaus.
Ja, ich find's gut, genau. Haben sie gut gemacht. Nee, aber wenn da so ein Anhänger dran ist, dann hat der Motor ja schon ordentlich mehr zu tun. Und das halt die ganze Zeit. Natürlich. Und nicht nur bei so einem kurzen Sprit über Sprint. Und das geht schon auf Batterie und eventuell sogar auf den Motor. Und dann kann es schon sein, dass sie das erstmal gesagt haben, ja, nee, das ist vielleicht erstmal nicht so eine coole Idee. Wobei das stimmt auch nicht, weil ich glaube, sie wollen ja doch irgendwo nachliefern.
Also ich glaube, der Motor ist nicht wirklich das Problem an der Stelle. Aber das Model X gibt es ja wohl jetzt mit Anhängerkupplung. Zumindest haben sie es mit Anhängerkupplung über die Bühne gefahren bei dem Launch-Event, was so klingt, als wäre das eine ganz normale Option, die man anklicken kann.
Ja, das war ja nur ein kurzer Einwurf.
Ist ja auch ein SUV.
Es ist auch ein SUV, ja.
Und suft nicht wie Sau.
Allerdings so SUV-ig finde ich den nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Die Beschreibung Minivan passt dann doch besser als SUV. Aber vielleicht verkauft sich die Bezeichnung SUV in Ameland besser.
Jetzt reden wir doch nochmal über Mac Accessoire. Kannst du uns das mal vorführen, auch wenn du jetzt gleich darüber sprichst? Also quasi rumgeben. Dein neues Bluetooth-Accessoire. Ach so, das weiße. Das sieht ja gar nicht so fett aus, wie es auf den Bildern aussah.
Mit der Werbung bin ich aber jetzt nicht so glücklich.
Mit der Werbung?
Ist das Ding aus jetzt?
Das klickt aber nicht hier irgendwo.
Mach's aus, ich mach's aus, ne?
Dann mach hinten mal aus, ja. Aber es hilft natürlich nicht viel, wenn's aus ist.
Ja, das ist dreckig, mann Timmer ey.
Kannst du es nicht schnell mit deinem Rechner koppeln?
Ja, gib mal Kabel.
Dann hab ich keine Maus hier an meinem.
Lass jetzt einfach nur mal angucken. Ich will's ja nur einmal.
Das ist gar nicht so leicht, wie ich dachte. Das heißt, es ist gar nicht so scheiße.
Da ist ein Akku drin.
Ich hab gedacht, das ist so ein ganz leichtes Ding irgendwie.
Das liegt gut auf. Also ich kann ja mal ein bisschen erzählen. Erstens gab es ja die Befürchtung von uns allen, oder von euch, oder von mir, dass...
150 Euro zu viel bezahlt sind.
Ja, weil das Ding ja eigentlich mit Bluetooth 4 nur laufen soll.
Ja, aber es läuft doch.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, worauf sich das beziehen soll. Ich hab das Ding mit Lightning da ran gesteckt, dann war es gepairt, dann hab ich Lightning abgezogen, da war das ein Bluetooth-Device und warum auch nicht.
Das stand als Systemvoraussetzung auf der Webpage.
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich habe keinen Anhaltspunkt, was das Ding mit Bluetooth 4 noch anders tun soll, oder können soll im Vergleich zu...
Also jetzt hier, ich werfe mich mal wieder ein, ja? Das Ding kann gar kein Bluetooth 4. Weil der Chip ist da drin, wie iFixit geschrieben hat, sind alle Bluetooth 3.
In dem Trackpad?
Ja, in allen drei Geräten ist der gleiche Chip.
Der kann gar kein Bluetooth-Ihr-Kram?
Aber ich habe gar keine Auto.
Genau, alle drei Geräte können nur Bluetooth 3. Haben die so geschrieben. Wenn das stimmt, dann ist das nur Bluetooth 3. Und es ist sogar so, dass ausreicht, damit sie funktionieren, ist wohl Bluetooth 2 sogar auf der Gegenseite nur nötig.
Ja, und so ist es ja bei mir auch.
Also groß ist es schon, das muss man mal sagen. Und es ist auf jeden Fall...
Ist auch rutschiger als das Alte, das stimmt wirklich. Also die Oberfläche ist sehr auch leicht angeraut, damit man eben keine sich ansaugenden Flächen haben, die total glatt sind und dass dein Finger da irgendwie klebt. Gib mal das Alte her, genau. Hast du das Alte noch?
Mein Finger verbringt acht Stunden am Tag auf dem Alten.
Deins ist auch so eingespeckt, das kann man jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr so verstehen.
Sollen wir mal den Double Blind Test machen? Hier ist mein Finger, du legst jetzt irgendeins drunter.
Nochmal.
Und was war das Erste, was war das Zweite?
Das Erste, das Rutschigere war das Neue und das Zweite war jetzt das Alte.
Also das Zweite ist rutschiger, das Alte ist rutschiger.
Nein, das Erste war das Neue, das Zweite war das Alte.
Ja, stimmt. Und das sei rutschiger, das Alte, sagst du?
Hab ich das falsch gesagt. Nein, das Erste war...
Ich weiß nicht genau, was rutschiger sein soll.
Das Erste rutschte sich besser.
Das rutschte sich besser.
Ja, rutschiger, genau.
Okay, das Zweite ist glatter. Das Neue ist angerauter.
Es gleitet besser.
Es hat mehr Grip. Also es ist schon okay. Und mit dem... Wie heißt es noch gleich?
Force-Touch.
Das hat einfach den riesen Vorteil, dass man eben den Klick überall hat. Das macht sich schon positiv.
Und den spürt man dann auch. Der hat ja auch diesen... oder?
Ja klar.
Muss er ja haben. Jetzt wo er aus war, konnte man ja nicht klicken.
Jetzt ist er gerade irgendwie überhaupt nicht da.
Wo bin ich denn gerade?
Bin ich überhaupt irgendwo? Ist das noch ausgeschaltet?
Kaputt.
Eigentlich nicht.
Jetzt ist er connected. Hat eine Weile gedauert. Soll ich gerade ausprobieren?
Force-Touchen.
Ah ja, du sollst mal hier ein bisschen Klick so an.
So, ich beschreibe das jetzt mal. Ich fahre jetzt mit meinem Finger hier so drüber. Und jetzt drücke ich. Oh ja, merkt man aber richtig gut. Das fühlt sich so richtig so an, als wenn das ganze Ding runter und hoch geht. Das geht nicht runter und hoch.
Es bewegt sich auch ein bisschen, aber im Wesentlichen ist es halt so, dass der Rückstoß von diesem Taptic fuhr. Du kannst halt überall diesen Effekt erzeugen. Egal wo du halt drauf drückst. Und das ist schon cool, weil vorher ging es halt, klickte es sich nur gut unten.
Okay, ich kann ganz rechts oben klicken und hab den anderen Finger ganz links unten und der spürt trotzdem total volle Pulle diesen Klick, weil der natürlich gleichmäßig erzeugt wird. Der ganze Tisch wackelt wahrscheinlich in dem Augenblick. Wenn man so einen Tischennachbarn hat, der spürt das die ganze Zeit, wenn man drückt, ist das auch securitymäßig wahrscheinlich gar nicht gut. Nee, aber fühlt sich wirklich wie ein echter Klick an. Find ich gut.
Die Nützlichkeit von diesem Force-Touch...
Will auch nochmal klicken.
Die Nützlichkeit von diesem Force-Touch, die ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar.
Du meinst 3D-Touch oder Force-Touch?
Na hier ist es ja Force-Touch.
Ich glaube, die haben das bestimmt insgesamt.
Das fühlt sich ja wirklich wie ein Klick an. Das ist ja verrückt.
Jaja, das ist ja schon bei dem Air so.
Also ich glaube bei den Trackpads ist es Force-Touch und bei der Apple Watch ist es auch Force-Touch. Und beim Phone ist es 3D-Touch.
Aber hast du denn da 3D-Touch? Also das, wenn du richtig doll durchdrückst, hast du ein Kontextmenü?
Ja, du kannst jetzt hier so ein Wort markieren und dann einfach mal durchdrücken.
Wow, hat er aber jetzt wirklich nur ein Wort. Das fühlt sich ja echt an wie klicken.
Das ist ja verrückt.
Also das haben sie schon wirklich perfekt gemacht.
Das haben sie doch wirklich erstaunlich gut.
Das ist bei der Maus, bei der neuen aber nicht so, oder?
Das muss ich auch klicken hier.
Timme, bei der neuen Maus ist das noch nicht so. Da haben sie weiter diesen physikalischen Klick, oder?
Maus, Maus, wir sind die Sendung mit dem Trackpipes.
Wir sind die Sendung ohne Maus.
Die Sendung ohne Maus.
Was war nochmal die Frage?
Ja, wir sind raus.
Ich klick die Maus, ich klick die Maus. Das ist gleich das Lied von Helge Schneider noch ein.
Ich hab gefragt, ob die neue Maus auch einen Force-Touch hat oder nicht.
Maus.
Nein, hat sie nicht.
Die Maus hat's nicht, die Maus hat noch physische Klicks.
Die Maus ist im Prinzip genauso wie vorher. Also die ist...
Du bist auf den Anschluss nach unten. Mann, ey, wirklich, wie kann man das verkacken?
Ich find das völlig nachvollziehbar und total okay.
Nee, es ist halt nur dazu da, um mal kurz aufzuladen.
Du bist halt kein Kabelnutzer, ne?
Das macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Kabelmäuse sind einfach Keks.
Nee, die sind geil.
Doch, doch.
Mäuse sind überhaupt Keks.
Du bist kein Zocker, oder? So eine Funkenmaus ist einfach fucking zu langsam.
Mir ist sie zu schwer. Weil da sind Batterien und Akkus drin.
Nee, schwer ist okay. Die muss gut rutschen. Schwer ist egal. Die muss gut rutschen und die muss verdammt nochmal keine Latenz haben. Und diese Funk-Dinger bisher alle, die haben einfach Latenz.
Ja, das ist nicht präzise ja noch.
Wenn du da so ein Zockerspiel spielst, dann merkst du, dass es geht mit so einer Funkenmaus.
Dafür ist diese Maus halt nicht gemacht.
Und ergonomisch ist das halt auch eine Katastrophe, dass das Apple da macht.
Dann hab ich zwei Mäuse an meinem Rechner, oder? Wenn Apple irgendwie will, dass die Leute auch mal irgendwie zocken, dann sollen sie auch passende Mäuse verkaufen.
Ich glaub gar nicht, dass Apple so drauf ist, dass du zockst.
Hätte ich schon gern.
Du hast dein Geld ja schon komplett verzockt, als du das Gerät gekauft hast.
Ja, also ich glaube, diese Maus, die eignet sich zum Zocken mal so gar nicht.
Ja, die Maus ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was die... Also ich verstehe, dass es Anwendungsgebiete gibt, wo eine Maus sinnvoll ist, aber ich bin schon lange über die Maus hinweg.
Ich auch, mausfrei.
Ich weine den Mäusen keine Träne nach. Dieses permanente Zettelgeschiebe auf den Tisch, damit man irgendwie den Platz hat und dieses Umsetzen und das Alter, ganz der Wahnsinn.
Dann dreck Dinger, da brauchst du dafür mehr Platz.
Nein.
Na klar.
Das ist Quatsch.
Meine Maus braucht auch nicht mehr Platz als das. Die liegt da so und ich bewege das ungefähr so, das war's.
Also ich hab festgestellt, dass wenn es unbedingt sein muss, und man hat wirklich wenig Platz auf dem Schreibtisch, reicht auch die Fläche einer Zigarettenschachtel.
Die Zeiten, wo du deine Maus hast, wenn du so einen halben Quadratmeter zur Seite ziehst, um auf die andere Bildschirmehälfte zu kommen, die sind vorbei. Man stellt die ultra fein ein. Am Anfang ist das ein bisschen hektisch, aber deine Hand gewöhnt sich dran. Und deine ganzen Kapaltunnel, wie auch immer die alle heißen, werden es dir danken, weil du deine Hand nur noch wirklich ganz leicht bewegst und sonst nix mehr. Dieses ganze Hin und Her und so, das ist alles vorbei.
Funktionieren die jetzt auch auf Gucksspiegel?
Ich hab so eine schwarze Laser-Maus, die funktioniert ziemlich gut, außer auf meinem Ikea-Stuhl, da spinnt die rum wie Sau. Ich weiß nicht, warum. Sogar auf meinem Glastisch geht die einigermaßen auf dem Ikea-Stuhl. Keine Chance. Das wackelt und die läuft da rum von alleine. Das ist unglaublich. Volles Eigenleben.
Das ist alles vollkommen gaga. Und Trackpads lösen einfach diese Probleme. Und vor allem, du hast viel mehr Gespür in so einem Trackpad.
Aber du kannst damit nicht zocken.
Davor hast du kein 3D-Force-Quatsch.
Brauche ich ja auch nicht, weil ich habe ja da schon eine Taste unter meinem Finger.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn ich zocken will, dann habe ich halt eine Zockmaus. Also das ist irgendwie so.
Ja, Zockmaus jetzt, ja.
Haben sie auch Zockmäuse?
Okay, also zusammenfassen, du bist happy zufrieden. Ich muss sagen, haptisch ist das Ding sehr cool. Ob ich es benutzen würde, weiß ich nicht, aber es fässt sich gut an und ich finde, das ist auch mal sehr, sehr...
Also wenn ich eins hätte, ich würde es sofort benutzen, aber 150 Euro sind mir vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu viel.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber da ist nix Premium dran irgendwie.
Doch, hat ein Akku und hat...
Das Kabel nach hinten.
Also wenn du dir die drei Geräte mal anguckst...
Vor allem man kann es ausschalten.
Dann ist dann all drei Geräte mehr oder weniger das gleiche Board drin. Das ist der gleiche ARM-Chip immer, der gleiche Bluetooth-Chip mehr oder weniger, der gleiche Batterie-Lade-Controller-Chip irgendwie.
Die haben einem Typen gesagt, warum sollte sich das auch groß unterscheiden?
Genau, aber die Maus kostet 70 Euro. Das kostet irgendwie das Doppelte. Da ist nichts anderes, außer das Ding, was diesen Force-Touch macht.
Da hast du erstmal diese Glas-Oberfläche und du hast hier diese ganze Taptic-Engine drin. Es ist was anderes.
Dafür hat die Maus ihren Lasert unten drunter und ihr Taster und so was halt.
Das ist kein Laser.
Laser-LED nennen die das.
Laser-Maus.
Okay, ich denke, wir haben uns jetzt genug über Feinheiten, die am Ende kein Interessieren unterhalten.
Deswegen hören wir unsere Sendung, Mann. Ist so.
Wir unterhalten uns über die Kugel.
Hat es jemand schon über sich gebracht, einen Apple TV zu bestellen, außer Roddy, der den Hintern geschoben bekommen hat?
Ladenhüter.
Warte mal, warte mal, wo wir noch bei Zubehör waren. Ich habe von Peter aus München eine Tastatur geschickt bekommen, dafür vielen Dank. Und zwar eine von den Kleinen mit Kabel.
Kannst du nochmal bitte die Tastatur bestellen?
Goldstaub, sag ich dir nur, Goldstaub. Wir müssten eigentlich mal so eine Liste, nicht zu vergessen, ein Apple Gerät aufstellen, dann ist diese Tastatur wahrscheinlich dabei. Der Mac Pro, die Extended, von damals diese Tastatur, Extended 2 und noch so ein paar andere.
A1242. Sagen wir es nochmal.
Also ich habe mich gefreut wie Hulle, weil jetzt habe ich so eine Tastatur. Und die deutsche ist übrigens richtig. Ich bin ein Benutzer deutscher Tastatur Layouts.
Und du Huckel, hast du auch schon eine bekommen?
Nein, ich will ja gar keine. Ich finde ja die mit Keypad International English. Das ist ja mein Steckenpferd, mit dem ich so bei den verschiedenen Programmieraufgaben hausiere.
Okay, also die nächste A1242, die noch irgendwo vom Lastwagen fällt, die nehme ich dann.
Kriegst wieder du.
Du hast da schon eine.
Ja, jetzt geht es halt wieder von vorne los.
Ich habe ja auch mehrere Computer.
Das andere ist dann diese Funk-Tastatur mit der Batterierolle hinten dran. Und die willst du noch nicht ersetzen gegen diese neue Tastatur?
Ich habe wirklich keinen Tastatur-Mangel. Ich habe irgendwann mal viel zu viele Tastaturen gekauft. In irgendeinem Waren, wo ich dachte, mir würden Tastaturen fehlen.
Dann kriege ich irgendwo so einen Schublader auf.
Ich habe noch eine Funk-Tastatur über. Also ich habe sozusagen Spare.
Welches Layout nimmst du denn?
Und ich habe auch, glaube ich, Deutsch. Ich glaube, ich habe auch sogar, warte mal, ich muss nochmal gucken.
Ich habe hier auch irgendwo noch so eine große. Nee, doch.
Nee, doch.
Doch.
Oh, ich habe noch eine A1242. Wow, hast du mal nicht hier alles entdeckt?
Also ist wieder Dennis dran.
Tatsache.
Geil, ich habe zwei A12.
Das habe ich hier nicht im Einsatz.
Hast du dir für schwere Zeiten noch zurückgelegt?
Ja, die habe ich in der Raspberry Pi Tüte.
Warum auch immer. Für den Raspberry Pi natürlich. Ein bisschen groß vielleicht.
Die Tastatur? Das ist die kompakteste Tastatur mit USB-Kabel, die man so da dranballern kann.
Eigentlich könnte Apple so einen Raspberry Pi mal gleich mit in die Tastatur einbauen.
Ja, sowas gibt es ja jetzt auch schon so.
Bei den Preisen, die die aufrufen, könnten die das ohne Verlust machen.
Ja, wie den C64 damals. Aber das war auch so.
Ich wollte es nicht sagen.
Irgendwer meint auch schon, es kann nicht mehr lange dauern, bis der Rechner bei Apple in der Tastatur drin ist. Aber haben sie am Bildschirm schon, ist ja genug Platz.
So, ihr habt alle keine Apple TV.
Und auch keinen Bedarf.
Ich bin noch so ein bisschen... Weiß nicht. Vielleicht warte ich einfach noch mal bis die ersten Wundermeldungen kommen.
Bis die nächsten 500 Flatterklicks da sind.
Ja, mich interessiert das natürlich vor allem. Also ich muss mir eigentlich eine kaufen, einfach aus meinem Beobachterstatus heraus.
Bist du internationaler Beobachter oder was?
Ja, es interessiert mich natürlich wie Hulle, was sich da jetzt Podcast-App technisch entwickelt, weil wird sicherlich nicht lange auf sich warten lassen, bis wir halt auch, was weiß ich, so was wie Overcast auf TV OS sehen. Warum solltest du halt jetzt nicht auch für diese Plattform einen dedizierten Podcast klar entbauen?
Geile Podcasts auf 46 Zoll Fernseher hören.
Also ich weiß, dass Timo Hetzel dabei ist, seine Bits und so App irgendwie auf die Apple TV zu bringen.
Ich hör auch von verschiedenen Richtungen. Jeder, der vor allem Video-Material auf Halda hat, wird sich da was stricken. Zumal es wohl recht einfach ist, man muss ja jetzt noch nicht mal so eine Native App machen, sondern es reicht ja, dass du deinen Content in diesem TV-ML und TV-JS Markup-Kram und JavaScript bereitstellst und dann hast du im Prinzip schon so deinen Grund gerüst.
Da muss ich sagen, damit habe ich mich nicht beschäftigt, weil so Dinge, die JS am Ende heißen, das interessiert mich nicht ganz so sehr.
Ich will nur sagen, du kannst halt so templateartig sagen, hier ist mein Content und dann hast du den so quasi generisch. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob man dafür noch so einen leeren App-Container, der mit irgendwelchen Standard-Frameworks gelingt ist und ein eigenes Icon hat, noch bereitstellen muss. Und dann saugt man sich da rein und ruft aber nur noch Systemfunktionen ab, um das dann sozusagen als User-Interface hinzurennen. Ich vermute, dass es so ist. Ich weiß bloß nicht genau.
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen, aber ich kann es mir ja mal angucken.
Genau, das können wir demnächst mal angehen, weil ich schätze mal zur nächsten Sendung dürfte dann dieser ganze Fu auch schon über uns hereingebrochen sein. Die Geräte werden nächste Woche ausgeliefert und dann geht es halt ab. Ansonsten hält sich mein Excitement jetzt auch in Grenzen. Ich weiß bloß halt nicht, kaufe ich mir jetzt das kleine oder kaufe ich mir das dicke?
Ja, interessanter Reisewechsel.
Wahrscheinlich bei der ersten Generation reicht erst mal die kleine, weil so viel wird ja am Anfang jetzt erst mal noch nicht kommen. Oder du planst vielleicht die für Jahre zu haben und nicht abzugraben, denn irgendwann ist der Cycle schon ein bisschen länger, bis die dann neue rausbringen.
Ja, ich denke halt auch immer so im Hinblick auf Zeug speichern und so lange.
Wiederverkaufswert, Modell.
Aber weiß man am Ende nicht.
Also bei dem Developer-Ding haben sie sich nicht die Mühe gemacht, dazu zu schreiben, ob es die kleine oder die große ist. Aber ich glaube, es ist die kleine.
Davon kannst du wohl mal schwer ausgehen, dass es die kleine ist.
Wenn es nicht sogar ein noch stärker abgespecktes Modell ist.
Womit machen wir weiter?
Schlag uns doch mal was vor.
FreeBSD auf Apple Hardware haben wir da.
Genau, das bleiben wir noch beim Mac-Thema.
Klappt das mal auf.
Wie viele Kilometer Notizen kommen da?
Warum kann man eigentlich an den Punkten nicht sehen, ob da überhaupt was kommt oder nicht?
Doch, siehst du doch. Wenn die so komisch umrandet sind, kommt noch was.
Wenn die so ein Hallo haben.
Hab ich gesehen, ich dachte, okay, okay.
Warte mal, geht's jetzt um Mac ausbauen?
Nee, Software.
Aber ist ja schon auch ein bisschen, oder?
Ja, so ein Kanzelspiel ein. Ist zwar nichts gepimpt, aber...
Ist nicht gepimpt?
Nicht wirklich.
Immer wieder eine Freude.
Und wieder kaputt. Also ihr wisst ja hier, wir haben ja, Timme auch und ich haben einen Mac Pro. Wobei das eigentlich egal ist, das geht jetzt mit den MacBook Pros auch. Und zwar, die können ja nicht nur Open, Quatsch nicht Open, OS X fahren, sondern manche haben ja sogar auch Linux drauf. Aber ich bin ja nicht so der Linux-Freak und deswegen, ich benutze halt FreeBSD. Und FreeBSD hatte bis vor einer Weile immer das Problem, dass die halt kein EFI-Bootloader hatten. Und dann konnte man zwar wohl FreeBSD benutzen, so über den Bootcamp-Trick mit MBR, mit dem Master Boot Record, so wie man halt Windows bootet. Glaub ich jedenfalls, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, das hab ich nie gemacht. Aber ich glaube, das ging mir nicht mit Refit und so. Jedenfalls, schon letztes Jahr, glaube ich, irgendwann haben die dann bei FreeBSD ihren EFI-Bootloader gehabt. Und das sorgte dafür, dass man dann auf einem Mac Pro und auch auf dem Macbook Pro, dass man FreeBSD mit diesem EFI-Bootloader booten konnte. Das ging auch irgendwann mal bei mir zu Hause, aber auch nur, wenn die richtige Grafikkarte drin war. Dann hab ich die ja gewechselt, dann ging das nicht mehr. Also er bootete FreeBSD, aber man hat kein Bild gesehen. Das haben die jetzt auch alles gefixt. Das funktioniert jetzt super cool. Da kommt jetzt auf jeden Fall immer ein Bild, auch egal, welche Grafikkarte drin ist und so. Und ist alles schick. Was aber noch nicht ging, also die Links dazu haust du alle später rein. Die muss ich jetzt nicht erwähnen.
Erwähnen kannst du sie ja trotzdem.
Soll ich das mal machen? Ich hab den Workflow hier irgendwo offen.
EFI-Support hat Apple nicht doch.
Nee doch, Apple hat nur EFI. Das ist halt eben das Ding.
Teilweise relativ ranzig bei älteren Geräten. Aber das war am Rande.
Die ersten machen ja auch alle gar keinen EFI, sondern die machen inzwischen alle UEFI, was wohl auch schon ein bisschen was anderes ist. Ich hab dir die Unterschiede noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Aber die PCs, die kommen jetzt gerade alle mit. Die haben aber natürlich noch im Bios den Schalter zwischen EFI und nicht EFI. Und natürlich schalten die noch alle um. Oder ich glaube, die sind noch nicht so richtig so weit. Ich weiß nicht so genau. Vielleicht aber auch schon. Und die Leute meckern wieder, dass wir wieder keine Ahnung haben. Aber die kommen auf jeden Fall mit Dual-Support in ihrem Bios. Und ja, jedenfalls, also, man kann FreeBSD jetzt mit Max booten, weil halt die das jetzt mit dem EFI Bootloader alles schicken können. Was aber noch nicht geht und auch offiziell immer noch nicht ist, dass man halt auch sein ZFS-basierendes FreeBSD damit booten kann. Weil bisher konnte der Bootloader halt nur UFS und konnte mit ZFS noch nichts anfangen. Und da gibt es irgendeinen Typen, der schon im Juni einen Patch gemacht hat. Und da muss man halt wirklich dann seinen Kern irgendwie den Patch rüberspielen, neu bauen, machen und tun, den Bootloader da ist irgendwie... Dieser EFI-Bootloader ist in Wirklichkeit ein mini, mini FAT-Filesystem. Und dann muss da irgendwie so was rein und der muss irgendwie als Partition da hinter dem GPT liegen oder die erste Partition sein oder den Loader-Typ haben, wie auch immer das genau läuft.
Damit das EFI sozusagen mit dem Filesystem was anfangen kann.
Ja, das EFI lädt dieses Filesystem, da drin sind die richtigen Files. Wahrscheinlich der nächste Loader, das ist ja mal so ein Stages irgendwie und dieser Loader da drin, der kann jetzt halt auch dein ZFS, der kann dann das ZFS, den Kernel lesen und noch irgendwelche anderen Dateien und dann legt der los und jedenfalls diesen Patch habe ich dann nachdem so ein Franzose im August geschrieben hat, dass er das ausprobiert und das ging, weil ich habe immer kein Bock was zu probieren, wenn das eventuell gar nicht funktioniert. Der meinte, das geht jetzt, habe ich auch gemacht und habe irgendwie da ein bisschen gesessen und MS-DOS und Mount und Unmount und Files reinschreiben und so und das tut. Und jetzt kann ich sozusagen meinen Mac Pro, wenn dann irgendwann mal ein neues Update kommt und der dann nicht mehr, der dann sozusagen bei El Capitan hängen bleiben würde, weil die das nicht mehr weiter supporten, weiß schon irgendwann wird er ja rausfliegen, der ist ja nun ja schon von 2009, dann muss er nicht irgendwie elendig weiter mit El Capitan veraltet irgendwie sich rum ärgern, sondern dann kann ich den halt schön nativ irgendwie FreeBSD mit allen Bangs und Whizzles und wie das so heißt irgendwie... Ja Bangs auch. Bells and Bangs. Booten und ist alles schick und macht Spaß. Und das finde ich ist schon ein großer Schritt.
Aber ich glaube der Mac Pro der wird schon noch...
Die nächste OS auch noch mitmachen?
Das nächste mindestens. Und eigentlich auch noch das übernächste.
Also früher waren die bei Apple mal richtig schlimm mit dem Rauschmeißen. Gerade sind die da relativ entspannt. Das kann auch mal wieder kommen. Dann sagen sie, okay jetzt nur noch Geräte, die wirklich nur noch Bluetooth irgendwas können oder wirklich alle USB 3 haben oder irgendwie so. Ich weiß nicht.
Warum sollte das so sein?
Also die letzten Runden waren ja erst flogen die 32-Bit-CPUs raus und dann flogen die Geräte raus, für die es keine 64-Bit-Grafiktreiber gab. Und seitdem ist eigentlich nichts mehr rausgeflogen.
Ja, also es war wirklich sehr...
Sind nicht dann noch mal Rechner rausgeflogen, die hier nicht grafikmäßig irgendwie ein gewisses Set quasi quarzmäßig was unterstützt haben?
Nee, ich glaube der Grund waren die Grafiktreiber, die nicht 64-Bit-kompatibel waren. Aber ist auch egal.
Ja, und es waren eigentlich auch immer nur so CPU. Ich meine, vorher war es PowerPC, was rausgefallen ist. Das ist ja jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschend. Also es war im Prinzip diese komplette CPU-Transition von den alten PowerPCs auf...
Es sind mehrere kleine Schritte, um insgesamt von PowerPC nach 64-Bit-Intel umzuswitchen, mit so ein paar Zwischenschritten.
Und jetzt geht es halt bis 2008 teilweise. Oder gibt es, glaube ich, so irgendein 2007er-Gerät noch? Weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau welches, aber ordentlich. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir sieben oder acht Jahre Support-Span von einem OS-Release.
Gut, die Windows-Anhänger, die werden jetzt lachen, aber... Nein, weil du natürlich auch ein relativ altes Windows noch... Also, nee, du...
Die Frage ist, ob du ein relativ neues Windows auf einem relativ alten PC ohne weiteres zum Laufen bekommen würdest.
Na ja gut, da du Windows sowieso nicht ohne weiteres zum Laufen bekommst. Also, das ist zumindest meine Erfahrung. Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht. Ich wäre jetzt nicht so überrascht, wenn da auch mal was mit acht Jahren dabei ist. Vielleicht sogar auch mit zehn Jahren. Aber das bedeutet ja auch nur, dass sich die Architektur nicht so viel verändert hat. Also, wie lange dauert das, bis dann mal ein BIOS abgeworfen wird und man dann halt wirklich mal auf UEFI geht und so. Das sind immer so Megagenerationen, die sich da durchlaufen müssen, bis man dann mal Floppy Discs weglässt und man dann mal USB macht.
Bist du trollig oder was?
Naja, wie auch immer, also das läuft. Das Bett müsste jetzt eigentlich schon total besoffen sein.
Also ich bin jetzt eigentlich schon relativ besoffen.
Ja, ich geh auch schon aus dem Leim hier.
FreeBSD auf Apple-Hardware find ich gut. Ich find das ist nicht der schlechteste.
Naja, ich hab da noch so zwei uralte Mac-Minis rumliegen. Vielleicht versuch ich das einfach mal auf den Kisten.
Ja, und wenn du deinen Kern nicht patchen willst, dann kann ich dir die eine Loader-Datei, die man da braucht, eigentlich nur eine Datei, die da gebaut werden muss, die kann ich dir auch so schicken, dann musst du das glaube ich nicht komplett machen.
Naja, es ist jetzt die Frage, ob der überhaupt irgendwie bootet, ist da schon spannend, weil ich glaube das Letzte, was da drauf läuft, ist 10.7 oder so.
Na, das kannst du ja probieren. Bei FreeBSD gibt es ja so Memstick ISOs für USB-Stick. Und dann nimmst du einfach das mit dem EFI drauf halt irgendwie.
Ich kann auch eine CD brennen, so ist es.
Nicht. Das gehört sich nicht. Das lohnt einfach nicht für einmal so eine CD.
Ach, aber die USB-Sticks, wenn die da nicht mehr gehen...
Die hat er ja eh.
Ich hab auch die CD-Rohlinge eh. Ich werd auch keine neuen mehr kaufen, aber es sind halt noch welche da.
Ich hab grad ne 50er-Spindel gekauft.
Ich hab ja...
Über eine Audi-Aufnahme.
Ich hab ja so Zugriff noch auf ein Fahrzeug, was mir zwar nicht gehört, aber was ich doch des Öfteren fahre. Und in diesem Fahrzeug befindet sich ein CD-Spieler.
Ist nicht ein Radio mit Auxiliary-Fort billiger als ein 50er-Spindel?
Ja, es ist halt nicht mein Fahrzeug und ich will da auch nicht jetzt das Werksradio rausbohren und da irgendein anderem Ding reindübeln. Das ist ja auch nicht so teuer.
Früher für die Kassettenradios gab es ja immer diese schönen Aux-Adapter. Für CDs ist das einem noch kein Problem. Das wär doch nochmal eine geile Technologie, die ist auf so einem Lasernard.
Das wär mal ein Hack. Frag doch mal deinen Professor von der TU.
Oder einfach so eine drehende Scheibe. Vorne schreibt er drauf, der Leser liest es und wenn es da wieder rumkommt, schreibt er wieder drüber.
Ja, es gab es ja auf dem Camp, auf dem vorletzten Camp, da bin ich ja auch eines Abends so ein bisschen verschallert zum Zelt durch so ein Wäldchen getappert und da war irgendwie Licht und Leute saßen um dieses Licht herum und da kamen komische Klinge her. Und da dachte ich mir schon so, was ist das denn jetzt? Und sind da so hin und da saß so ein alter Mann mit einem Bart vor so einer Maschine und hat quasi eine Scheibe Vinyl vor sich gehabt und hat mit der einen Nadel quasi was draufgeschrieben und dann dahinter das abgespielt, was er gerade draufgeschrieben hat und das wieder mit in die nächste Spur mit einem neuen Signal in die nächste Ritte geschrieben, sodass sich das dann irgendwann alles überlagert hat und totale weirde Überlagerungssounds gemacht hat und alle saßen halt total high vor dieser Maschine und der Typ sah so aus, als wusste er ganz genau, was er da tut und hier noch mal ein bisschen an der Schraube drehen und da noch mal ein bisschen den Sinti über...
Wie hat denn der in das Venue geschrieben?
Na ja, du kannst ja auch schneiden. Du musst ja nicht pressen. Du kannst ja auch Venue schneiden.
Mit einer Schneidnadel.
Was meinst du, wie Platten gemastert werden? Na ja, du hast eine Scheibe und da schneidest du mit so einem Messer halt die Spur rein.
Also das Ding ist, du kannst Venue auch billiger produzieren. Also wenn du jetzt eine Schallplatte produzieren würdest wollen, nur so aus Spaß und Erfolge Freak Show auf Vierfach LP. Dann kannst du die relativ günstig schneiden lassen. Das Ding ist halt, und das machen halt auch die DJs. Also wenn sie sich irgendwelche Sachen so custom anfällen lassen, dann werden die meistens geschnitten. Weil es halt billiger, aber die nutzen sich dann auch sehr schnell ab. Deswegen die langhaltenen Vinylscheiben, die sind die gepressten. Das heißt, du schneidest einmal den Master, machst deine Form, presst es dann, die halten dann auch länger, die werden dann nicht bei jedem Abspielen irgendwie gleich zerfnordet. Ich weiß nicht woran das liegt, vielleicht ist die Rille dann nicht so schön.
Ja, ich glaub das Material ist einfach weicher, in das du schneidest. Und dann hast du halt diese Master-Press-Matrize, von der du dann die Negativen machst, mit denen du dann tatsächlich dir eigentlich Scheiben pressen kannst, damit du die schneiden kannst.
Die wollen ja auch dann so die Pink Floyd-Alben nicht von irgendwo haben, sondern aus so einem bestimmten Presswerk, weil da war die Qualität irgendwie besser, weil das andere Presswerk war irgendwie das Plastik, nicht so gut, oder das Vinyl, wie auch immer.
Naja, und vor allen Dingen dann noch das 180 Gramm natürlich. Und dann hab ich ja auch kürzlich erst gelernt, dass du ja auch beim, wenn du Vinyl anfertigen lässt, dann hast du ja auch eine Bandbreitenwahl. Du kannst also die Rille breiter machen, kriegst sozusagen mehr Bandbreite, mehr Information rein, aber dann musst du halt, kriegst du nur drei Songs auf eine Seite. Und also der ultimative...
Na, es wird dann vor allen Dingen auch lauter.
Kriegst halt mehr... Hat da irgendwas so mit einem Synthi oder so, irgendwas reingeschnitten, hat das wieder direkt abgespielt und das per Feedback-Loop quasi wieder in die nächste Rille, die er dann geschnitten hat.
Das heißt, dieser Schneidevorgang ist auch so sauber, dass da jetzt keine Flöckchen...
Doch, die musst du ab und zu wegmachen.
Also irgendwas hat er dann auch immer noch da gemacht, ja. Und hier noch ein Schräubchen eingestellt.
Weil da ist kein Gebläse dabei, womit er die ganze Zeit den Schneidevorgang begleitet hat.
Nicht ganz nüchtern, muss man sagen. Also diese Details sind mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz. Aber es war saukool. Und als wir dann das mal verstanden haben, was da passiert hat, haben wir auch verstanden, warum die Leute da wahrscheinlich schon seit zwei Stunden mitten in der Nacht vor dieser Installation da gekleben geblieben sind. Das war echt cool. Und vorallem total unerwartet irgendwo im Nirgendwo. Von Camp zu Zeltplatz und so.
Ich hab ja hier auch, warte mal kurz.
Jetzt holt er doch die Freak Show LP raus, oder was?
Nee, das ist nicht Freak Show auf LP, das ist Not Safe For Work auf LP. Hat uns tatsächlich mal einer zukommen lassen.
Wahrscheinlich halt auch dann geschnitten. Oder am Stück.
Vinyl-Einzelanfertigung, Master Folien-Schnitt und Presson.
Ach, naja, aber das ist das, was die anbieten, diese Firma.
Jaja, genau, die hat das dann produziert.
Ach, das war, verstehe.
Dann haben wir hier eine Folge NSFW auf Vinyl.
Das muss aber eine kurze Folge gewesen sein.
Ja, also es war jetzt, weiß nicht, ein Ausschnitt einer Folge.
Oder mit niedriger Partie.
Haben wir uns dann auch mal hier angehört. Ich habe auch noch einen Plattenspieler da hinten. Jetzt bin ich gerade nicht vorbereitet, das einzuspielen. Aber da kann man irgendeine NSFW-Folge nachhören.
Oder ich mach das das nächste Mal.
Bin ich auch vorbereitet. Hier habe ich noch eine schöne Rick Astley-Picture-Disc.
Ja, die kommt aber aus dem Presswerk.
Jaja, aber das ist halt so mit so aufgedrucktem Foto. Das wäre natürlich dann, wenn man schon mal so eine Nummer macht, dann auch der richtige Ansatz, dass du dann sozusagen auch gleich noch so ein richtiges Foto vollflächig auf der ganzen Scheibe drauf hast. Na ja, drunter macht man es nicht, oder? Interview-Picture-Disc, keine Ahnung, was hier wirklich drauf ist.
Rick Rowell, wer war sonst?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab mir den noch nie angehört.
Geht denn die Farbe weg?
Oder?
Ist ja überhaupt nicht. Das ist gar keine richtige Schallplatte.
Das ist nur, oder? Nee, hier ist auch gar nichts drauf.
Klar ist nur eine Schallplatte.
Doch.
Stimmt.
Ja, müsste man sich eigentlich mal anhören.
Ich muss jetzt doch noch mal den Schallplattenspieler rausholen.
Rick Astley willst du jetzt hören, oder was?
Nee, wollen wir nicht.
Ihr wollt jetzt bestimmt nicht mich und Holgi hören. Egal, egal, egal.
Klammer zu.
Lass uns mal über Ports reden. Du hast das ausgegraben. Huckel.
Nee, ich hab das nicht ausgegraben.
Ich auch nicht.
Echt nicht?
Nee, Roddy? Alles klar, nächste Thema.
Das war das Einzige, was schon drin stand, als ich das Workflow geöffnet hatte.
Ah, da hab ich das da reingeschrieben.
Genau, und zwar...
Ist schon Wochen her, da konntest du dich nicht mehr erinnern.
Nö, ich wollte euch das jetzt erstmal in die Schuhe schieben. Ich bin in so einem Apple...
Ist ja auch wirklich sehr cool. Es hat mich auch total vom Hocker gehauen, als ich das gesehen hab. Schnallt euch jetzt mal an hier. Lieber Hörer, jetzt Freak Show exklusiv berichtet. Live aus der Apple-Interner-Küche.
Clemens legt die Tischkante bereit.
Es ist einfach nur ein Support-Dokument, wo drauf steht, welches...
Nein, nein, nein, es ist nicht irgendein Support-Dokument.
Es ist das Support-Dokument.
Das ist schon ein bisschen üppigeres Support-Dokument.
Kann man wohl sagen. Hier ist mal ein vollständiges Verzeichnis, behauptet Apple zumindest, von allen TCP oder UDP-Ports, die so ein Mac normalerweise aufmacht.
Ich finde schon schön oben in der Übersicht, Many of these are referred to as quote well-known quote industry standard ports.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist nice.
Ja, nächste Thema. Nee, was? Wir vorlesen alle.
Ich verlink das mal. Ich wollte nur mal kurz gucken, ob da eigentlich irgendwelche besonderen Überraschungen drin sind. Aber da kann man auf jeden Fall mal nachschlagen, wenn man sich schon immer mal gewundert hat, warum sich da was abgeht.
Ich hab jetzt den Text da oben nicht gelesen. Sagen Sie, dass all diese Ports auch offen sind? Oder ist es nur Ports, die prinzipiell benutzt werden können?
Ich glaube, das ist das Dokument, wo du, wenn du so firewallmäßig drauf bist und irgendwie so eine Firma da im Griff haben musst und du guckst, was die Leute da so rein- und rausschicken. Du siehst da unseren Port, du hast natürlich als Linux oder Unix-Admin-Spezi keine Ahnung, was diese Scheiß merkst, da irgendwie durch die Gegend ballern. Und dann kannst du in dieser Liste da mal nachgucken und dann siehst du alles klar, dass es da Folgendes ist.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir diese Liste angucke, dann sollte eigentlich ein normaler Unix-Spezi-Admin irgendwie 80% dieser Ports mindestens kennen.
Nee, wieso, wenn es von Apple-Zeug ist, X, Sun, Administration, das kennt er nicht, Secure Server Administration.
Ich sagte 80%, da ist ja halt auch sowas wie Telnet.
Ja, aber da stehen sie halt einfach mal alle drauf. Und übrigens gibt es das auch von Drucker-Herstellern und anderen Peripherie-Herstellern. Wenn man da noch mal guckt, zum Beispiel HP-Printer-Ports, dann kriegt man auch die Liste von allen Ports, die HP jemals in der Geschichte der Drucker als Drucker-Port geöffnet hat.
Aber Serial-Number-Dämon? Port 626 UDP.
Suchen wir noch mal Wifi-Calling, bitte.
Ja, das fand ich nämlich jetzt auch gerade interessant.
Ja, genauer, 500. Okay, also UDPo, das ist... Ja, dann machen die Wifi-Calling mit IPSEC.
Genau, das ist eine Information, die man hier rauslesen kann, was ich schon mal ganz interessant finde. Also Wifi-Calling ist ja sozusagen dieses Telefonieren über WLAN, wenn du keine direkte LTE oder GSM oder 3G-Connection hast. Was jetzt wohl auch so langsam in Wallung kommt, ne?
Ja, was Apple richtig Geld kostet jetzt eventuell. Na, weil in den USA haben die gleich mal eine Sammelklage losgetreten.
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Das Wifi-Assist, ja, stimmt, hast recht.
Genau, das ist was anderes. Hier geht es ja darum, du bist im Wifi und willst das Wifi auch nutzen. Und ansonsten glaube ich, dass diese Sammelklage, die wird nirgendwo hingehen. Weil diese Wifi-Assist-Sache, die ist, keine Ahnung, das ist glaube ich ein Märchen.
An wie lange kriegen die das wahrscheinlich sogar durch? Bei denen ist das halt so.
Ja, weiß nicht, konnte ihnen denn irgendwie ein Fehlverhalten nachgewiesen werden, wirklich?
Na, der Typ sagt, er hat durch dieses Feature, was default an ist, bei Wifi-Assist, wurde halt auf LTE umgeschaltet. Dadurch wurde dein Datentarif mehr benutzt, was ihn ja Geld kostet. Und er wurde nicht genug darauf hingewiesen, dass das passieren könnte. Weil man muss die Leute darauf hinweisen, dass ein Feature eventuell zusätzlich Kosten verursacht. Und da kam ja dieses Dokument, wo Apple das nochmal richtig ordentlich dolle erklärte mit allen Aspekten und so. Das kam aber erst, nachdem das iOS schon draußen war. Und das war sozusagen ein bisschen zu spät. Und so argumentieren die da jetzt irgendwie rum. Und naja, so ist das halt in Amiland.
Ja, aber mit welcher Software will er denn so viel Daten erzeugt haben, dass er das abonniert hat?
Das werden die dann künstlich schon einfinden, bei dem das irgendwie ein Problem war. Keine Ahnung.
Na gut, aber so wie ich das Feature verstanden habe, funktioniert das ja nur, wenn du auch für die jeweilige App Mobile Data Usage freigeschaltet hast.
Na ja, hat er ja vielleicht. Aber er hat dann, ich werde dann argumentieren, dass er dachte, er ist halt im WLAN und kann jetzt machen, wie er will, aber konnte halt nicht.
Ja, aber es ist auch das WLAN-Symbol geht auch weg. Also, naja, wie auch immer.
So ein Symbol reicht halt nicht. So ein Symbol reicht halt nicht, um so eine Klage abzulegen. Das Support-Dokument kam halt wohl ein bisschen spät. Und ich finde, das per Default einzuschalten auch schon, naja, kann Apple ruhig mal ein bisschen über den Tisch reichen.
Gut, aber das heißt, dass jetzt, wenn man dieses Wi-Fi-Calling macht, dass das tatsächlich über IPsec geht? Das klingt doch eigentlich schon mal ganz gut. Das heißt, die machen im Prinzip so ein temporäres VPN zum Telekom-Provider, um dann darüber das Telefongespräch durchzuführen. Na ja, wir verlinken mal dieses Dokument. Das ist sicherlich etwas, was jeder schon mal gesucht hat. Und ihr könntet alle nicht schlafen, weil ihr es nicht gefunden habt. Oh man, hier sind aber auch echt noch so alte Korken drin. iSync und was nicht alles.
Ja, Distributed Compiler. Das sollen sie mal wieder anmachen.
Was ist denn das?
Das war eigentlich ganz witzig. Da konntest du X kurz sagen, hier mach mal Distributed Compiler an. Und dann hat er halt alles, was er so gefunden hat an Rechnern, die an waren, hat halt Compile-Jobs hin befördert. Und das hat eigentlich immer ganz gut funktioniert.
Ja, hab ich auch genutzt.
Und irgendwann war es dann wieder weg.
Und mein Desktop hat dann die eigentliche Arbeit gemacht.
Genau. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Nö, wie meinten das?
Schon lange nicht mehr.
Das LLVM und C lang, das ist so schnell, das lohnt sich alles. Hat er auch noch andere mit den Include-Files oder irgendwie sowas, dass da irgendwas war, dass er auch das alles rüber schicken musste.
Ich glaube, das war halt ein Feature von GCC und das haben sie bei C lang LLVM nie nachprogrammiert. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich das Problem an der Sache.
Ja, kurzer kultureller Hinweis. Das Let's Encrypt Projekt hat das Beta-Programm jetzt für alle geöffnet. Es gibt da einen Link, den der Tim jetzt freundlicherweise direkt in den Chat kippt und so dann auch seinen Weg in die Show-Notes findet. Und da kann man sich quasi mit seinen Wunschdomains mal registrieren. Ich glaube, es steht auch drin, sie geben jetzt noch keine Garantie ab, dass man zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt dann auch wirklich da teilnehmen kann. Aber ich kenne jetzt auch schon ein, zwei Leute, die sich da angemeldet haben und wohl schon fleißig mit diesem Programm Zertifikate generieren können. Also es geht voran. Das war eigentlich nur die Meldung. Ich habe es jetzt selber noch nicht ausprobieren können, weil ich noch nicht die Zeit hatte, jetzt zu überlegen, welche von meinen Seiten, die ich so betreibe, unwichtig genug ist, damit im Zweifel, wenn doch noch was nicht klappt, mir das egal ist. Insofern habe ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht, aber...
Ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht enumerieren, aber ich hörte von der Server-Infrastruktur, die sie sich da wohl zusammengeklickt haben, um diese ganze Netz-Incrypt-Geschichte zu fahren, und die ist wohl massiv. Vor allem haben sie diverse Server mit, wie nennt man das nochmal gleich, mit so Hardware, Krypto, Key, Modulen und so weiter. Das ist sozusagen Hochsicherheitstechnologie. Die fahren das jetzt nicht nur auf ein paar alten PCs, die sie noch mal rumliegen hatten, sondern die haben sich da irgendwie so ein Serious Rechenzentrum zusammengestellt und wollen gut vorbereitet sein. Deswegen kommt jetzt dieses Beta-Programm in Wallung und das geht vor allem über die ganzen üblichen verdächtigen Hacker-Communities. Da wird gerade diese Beta-Geschichte extrem durchgereicht, aber es kann sich ja jetzt im Prinzip jeder bewerben. Ich weiß bloß nicht, wie schnell man dann so Antwort bekommt.
Ja, hier meinte einer im Chat, dass er gerade gewidelistet wurde. Jetzt müsst ihr mal sagen, wann er sich angemeldet hat.
Oder sie.
Was auch immer.
Aber ja, wie gesagt, soweit ich weiß, wie er jetzt auch im Chat sagt, noch nicht dieses Root-Zertifikat überall drin, sondern man kriegt jetzt halt schon Zertifikate, man kann schon mit diesem Tool, mit dieser Toolchain rum experimentieren, aber es ist jetzt noch nicht überall supportiert. Deswegen hab ich es halt eigentlich auch...
Die sind alle gecross signed von dieser anderen Institution, von daher sind das schon gültige, funktionierende Zertifikate.
Er schreibt gerade wahr vor ein paar Wochen, was auch immer paar Wochen sind, aber...
Naja, aber es ist, ich denke mal, es nimmt jetzt gerade, macht das halt so seine Runde des Beta-Programmas, das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal noch länger dauern als weniger lange, aber...
Ja, die wollen sich einfach nur sehr, sehr, sehr sicher sein, wenn sie die Tore öffnen, weil sie schon davon ausgehen, dass die Adoption-Rate eher hoch ist. Und das kann ich mir auch ganz gut vorstellen, dass das nach so einer anfänglichen Testphase, bis die Admins sich erstmal an das Toolset gewöhnt haben und danach werden sie wahrscheinlich in irgendeinem Wahn...
Alles umsetzen.
Alles, ja, jetzt hier.
Das find ich gut.
Naja, wenn da mal jemand kommt und sagt, hier, kein Problem, ihr kriegt alle ein Cert.
Ich frag mich, es gibt ja dieses O-S-C-P oder O-C-S-P-Protokoll jetzt, was sozusagen diese Revocation-List ersetzt bei diesen Zertifikaten. Hatte ich ja schonmal erzählt, dass man jetzt in den Zert so quasi noch eine URL angeben kann, wo der Browser alle paar Nase lang mal, zum Beispiel wenn du da oben auf dein Schlösschen klickst in deiner Browser-Leiste und auf Details für dein Zertifikat von Wikipedia klickst und dann nochmal auf Details da unten drin, dann müsste da drin auch eine O-S-C-P, O-C-S-P-URL eigentlich drinstehen, wenn das ein einigermaßen aktuelles Zert ist und es ist ja von DigiZert, oh die haben ja ganz schön viel drin und gibt es das hier online, genau und im Prinzip ist das jetzt sozusagen so eine Art Online Revocation List Protocol, was halt so automatisch, das heißt wenn du in deinem Management Interface sagst, bitte dieses Zert revoken, dann muss jetzt nicht überall so eine Revocation List abgedeckt werden, sondern die Browser checken quasi Diese URL im Zert sowieso alle paar Nasen lang und das Revoken von Zertifikaten klappt dann quasi ein bisschen besser, weil meistens verlieren ja die Leute ihre Revocation-Zertifikates und dann geistern so halb valide Zertifikate oder Keys für immer rum und das ist jetzt mit diesem Protokoll.
Das heißt, mit jedem TLS-Click dieser Welt wird einmal da ein Call hingemacht?
Denn zum Beispiel Engine X und auch andere Web-Server, die können eine gecashte Antwort von diesem UCSP-Protokoll sozusagen für eine gewisse Zeit vorhalten und dann lieferst du sozusagen...
Sie signiert natürlich, die können... Genau. Sonst könnte der Attacker das ja auch machen, die ist natürlich...
Die sind halt von der RUCA gesigned, die du in deinem Browser hast, so und die sind dann...
Und da kann ich gleich mit ausliefern.
Genau. Und die sind dann halt gültig für, was weiß ich, 10 Tage oder so oder weniger. Kannst du mal... Kann man glaube ich einstellen. Es gibt einen Maximalwert und dementsprechend cashst du im Prinzip auch diese Revocation-List, aber du musst dich in keinster Weise darum kümmern, dass das dann hier irgendwie überall ordentlich propagiert wird. Also dieses Protokoll ist halt mit drin, aber es heißt natürlich trotzdem, dass du als CA-Provider Infrastruktur bereithalten musst, um diese Requests zu bedienen. Und wenn du eine relativ große CA bist oder eine sehr populäre, was jetzt eben bei Let's Encrypt der Fall sein wird, dann werden die darüber halt schon alleine einfach viel Treffik wahrscheinlich kriegen. Und da braucht man dann halt eben so ein bisschen Infrastruktur.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, ist aber ganz cool, dass es das halt so.
Also richtig neu ist das nicht?
Ne, ne, es gibt so die, äh, wir hatten bei VUGA...
Ich meine mich auch daran erinnern zu können, dass Google diesen OCSP abgeschworen hat im Chrome. Da gab es ja nicht letztes Jahr so eine Debatte drum.
Das ist auf jeden Fall, sagen wir mal, besser als gar nichts. Weil, das Problem aber, haha, jetzt kommt nämlich der Trick. Wir hatten nämlich mal so ein Wildcard-Zertifikator bei VUGA von einem billigen Anbieter, Rapid SSL in dem Fall. Und die hatten Probleme mit ihrer Infrastruktur von diesen OCP-Servern oder OCSP-Servern. Und dann haben sozusagen diverse Firefox-Instanzen gesagt, wir wissen gerade nicht, ob dieses Zertifikat noch richtig ist. Und haben sozusagen die Requests blockiert. Und ich glaube, danach hat auch, oder ich weiß nicht, man kann das irgendwie, beim Firefox, das war dann nur an, oder sie hatten bei Firefox es so auf streng geschaltet, sozusagen. Also sie haben dann immer dieses OCSP gecheckt. Und wenn das nicht korrekt ankam, dann ging es nicht. Das haben sie dann, glaube ich, auch relativ schnell wieder ausgemacht. Ob Google das jetzt supportet oder so, wäre auch mal eine gute Frage. Aber das letzte Mal, als ich geschaut hatte und mich da ganz interessiert mit beschäftigte, war es zumindest so, dass die Browser das auswerteten.
Ich kriege jetzt die Diskussion nicht zusammengefasst, aber ich habe es gerade mal nachgeschlagen. Und zwar trat das Problem hier nach diesem Heartbleed-Bug auf, wodurch ja quasi sehr viele Zertifikate kompromittiert wurden. Und hier sehe ich jetzt gerade ein heißes Security-Artikel, wo dann unter anderem drin steht, durch die Massensperrung nach Heartbleed fiel auf, dass Google Chrome diese OCSP-Nachfragen standardmäßig nicht durchführt. Deshalb, anders als etwa Firefox und Internet Explorer auf absichtlich mit gesperrten Zertifikaten betriebenen Servern, keine Warnung anzeigte. Und dann Debatte, Debatte, Debatte. Und Google das vor Jahren irgendwie absichtlich abgeschaltet hat. Und Google's HTTPS-Spezialist Adam Langley rechtfertigt diese Entscheidung jetzt auch erneut mit einem Blogbeitrag, den ich jetzt nicht so schnell durchgelesen bekomme, aber der ist von April 2014.
Kleiner Hinweis auch dazu, man kann im Schlüsselbund, also in dieser Schlüsselbundverwaltungsdingens Software Utility unter Einstellungen kann man einstellen, wie denn diese Zertifikate tatsächlich verwendet werden. Ob man das OCSP oder das CRL, also die Revocation List verwenden will und welches von beiden Priorität hat oder ob beides erforderlich sind und so weiter.
Und was ist der Default?
Der Default ist, wenn ich hier immer noch den Default habe, für beides bester Versuch Priorität CRL.
Na nee, mein Default ist OCSP und ich hab das definitiv nicht eingestellt.
Okay, kann sein.
Aber gut, ich bin ja bei Rosemite, vielleicht haben sie das auch wieder geändert. Welchen Browser?
Also die Keychain, das ist ja alles, was dann diesen Mechanismus verwendet, der irgendwie auf die Keychain-Zertifikat-Chain zugreift.
Firefox liefert ja seine eigene mit, ne?
Genau, und da ist man manchmal erstaunt, was das alles ist, was dahinter hängt.
Es gibt von Mozilla eine Liste, die hab ich hier zufällig gerade. Parat, Moment. Weil wir uns damit hier bei VUGA auch kürzlich mal wieder beschäftigen mussten, weil Mozilla ihr eigenes Süppchen braut und kommt jetzt gleich. Moment, Moment.
Wo kommt das gleich?
Im Chat, bei mir, von mir. Von mir für euch.
Für alle.
Für alle. Ach, fuck, jetzt hat der ja im Moment, wie war denn das jetzt? Ach, hier im Moment, ja, und hier, da, und dann müsste ich hier gucken. Und so, wo ist jetzt hier diese URL? Genau. Also es gibt von Mozilla auch eine Seite, die pack ich jetzt mal in den Chat für die ganz interessierten Nerds. Und da steht drin, welche CAs Mozilla zum Beispiel trusted und seit wann. Und es gibt auch eine Liste mit Pending-CAs, auch in diesem Wiki. Und da könnte man jetzt mal gucken, ob zum Beispiel Let's Encrypt schon mit dabei ist. In der Pending-CA-Liste. Die muss ich jetzt nur noch mal kurz wiederfinden. Ich glaube, da muss man irgendwie in diesem Wiki. Pending-CAs, CA, wie war denn das jetzt hier? Ah, Login-Required. Moment, der andere Link kommt bestimmt auch gleich. Mozilla, Pending C-Rs. Ja, da kommt sie auch schon frisch reingegurgelt. Bitte warten Sie, ich hol dir ein. So, da, bang! Ah ja, natürlich, das ist jetzt eine ganz andere Uhr.
Oh Mist, bei mir macht er da ein Smiley draus.
Achso, ja, nee guck mal, jetzt musst du dir auf den Link da oben klicken, dieses da, der da in der Mitte.
Weil da Doppelpunkt großes P ist, oder?
Ja, mach mal da hier diesen Link in der Mitte an.
Smiley, das mit diesen Smiley, mit diesen Emoticons, mit diesen, nee Emoticons sind die auch schon.
Das ist hier der eigentliche Link, bitte da nochmal.
Dieser Emoji-Warn. Was ist denn hier falsch mit der, oh jetzt.
Achso, die ist besser, weil da, genau, der andere hat's auch schon gepastet. So, das sind die Grünen, die sind jetzt schon sozusagen approved auf der Pending-Liste und gibt jetzt hier irgendwas von Let's Encrypt ne, was ist doch KL, ne, ne, naja.
Das ist jetzt die Warteschleife der Zuläufer, genau.
Latvian State Radio and Television Center.
Ah ja, und vor allem alle diese RU-CAs dürfen sozusagen alle Zertifikate generieren. Alle dürfen uns ein Google-Com unterschieben.
Dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, wenn die alle weg haben will, müsste eigentlich nur ein Keychain reingehen und alle CAs löschen und dann muss er danach die Zerts immer von Hand durchwinken, ja? Oder könnte man das so machen? Bevor andere mir was durchwinken, winke ich mir doch lieber selber durch.
Naja, schlauer ist da reinzugehen und zu allen zu sagen, dass du ihnen nicht vertraust. Wenn du sie rauslöscht, kann es sein, dass sie aus irgendeinem Grund wieder reinkommen. Bei irgendeinem Update von Apple oder hast du nicht gesehen.
Das muss man halt immer wieder machen.
Aber das Ding ist dann halt, dann hast du irgendwelche Third-Part oder irgendwelche Software, irgendwelche Updater, irgendwas, die so ihren eigenen HTTP-Stack noch mitbringen oder so, oder SSL-Stack, ihre eigene OpenSSL-Lib oder so und dann...
Wo du nicht einstellen kannst, hast du den Zert jetzt raus, weil die nicht fragen und auf jeden Fall...
Oder die einfach stillsterben, weil irgendwie sie davon ausgehen, naja, das Ruts zert, das wird schon getrusted.
Nee, aber wenn du ein Updater bist und hast sowieso Software auf dem Rechner, der da ausgeführt wird, dann kannst du auch dein eigenes Zertifikat mit in den... in den Downloader mit reinkippen und dann hast du...
Facebook zum Beispiel, wo wir auch letztes Mal von Facebook sprachen, die haben jetzt übrigens so Certificate Pinning, heißt das so. Eingeschaltet, du kannst jetzt nicht mehr, wie früher, so mit so einem Proxy dich dazwischen hängen und mal gucken, was da eigentlich so die Appys alle quatschen und so, sondern sobald du da so ein Proxy anmachst mit einem anderen Zert, so momenten, mittelmäßig, da heult dir dann jetzt Facebook also die Nase voll. Da kannst du gar nicht sagen, ja ist mir egal, trust dich trotzdem, bitte weiterfahren, sondern es geht einfach nicht. Die pinnen da.
Nee, genau.
Pinner.
Hast du noch wichtige Themen?
Wir haben noch MISC.
Eine Kleinigkeit, weil wer weiß wie lang es noch in der Mediathek ist, bei Arte gab es jetzt einen schönen Beitrag zum Thema Zucker nochmal. Der Titel gefällt mir nicht so, die große Zuckerlüge, aber dieses Thema, ich hab das ja schonmal angesprochen, mit dem Sugar the Bitter Truth, mit diesem Vortrag, der wird da auch drin erwähnt. Interessant ist diese ganze Backstory, wie es dazu kam, dass überhaupt sich so fürchterlich auf dieses Fett verlagert wurde, dass Fett so ungesund sein soll und Zucker aber irgendwie ganz gesund usw. Also wer will, der kann sich das mal angucken. Der ist relativ lang. Ich werd mal den Link kopieren. Und man kann also auch mit dem wohlbekannten Client YouTube.dl sich das angucken.
Der ist richtig gut.
Das ist eine Errungenschaft der Menschheit.
Ich bin neulich auch an so einer Doku hängen geblieben.
Bei Arte.
Ja, bei Arte. Da hab ich nämlich die App mal getestet und dann bin ich irgendwie schwuppdiwupp in so eine Doku reingeraten. Und da kann man ja auch echt gut hängen bleiben.
Ja, da gibt's schöne Dokus bei Arte.
Genau. Die war allerdings... Die war leider sehr erschreckend. Also es gibt ja jetzt in letzter Zeit so viel dystopisches Zeug. Ja, so hier. The truth about our planet. Und das Thema war Sand.
Sand.
Man denkt sich so, Sand, ja, okay.
Also ich weiß, dass Katar Sand importiert.
Nicht nur Katar.
Zum Bauen? Weil der Saharasand zu rund ist und man daraus keinen ordentlichen Beton machen kann. Deswegen die ganzen arabischen Länder Sand importieren.
Genau, nicht nur die arabischen Länder.
Kann man den nicht wieder kantig schleifen, den Sand?
Nee, das Zeug ist...
Das Ding ist, kurz gesagt, wir haben eine echte Sandkrise auf diesem Planeten. Sand ist eine knappe Ressource geworden. Eine hoch umkämpfte knappe Ressource.
Sowas finde ich immer geil, solche Themen.
Ja, und das ist richtig dramatisch, weil eigentlich wir so einen hohen Sandverbrauch haben für Gebäude, dass dem eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig ein Angebot entgegensteht, sondern der Sand wird halt einfach mit riesigen Saugkähnen auf dem offenen Meer abgesaugt. Das heißt, es gibt da so riesige, fette, speziell dafür gebaute Schiffe, die schnorcheln einfach mal so den ganzen Sandboden ab und nehmen einfach Flora, Fauna, alles das volle Programmwasser mit. Und die Mengen, die ich jetzt nicht genau qualifizieren kann, aber die in der Dokumentation genannt werden, die Mengen, die da täglich abgebaut werden, die sind so enorm groß, dass das Ganze schon zu maßgeblichen Erosionen führt. Ein Beispiel im Raum um Singapur. Singapur baut sich die ganze Zeit aus, hat jetzt auch noch mal eine Vergrößerung der Landfläche, irgendwie Landgewinnung und so weiter. Also allein für Landgewinnung, aber eben dann auch für die Gebäude da drauf. Der ganze Sandbedarf, den Singapur hat, kann von dieser Region gar nicht mehr gedeckt werden, beziehungsweise soll auch gar nicht mehr gedeckt werden, weil alle umliegenden Länder ein Sand-Exportverbot ausgesprochen haben. Das heißt, Singapur darf überhaupt gar kein Sand mehr geliefert werden. Trotzdem treffen da jeden Tag fette Kähne ein mit Sand. Und dann machen sie so Interviews mit den Leuten und so, ja, wo kommt das her? Ja, nö, keine Ahnung, wissen wir nicht. Oder hier auf dem offenen Meer, mal sagt einer das mal genauer, mal nicht. Und in den Regionen, wo halt abgebaut wird, also diese Sandmenge, die entnommen wird, die ändert einfach auch die ganzen Flussrichtungen und Strömungen, führt dann dazu, dass die Erosion noch stärker stattfindet. Das heißt, Küsten werden abgebaggert. Die haben dann so Stellen gezeigt, wo halt Leute schon die ganze Zeit damit kämpfen, dass ihnen das Wasser sozusagen ihr Haus nicht wegnimmt. Und sie meinten, naja, vor ein paar Jahren war hier noch 100 Meter Strand. Also... Manchmal möchte man auch echt nur noch vom Berg springen.
Das ist alles nicht so schön.
Ich schau gleich mal, ob es vielleicht zufällig diese Sand-Touro gibt. Ist da vielleicht zufällig gerade ein Link, den schon jemand rausgeholt hat? Nee, sieht nicht so aus. Aber wenn ihr den noch findet, dann weiß ich ja nicht, wie lange das erhalten wird.
Naja, es gibt ja irgendwie diese 7-Tage-Regel, aber dann gibt es ja nochmal, dass aus irgendwelchen Gründen manche Sendungen lehnen.
Ja, bei Dokus ist es dann anders.
Krieg um den Sand, hieß das so? 22. August 2011, klingt jetzt ein bisschen...
Naja, so viele Sand-Dokus werden sie schon nicht im Programm haben. Es sei denn, es ist jetzt...
Sand, die neue Umweltzeitbombe? Das könnte es auch sein.
Hier, Strände in Gefahr. Sieht ganz gut aus. Muss man kurz hier mal reinklicks on. Das ist irgendwie noch eine halbe Stunde. Ich hatte das Gefühl, das ist irgendwie länger.
Tickende Zeitbombe, hieß die Doku, sagt hier einer.
Tickende Zeitbombe?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau. Wir schauen nachher nochmal.
Wie auch immer.
Eine kleine Sache, ganz, ganz mini, mini, mini, mini, mini. Ihr kennt ja diesen Fall, wenn es an der Tür klingelt und da steht ein Fernsehteam vor der Tür.
Klar passiert mir fast täglich.
Den Fall kenn ich nicht.
Doch, weil dringend...
Du wohnst im Pretzlerberg....
für irgendeinen aktuellen Fall von Cybercrime oder sonstigen Vorfällen rund um Computer...
Achso, jetzt versteh ich....
muss halt dringend mal was gedreht werden und sie brauchen dann irgendwie natürlich auch noch den passenden Backdrop, also so Steal Hacker mit Maske. Aber das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so das Problem. Auszusehen wie ein Hacker vorm Rechner, ist ja einfach. Aber was macht man auf dem Bildschirm? Aber keine Angst, dafür gibt es jetzt hacketyper.net. Das kann sein, dass ihr das schon kennt. Ich kannte es noch nicht und deswegen erzähle ich das jetzt hier, als wäre es der neueste Scheiß überhaupt. Das ist einfach eine schöne Webseite, wo man dann...
Aber dann solltest du, wenn das Fernsehteam da ist, den Addressbar vom Browser schon noch wegmachen.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja denen eigentlich auch egal.
Geht es von allein oder was?
Keine Ahnung, der Beamer hat gerade geschwächelt. Nee, ich glaube, das war eher der Beamer.
Na ja, wie auch immer, hackertyper.net.
Prost.
Da kann man mal eben so auf der Tastatur rumhauen und schreibt nebenbei auf dem Bildschirm ein cooles C-Programm, wie das Hacker halt so machen, ohne einmal die Lied zu drucken.
Aber ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen unrealistisch.
Aber die Lied kann man auch machen.
Das ist ein bisschen unrealistisch, weil pro Tasten Anschlag Tipps.
Es kommt sogar noch ein Excess Denied hier.
Da hast du ja mehrere Worte gleich.
Das merkt auch keiner. Das ist Fernsehen. Ich bitte dich.
Nee, das ist natürlich Autovervollständigung.
Das ist nicht realistisch, sondern das ist so...
Das ist total unrealistisch!
Wie das Fernsehen das gerne hätte.
Deswegen macht man mit denen nichts.
Zum Thema Fernsehteam. Ich war ja mal ein halbes Jahr in Hamburg. Ihr kennt die Geschichte alle. Und da habe ich etwas sehr Skurriles erlebt. Weil ich war auf der Suche nach einer WG. Und bin dann irgendwann an eine WG geraten. Die waren alle sehr merkwürdig. Die hatten dann auch so ein komisches Kennenlernspiel mit so einer Salatschüssel, wo so Zettel drin waren. Und dann sollte man Zettel ziehen und was zu den Zetteln sagen. Also irgendwie war das unten ein Stapel CDs. Man sollte zu den CDs was sagen. Das war irgendwie alles sehr merkwürdig, stellte sich heraus. Das war alles ein gestelltes Setup von RTL. Die das als quasi Reality-TV-Show da irgendwie abgedreht haben.
Und da bist du gelandet, ausgerechnet?
Und du hast nichts von den Kameras gemerkt in RTL?
Naja, das war halt eine normale Wohnung und sie hatten irgendwie einen Raum. Da war halt irgendwie die Technik und dann hatten sie die Kameras irgendwie versteckt. So genau weiß ich es nicht mehr. Ich war etwas überrascht.
Bist du dann auch bei RTL gelandet?
Ich weiß es nicht, ob das je gesendet wurde. Aber ich glaube, ich war auch nicht einer von denjenigen, die jetzt da so hervorgetreten ist. Auf einem von diesen Zetteln stand dann Kiez oder Schanze. Und da sollte ich dann was zu sagen. Und dann dachte ich mir so, naja, so als Berliner, Kiez oder Schanze, was soll ich jetzt dazu sagen? Ja, gibt's halt. Was wollt ihr hier von mir? Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass das je gesendet wurde.
Weil du einfach keinen ordentlichen Fernseh-kompatibenden Spruch auf den Lippen hast. Aber hättest du nur sagen müssen, als Scheißer, ey, wir können mir mal hier Kiez, Schanze, mir egal.
Bei Lina sagst du Kiez, Mann.
Ein Fernsehen musst du einfach hitten und dann kommst du auch rein.
Hey, weißt du, hab ich Kiez gewohnt, hab ich Schanze gewohnt, weißt du, ist nicht ein großer Unterschied.
Ist mehr Latte.
Ja, irgendwie so, gut.
So, jetzt hocke ich hier, hau durch.
Ach, jetzt sag ich gar nicht so, ich bin echt auch, ich bin auch schon durch. Aber ich hab ja schon auf Twitter gefragt, es ist ja ein großes Problem, heutzutage vernünftige Hardware zu kaufen. Wir kennen das alle. Und das zieht sich durch bis zu Steckdosenleisten. Reden wir nicht lange um den heißen Brei herum. Es geht um das, was unsere Geräte füttert. Ohne Steckdosenleisten... Kein Strom für unser Aller-Entertainment.
Und auch bald unsere Aller-Otos.
Genau, und ich hab mir vor einiger Zeit eine Steckdosenleiste von der Firma Brennenstuhl gekauft. Die sind ja wirklich überall, wenn man Steckdosenleisten hat. Und die sehen ja auch auf den Bildern ganz ordentlich aus. Und die haben auch ganz coole Features, wie über Spannungsschutz und Netzfilter. Und hast du nicht gesehen, aber das hat dann leider nicht lange gehalten, denn vorgestern habe ich diese Steckdose eingeschaltet. Die hat so einen Kippschalter. Und dann machte das... Also die Leuchte ging so sehr schnell gepulst an und aus. Und dann endet es mit einem traurigen, aber wahren...
Trauriges, aber wahres...
Dann war es aus mit der Brennensstuhl-Steckdosenleiste, woraufhin ich anfing zu gucken, ich weiß, die Brennensstuhl-Steckdosenleiste, die sah zwar gut aus und hatte Features, aber sie hat nicht besonders viel gekostet. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein bisschen wertvollere Sachen. Und vor allen Dingen langhaltende Sachen. Dann habe ich auch schon auf Twitter gefragt und ich habe auch schon sehr viele Marken genannt bekommen. Doch einige von denen sind halt auch genau so eine Brennenstuhl-Plasten-Bomber, die nach nichts aussehen, wie ich sie bereits schon hatte. Oder sie haben bestimmte Features nicht. Ich suche konkret nach Steckdosen-Leisten, die fünf bis sechs Dosen haben. Ich suche eine Variante, wo jede Steckdose einen Einzelkippschalter hat zum An- und Ausschalten. Und ich suche eine Variante mit einfach nur einem Ein- und Ausschalter für die gesamte Leiste, die aber über einen Netzfilter und einen Überspannungsschutz verfügt. Für sachdienliche Hinweise bitte wenden Sie sich direkt vielleicht dann gleich an meinen Twitter-Account. Die, die ich bisher genannt habe und für interessant befand, waren die von der Firma Knurr. Die sind aber sehr schwer zu bekommen. Und es ist auch so Premium-Hardware, weil die sind so für Racks eigentlich verbaut. Und die sehen auch so aus, als würden sie ein Leben lang halten. Und so lange brauche ich ja nicht. Ich bin ja schon 33 immerhin. Und dann gab es noch eine Firma, die heißt Bachmann. Die sehen auch okay aus. Habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ja, Bachmann ist natürlich schon...
Geht so. Die haben jetzt auch nicht nur teure Sachen. Also die waren jetzt auch nicht, zumindest die Modelle, die ich bisher gesehen habe, auch nicht viel teurer als die von Brennenstuhl. Die von APC, die auch immer alle möglichen Leute empfehlen. Ich weiß nicht, APC, das sieht auch wirklich immer so nach krassen Plastibomber aus. Also wenn jetzt genug Leute sagen, APC ist super und benutze ich schon seit Jahren und ist geil, dann würde ich mir das nochmal angucken. Ansonsten war jetzt bisher tatsächlich dieses Bachmann so der Mittelweg zwischen diesen Knör-Produkten, die man auch nirgendswo so richtig zu kaufen kriegt. Da muss man immer so Spezial-Webstores oder so gehen. Also, mehr will ich dazu eigentlich auch gar nicht sagen. Ich kann nicht sagen, die Anforderungen sind eigentlich gar nicht so großartig. Ich hätt gern einfach was, wo man lange Freude hat und wo der Kippschalter nicht nach einem halben Jahr...
macht. Was sind denn aufbauten für Bürotische? Versenkbare, rangriffbare, einbaubare? Ich hab mir deren Programm auch mal angeschaut.
Haben wir im Büro die Dinger.
In welcher Variante?
Da, wie sie es sind, so schräg mit Clem an den Tisch klemmen.
Und rockt das schon ausreichend?
Das kostet amtlich Geld und es tut, was es soll. Aber für den Preis würde ich es mir nie kaufen.
Die haben ja auch, wie gesagt, normale Steckdosenleisten. Irgendwo hier im Angebot.
Aber schick ist natürlich, wenn man so drückt und dann kommt da so eine Röhre mit Steckdosen hochgefahren. Wenn man sie nicht mehr braucht, kann man sie wieder runterversenken.
Nein, halt dieses Rangklemmteil.
Ich hab ja jetzt auch hier in meinem Tisch das Problem, wie ihr ja alle seht, dass hier einfach wieder viel Kabellage rumliegt und ich würde das ja auch ganz gerne mehr versenken. Aber die ganzen Edelvarianten von Bachmann, da kommt man dann noch mal schnell auf ein paar 100 Euro für so 300 Steckdosen.
Sagt der, der jetzt hier für 150 Euro einen Trackpad sich kauft. Ja, doch, aber du kannst noch eins einstellen. Machen wir hier Steckdosenleiste da oben noch schnell ganz kurz.
Was ist mit der Steckdosenleiste?
Na, hier die da in den Kategorien Steckdosenleiste universal da oben, also über Conference.
Dosenleiste universal.
Da gibt es jetzt irgendeine davon, die hat auch einen Überspannungsschutz und Netzfilter. Und Ein- und Ausschalter. Aber anyway, also falls noch jemand sagt, die nicht Hinweise hat und total überzeugt langjähriger Benutzer von irgendwelchen Produkten ist, die diese Features haben und noch nicht kaputt gegangen sind durch normale Benutzung, dann her damit. Und ein weiteres Stichwort zu dem Thema ist halt auch so Handwerker Steckdosenleiste, weil da ist das auch wohl ganz üblich, dass die einzelnen Dosen ein- und ausschaltbar sind. Gut, das soll's auch jetzt erstmal gewesen sein. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht unnötig.
Wir können ja das nächste Mal berichten, wie das Ergebnis so gelaufen ist. So, last but not least, Dennis. Was ist los? Brauchst du eine Bahncard?
So sieht's aus.
Winter jetzt, ne?
Ist Winter. Als Motorradfahrer fährt man ja im Sommer Motorrad. Im Winter auch, aber...
Also du bewegst dich doch sonst kaum aus Berlin-Mitte raus.
Ich doch.
Du hast es natürlich unterwegs.
Wirklich? Wohin denn?
So ist es, wenn man eine Fernbedienung hat. Fernbedienung.
Und?
Da brauch ich eine Bahncard.
Ja, was für eine?
Ja, das ist genau das Ding. Da muss man halt kalkulieren, wenn man nicht die falsche kaufen will. Und ich hab das schon mal gemacht. Eigentlich ist das ja nur, das andere Mikro ist hier noch an. Deswegen ist das so laut die ganze Zeit, wenn ich hier irgendwie lege.
Ja, kein Problem. Das kann ich dann nachher.
Ist noch an.
Nimmt, ja, Sekunde.
Super. Wo wir wahrscheinlich geblieben?
Bahncard 100 oder 25 oder 50?
Genau, also ich brauch eine Bahncard. Und ich hab das ja eigentlich schon mal gemacht irgendwie. Aber da ich jetzt wieder eine Bahncard mal brauche, hab ich das jetzt halt noch mal gemacht. Und mit den neuen Preisen halt mal getweetet. Du hast das gesehen und als Thema aufgenommen. So war's. Und ich wollte es mir halt leicht machen. Und deswegen habe ich die Preise der Bahncards und die Vergünstigungen entsprechend in Wolfram Alpha geschmissen, sodass da so ein paar Grafen entstehen, die dann auch übereinander liegen, sodass man halt...
Aber keine Legende haben.
Ja, da weiß ich nicht, wie man dieses Wolfram Alpha, wie man das so perfekt bedient. Also ich hätte das auch gerne eigentlich so ein bisschen programmiermäßig, weil ich hab jetzt da in dieser... Bei Wolfram Alpha kann man ja so eine Zeile eingeben. Ich lese die mal so für die BahnCard 50. Lese ich die mal vor, dann räumen wir noch mal hoch. Wenn man für die BahnCard 50 das wissen will, dann tippt man ein. Plot 255 plus x mal 0,5 mal 168. In dem Fall ist jetzt 168. Eine Fahrt hin und zurück. Wohin? Das ist jetzt in dem Fall Bielefeld genau. Weil eigentlich fährt man ja immer hin und zurück. Deswegen ist ja selten, dass man, also wenn man schon eine BahnCard hat, dann fährt man ja auch hin und her anscheinend. Deswegen hab ich das gleich mal so genommen, dann kann man das besser rechnen, weil sonst muss man mal doppelt zählen. Plot 255 plus x mal 0,5 mal 168. 0,5 ist der Faktor, den du halt bei einer BahnCard 50 sparst. Deswegen ist es sozusagen nur die Hälfte des Preises. Und 250 ist halt der Anfangspreis, den du auf jeden Fall bezahlst, nämlich für die BahnCard selbst. So, und wenn man dahinter Komma schreibt, dann kann man noch den zweiten Graph machen. Das wäre dann Plot 62 plus x mal 0,75 mal 168. Das heißt, du zahlst jetzt noch 75% von dem Hauptpreis. Also sparst du 25%. Also hört man schon, wir reden von BahnCard 25. Und aber am Anfang stand nur Plot 62, weil der einmalige Preis, den du halt für die BahnCard 25 bezahlst, sind halt 62 Euro. Und wenn man jetzt die beiden Linien, die anderen lassen wir jetzt mal weg, dann kann man das besser sehen, weil die überkreuzen sich ein bisschen zu viel sonst. Dann sieht man da unten, wenn du ein bisschen runter scrollst, dass die BahnCard 25, die lohnt sich halt bei einer Fahrt nicht so wirklich, jedenfalls nicht nach Bielefeld, da ist es immer noch ohne BahnCard eigentlich billiger. Das heißt, wenn du weißt, du fährst nur einmal im Jahr, dann brauchst du eigentlich keine BahnCard 25 kaufen. Aber du kannst schon sehen, bei der Grafik ist die BahnCard 1 noch mit drin, die sorgt dafür, dass das so rausgezoomt ist, weil das erst dann bei 46 Fahrten sich die BahnCard 1 loslöscht, wenn du das oben löscht.
Was ist denn eine BahnCard 100?
Eine BahnCard 100, Entschuldigung. Mach mal ganz rechts das Plot 4090, mach das mal raus. Das ganz letzte hinten genau das.
Meinst du, die BahnCard 100 kommt nicht in Frage?
Doch, aber die stört in der Grafik gerade, weil es zoomt dann raus und dann sehen wir die Auflösung nicht so fein. Man kann da nicht reinzoomen, wenn man keinen Wolfram Alpha Special Account hat. So, jetzt siehst du das hier viel besser. So, hier kannst du das sehen. Siehst du, wenn du jetzt eine fahrt, das ist ja deiner...
Warte mal, was ist hier die X-Achse?
Das ist die...
Fahrpreis.
X ist Anzahl der Fahrten.
Genau, und Y ist der Preis. Und jetzt kannst du X... Wenn du bei X bei 1 gehst, dann kannst du sehen, dass bei Y das erste, das billigste Y, sozusagen der billigste Preis, ist halt das, die Linie, die halt durch die Null schräg durchgeht. Das ist das, was halt gar keine BahnCard heißt. Das ist sozusagen der Normalpreis. Das heißt, wenn du nur eine Fahrt machst, dann ist das am billigsten. Dann lohnt es sich nicht, eine BahnCard 25 zu kaufen, weil die ist leicht teurer. Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen. Wenn man exakt einmal im Jahr fährt. So, bei zwei Fahrten siehst du aber jetzt schon, dann ist die BahnCard 25 jetzt billiger geworden. Die fängt zwar teurer an durch den Preis der Karte, aber danach wird sie halt immer ein Stück billiger sein als der Normalpreis. Die hat das sozusagen preislich eingeholt. So, wenn du jetzt noch weitergehst. Bei vier ist die 25 auch noch billiger, aber bei fünf schon. Da fängt dann an, die BahnCard 50 billiger zu werden als die BahnCard 25. Weil halt die nur 50 Prozent kostet. Das dauert aber eine Weile, bis sie billiger wird, weil sie so einen hohen Einstiegspreis hat. Und wie wir eben gerade noch vorher gesehen haben, die BahnCard 100, die lohnt sich circa ab 46 Fahrten. Dann wird sie billiger als die BahnCard 50. Genau, das kann man jetzt dann hier so schön sehen. Weil du musst ja auch die BahnCard 100 eben nicht mit dem Normalpreis vergleichen, was vielleicht manche machen, sondern du musst die natürlich mit der billigsten anderen Karte vergleichen, die es so gibt. Und in dem Fall ist das halt die BahnCard 50. Und wie auch schon manche geschrieben haben hier, das muss man jetzt mal alles erwähnen. Erstens natürlich die BahnCard 25 ist für die richtigen Sparfüchse am billigsten, weil du kannst da natürlich die Sparpreise nehmen und kriegst trotzdem noch die 25%, was dann insgesamt...
Die nächste auch bei der BahnCard 50, oder?
Was dann immer noch billiger ist, also im alten System als die BahnCard 50, das Problem ist bloß, was ich immer nicht hinkriege, du hast dann Zugbindung und wenn du das dann nicht schaffst und den Zug nicht nimmst, dann ist das Geld weg. Dann hast du da gar nichts gespart, eher im Gegenteil. Deswegen bin ich halt Fan der BahnCard 50. Wenn ich eine BahnCard 25 hätte, dann würde ich auch nur die 25% nutzen und wahrscheinlich nie den Sparpreis, weil ich kriege das gar nicht erst hin und würde das auch gar nicht erst machen. Ich fahre gerne zum Bahnhof und nehme den Zug, der als nächstes kommt. So, was haben wir noch? Das war das eine. Das andere ist, was auch einer gepostet hat per Twitter. Replied sozusagen. Er meint, er hat eine BahnCard 50 und eine BahnCard 25. Und sozusagen, wenn er vorplanen kann, also wenn er den Sparpreis kriegt, dann nimmt er den mit seiner BahnCard 25. Und wenn er aber das nicht kriegt, dann nimmt er seine BahnCard 50. Das lohnt sich natürlich nur, wenn du schon den Graf müsste man sozusagen auch. Nee, das kann man nicht meinen, weil man diese Sparpreise schlecht...
Also der zahlt lieber mehr, um mehr sparen zu können.
Genau, aber wahrscheinlich fährt er insgesamt so viel, dass es sich halt trotzdem noch lohnt, diese BahnCard 25 zu kaufen. Vor allem, wenn die Bahn schickt einem ja so Angebote, dann kriegst du die BahnCard 25. Habe ich gerade erst gestern bekommen. Deswegen bin ich auch drauf gekommen, das da zu machen. Haben sie mir ein Angebot geschickt, dass ich die ja für 36 Euro kriegen würde, anstatt für 62, weil ich meine letzte BahnCard nämlich gecancelt habe und ich habe mir noch keine neue geholt. Und die hätte natürlich jetzt ganz gerne, als ich mir die nächste hole. Weil es ist ja ein Abo-Modell und die wollen einen ja abzocken. Man kann ja nicht sagen, man will die nur für ein Jahr. Nein, die wird ja automatisch verlängert.
Was, die BahnCard 25 wird automatisch verlängert?
Nein, die 50er. 25er wahrscheinlich auch. Wenn du die nicht kündest, dann kriegst du automatisch die nächste. Das ist ja die größte Abzock überhaupt. Das Verlängern finde ich nicht mal schlimm, aber ich kann nicht sagen, danke. Beim Kaufen kann ich schon nicht sagen, nee, ich will nicht. Sondern ich muss die kaufen und muss sie dann über einen anderen Weg als den Kaufweg kündigen. Und ich finde, das sollte gesetzlich verboten werden. Weil wenn ich was kaufe und da schon nicht sagen kann, nee, ich will die nicht länger als ein Jahr, das geht nicht. Das muss zumindest die gleiche Stelle sein. Und wenn ich die da am Schalter bei der Bahn kaufe, dann will ich die auch am Schalter bei der Bahn kündigen können. Und das ging nicht. Das finde ich nicht okay. Hallo Verbraucherzentrale, macht das mal heile. Das geht gar nicht.
Und muss man dann, wenn man jetzt diese BahnCard 50 haben will, mit der man auch die Sparpreise haben kann, muss man sich dann eine neue Bahn... Also muss man dann die alte kündigen und sich eine neue holen oder wird das auch auf bestehende BahnCards abgegradet?
Das bezweifle ich, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin da über die Details nur eingeschränkt informiert. Das ist eine Information, von der ich jetzt noch nicht mal bestätigen kann, dass es schon klar ist, dass das kommt.
Aber schon viele haben geschrieben, dass die Bahn das mit der BahnCard deutlich umstellen will, weil sie so einen Druck durch die Busgeschichte hat, dass sie da was machen muss und...
Ja, ihr meint es auch schon, diese Schnupper-BahnCards und so.
Diese 3-Monats-Geschichte und so.
Mich wundert das gerade, dass du meinst, du brauchst 46 Fahrten, bis ich eine BahnCard 100...
Da hab ich ja auch überlegt, Tim, ob sich das für dich lohnt. Guck mal, als BahnCard 100 kommen ja noch andere Faktoren dazu. Und zwar, du kannst ja... Wobei, es wird der BahnCard 50...
Ja, aber es ist jetzt für genau die Strecke.
Es ist schon eine mittelmäßige Strecke. Es ist jetzt nicht von hier bis nach Köln, aber...
Aber 46 Fahrten?
Wenn du nach Hamburg fahren würdest, dann wär das wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr.
Na, kannst du ja auch gucken. Wenn du 46 mal so fährst, ohne irgendwas, 168, dann wär das 7.700 Euro. Das heißt, mit der BahnCard 50 hast du da schon reichlich gespart. Da bist du nämlich bei... Was ist das dann? Mal 84. Dann bist du noch bei 3.800 Euro plus die 255 Euro für die BahnCard 50. Dann bist du genau das, was die BahnCard 100 kostet. Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich... Du würdest mir sagen, du hast zwar eine BahnCard 100 gehabt, aber du wirst keine 46-mal im Jahr gefahren. Richtig?
Ja, aber eventuell längere Strecken.
Ich bin natürlich ganz andere Strecken gefahren.
Ja, da muss man halt kalkulieren. Aber ich sehe auch ein, dass man natürlich...
Also ich hab das auch nachgerechnet. Ich hab genau meine Touren in so einen Tabell eingetragen, das nachgerechnet. Und es war am Ende immer so in etwa ein bisschen besser oder ein bisschen schlechter als BahnCard 50.
Ein bisschen schlechter ist ja schon auch nicht so schlimm, weil du hast ja natürlich den totalen Luxus, weil du fährst einfach hin und steigst ein. Du musst da nicht an den Schalter ran, an nichts, gar nichts. Du gehst einfach rein, setzt dich hin und bang, das war's.
Los, Lounge.
Ja, von mir aus und natürlich hier in Berlin.
Du hast ÖPNV halt auch noch mit drin.
Nur A und B, ne? Ja, weiß ich nicht, kann sein. Und vor allem in allen anderen Städten auch. Genau. Aber du hast auch bei der BahnCard 50 der Weg zum und vom Bahnhof ist auch mit drin, aber sonst halt nicht, was bei der BahnCard 100 aber dauerhaft ist. Richtig? So würde ich auch, ich persönlich würde auch, wenn ich schon 40 mal im Jahr fahre, dann würde ich mir auch schon den Luxus gönnen, mir so eine Card holen und hab meine Ruhe. Das ist mir schon eine Menge wert. Man muss es halt aber wissen und ich glaube, viele Leute kalkulieren da vielleicht nicht ganz so genau. Und da kann man es halt genau sehen, weil ich denke Leute, die eine BahnCard 100 haben, das sind vielleicht zum Beispiel, sieht man ja, ich sehe das im Zug immer die ganzen Wolfsburg-Pendler da, von Berlin Wolfsburg irgendwie so. Die wissen ja auch ihren Preis, die wissen, wie oft zu fahren, die können das direkt mit dem Preis da eingehen. Müssen da nur die 168 gegen euren Standard-Fahrpreis da tauschen und bumm fertig und dann steht da halt auch irgendeine Zahl und dann sieht man das.
Naja, wenn ein Jahr irgendwie 52 Wochen hat und 46 Fahrten ist das, was du brauchst, dann heißt das eigentlich, dass du das ganze Jahr über jedes Wochenende fährst.
Ja, entweder Wochenendsfahrer bist oder du fährst einmal die Woche, weil du wohin musst.
168 ist das der Hin- und Zurückpreis?
Also eigentlich ist eine Richtung in Bielefeld 84 Euro, so rum, genau. ICE, also ICE, nicht IC, IC kostet weniger. Ich fand das optisch halt mit Wolfram Alfa eine schicke Sache, das so schön hinzukriegen, wenn es einer schafft, dass ich den Fahrpreis oben in so eine Art Variable stecken kann und den nur an einer Stelle ändern muss, wenn ich ihn ändern möchte und dann hinter nur noch die Variable nehme, dann kann er mir ja mal per Twitter irgendwie ein Update schicken. Und wenn einer das weiß, wie das mit der Legende da ordentlich geht, dann kann er mir das auch schicken. Ich hab das ein bisschen rumgefummelt, aber dann hatte ich irgendwie auch keinen Bock mehr bei.
Das kannst du bestimmt alles mit iCloud-Numbers machen oder mit Google Docs.
Gibt es dieses Mathe-Tool noch auf dem Mac?
Grafik-Kalkulator oder Graf.
Gibt es den noch? Der war eigentlich auch immer ganz sinnvoll für solche Sachen.
Übrigens, laut aktueller Bahnausgabe Berlin-Bielefeld, 157 Euro.
Ich hab aber gestern extra nachgeguckt, oder vorgestern, weil ich das gemacht hab.
Ja, ich hab extra jetzt nochmal nachgeguckt.
Haben sie gesehen hier meine Tweets? Und wir haben gesagt, oh scheiße, ist das toll, alle wollen in Bielefeld fahren. Irgendwas ist da los, wir müssen schnell die Preise senken. Keine Ahnung, echt. Ist ja günstig, weil ich muss da übermorgen mal wieder hin. Und dann spare ich ein paar Euro.
Ja, 157 in und zurück.
Laut bahn.de.
Bei mir kommt hier 84 Euro.
Achso, warte mal, vielleicht hab ich hier... Warte mal, hat der hier noch meine... Nö, keine Ermäßigung.
Wobei, hier gibt es auch einen für 84 und einen für 69. Ich weiß aber nicht, warum die den einen so anbieten und den einen so. Ich kann mal zu dem 69er gehen.
Gibtst du da irgendwas anderes an, als ich?
Nee, ich hab hier... Da, und dann kommt das, wenn ich das so jetzt mache.
72, achso, hier, guck mal, hier ist 73.
Nee, aber das ist ein ICE. Guck mal, das ist hier mit zweimal Umsteigen, das will ja keiner. Also was ich da mache, ist Berlin-Biedelfeld ICE ohne Umsteigen.
Und Tim hat einfach schon den Bonus-Cookie gesetzt.
Nee, ich hab jetzt auch keine Ermäßigung.
Nee, hab ich ja auch nicht. Die Ermäßigung rechne ich ja dann später selber.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich jetzt gerade anders eigentlich mache als du.
Das ist die moderne Welt der individuellen Preisvergabe. Ja, aber warum sie hier zwei Preise anbieten, einmal 69 und einmal 84 für die gleiche Zugfahrt? Achso, da oben steht's ja, okay, da oben. Hätten wir eine andere Farbe für nehmen sollen hier irgendwie.
Sollen wir mit dem Podcast Bahn klicken?
Dann soll ich erstmal durch. Ich hab ja jetzt auch keine Bahncard 100 mehr. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin auch so ein bisschen frustriert, weil die Bahn, das wird nicht besser irgendwie, das Bahncard 100-Angebot. Also es wird nur teurer.
Nee, 4090 Euro.
Genau, das war mal bei drei, sechs, als ich irgendwie mit dem Spaß angefangen habe. Und mittlerweile ist es bei 4,1 oder 4,2 sogar schon.
Ja gut, aber die Ticketpreise sind ja auch dementsprechend gestiegen.
Ja, aber es hat sich halt auch nichts verbessert. Das fängt schon damit an.
Die Marlboros sind auch die gleichen wie vor 30 Jahren. Und die kosten jetzt sechs Euro. Also, was ist denn das für eine Aussage?
Das eine ist ein Kaufprodukt und Verbrauchskonsumprodukt und das andere ist eine Dienstleistung. Die steht in Konkurrenz zur anderen Dienstleistung.
Na die WLAN-Hotspots in der Bahn, die kosten bestimmt so viel Geld jetzt.
Du, Fliegen ist einfacher geworden in der Zeit.
In Europa.
Nicht einfacher, aber billiger.
Auch einfacher.
In Europa.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass es immer schwieriger wird. Immer noch mehr Kontrollen.
So, ich kann heute bei jedem Flug, Tage vorher einchecken, hab meinen Sitzplatz, weiß genau, wieviel Uhr ich da hinkommen muss. Und die Zeit, die ich früher habe, früher da sein müssen, war größer. Wie hab ich denn das jetzt gesagt? Früher musste man einfach früher da sein, weil so ein Check-In einfach unvermeidlich war. Dann kam der Online-Check-In und jetzt muss man einfach nur noch Koffer abwerfen, fertig. Also es geht einfach schneller. Ist so.
Wenn du keinen Koffer hast, dann ein Handgebeck, ist sogar noch besser.
Genau, und dann ist es sogar noch besser. Also es ist einfacher geworden.
Also so wie ich das in Erinnerung hab, war irgendwie, ist das nur Koffer abwerfen oder Koffer abwerfen, mit einchecken, irgendwie nie so ein großer Unterschied.
Doch, wenn du mit EasyJet fliegst, dann ist...
EasyJet ist halt auch...
Die Zeiträume sind andere. Also man kann viel knapper vorher, ich kann halt eine halbe Stunde vorher da sein.
Ja, aber nicht wenn du in München zum Beispiel zum Flughafen oder vom Flughafen weg willst.
Ich sag nur, es ist besser geworden, das kann man glaube ich kaum bestreiten. Also Fliegen ist einfacher geworden, Busfahren ist einfacher geworden, alles ist einfacher geworden. Teilweise geht das halt auch für die Bahn, aber ich erwarte halt auch bei so einem Premium-Ticket wie BahnCard 100, was ja im Prinzip sagt mit hier, wir geben euch ein Jahr vorher das Geld. Das könnt ihr schonmal auf die Bank legen. Das ist ja jetzt auch kein...
Stimmt, das ist auch kein Abo, ne? Sondern du musst auf dem Block teilen.
Das gibt es auch als Abo, aber dann ist es noch ein bisschen teurer.
Natürlich.
Ja, dann...
Das BahnCard 100 als Abo ist teurer, als wenn du es nur für ein Jahr nimmst.
Ja klar, wenn du Upfront zahlst, dann gibst du ihnen ja das ganze Geld vorher schon. Das ist natürlich dann günstiger, als wenn du es monatlich zahlst.
Ja okay, ich dachte mit Abo jetzt, dass es nach einem Jahr verlängert wird.
Geht halt auch nur bei dieser monatsbasierten Geschichte. Ja, nee, ich... Aber was mir am meisten stört, ist, dass man einfach sozusagen nicht so als Premiumkunde so richtig wahrgenommen wird. Klar, sie haben halt da so ihre Laute.
Du hast eine Bahncard 100, du bist voll der Spararsch. Du bist doch da kein Premiumkunde. Du zahlst am Ende weniger als einer, der 50 Mal den Normalpreis hinlegen würde. Du bist da der Arbeiterhong, der fahren muss.
Ja, ich bin für die gesicherte Einnahme. Die müssen keine Serviceeinheiten bereitstellen. Also sehe ich nicht so.
Ja, das war auch jetzt sehr ironisch, aber... Ja, die Bahn, ich glaube, die hat schon noch schwer zu kämpfen jetzt mit der ganzen Busgeschichte und so. Und dem Internet, dem Service, der da in der Bahn fehlt. Dabei ist es ja schon ganz schön schade. Du hast so viel Zeit da im Zug. Und kannst im Gegensatz zum Auto da irgendwie machen und tun. Und dann kannst du doch nicht, weil... Weil Bücher lesen kann ja keiner mehr.
So, jetzt setzen wir dem Ganzen ein Ende hier. Freak Show, der 164. Schön, dass ihr bei uns wart. Und in zwei Wochen geht es wieder weiter.
Ja, das ist MS-DOS Manfred. Er hat's nicht so mit Menschen, aber besitzt den einzigen Personalkomputer im Großraum Köln. Personalkomputer sind sowas wie sehr komplizierte Taschenrechner, an die ein Röhrenmonitor und eine Schreibmaschine angeschlossen sind. Ja, das ist MS-DOS Manfred. Zuerst schaltet Manfred seinen 286er an. Er ist sehr stolz auf das Gerät, denn es war sehr, sehr teuer. Zeit genug, um schon mal den Nadeldrucker mit der selbst eingebauten Schnittstelle zu verbinden und die 40 Installationsdisketten für das Grafikprogramm zu sortieren, das er in monatelanger Nachtarbeit selber programmiert hat. Jetzt noch den Prozessor in den BIOS-Einstellungen übertakt'n, um seinen 286er zu grafischen Höchstleistungen zu peitschen. Gleich geht's los. Mit dem BIOS kennt sich Manfred leider gar nicht aus. Darum braucht er die Hilfe einer lebenden Computerlegende. Die Rede ist von BIOS Bernhardt. Die zwei Experten übertakt'n den Prozessor. Der Computer läuft, doch jetzt muss MS-DOS-Manfred noch über die Eingabe-Aufforderung, die DOS Shell Excel bearbeiten, damit sein Grafikprogramm läuft und er in der Lage ist, per Computer das Bild eines echten Menschen auf Papier zu drucken. Oh nein, BIOS Bernhardt bemerk'nen Anstieg der Prozessortemperatur. Hat sich wohl ne Wollmaus im Netzteil Lüfter verfangen? Scheiße, einen Blick ins Gehäuse bestätigt den Verdacht, die Hauptplatine ist wohl endgültig im Arsch. Wir brauchen Ersatzteile und das ist ein klarer Fall für Hardware-Hans-Peter. Manfred, BIOS Bernhardt und Hardware-Hans-Peter schrauben seit 53 Stunden am 286er. Zum Glück befindet sich keiner von ihnen zurzeit in einer festen Beziehung und es hätte sicherlich längst jemand den Ausschalter auf der Steckerleiste gedrückt. Nach Neueinbau der Hauptplatine kurz noch die Festplatte in den Slave-Modus geswitcht und ne DOS-Neuinstallation. Hurra, jetzt ist der Computer endlich heile. Ah, Mist, nur die Grafikkarte hat einen Wackelkontakt. Da kann eigentlich nur noch einer helfen. Denn kein anderer in Mitteleuropa repariert Wackelkontakte wie er. Er ist Lötkolgen Ludwig. Fünf Lötzen rollen später, läuft alles wieder. Gluck, gluck, gluck, gluck, gluck, lecker Filter-Café. MS-DOS-Manfred programmiert sein Programm. Jetzt noch die Print-Taste drücken und dann wird's ernst. MS-DOS-Manfred. Lötkolben-Ludwig, MS-DOS-Manfred, BIOS-Bernhardt und Hardware-Hans-Peter schauen gespannt auf Manfreds Nadel-Drucker. Nach bangen Minuten ist es dann soweit. Das Endlost-Papier bewegt sich. Die Druckernadel bewegt sich. Haha, er druckt! Er hat's geschafft! Er hat's endlich geschafft nach nur 15 Tagen! Ein Bild wird gedruckt.